SO I WILL GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE WEDNESDAY JANUARY 24TH
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER AND TO START LET ME ASK
OUR SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. LAIRD HERE, KOBO SMALLWOOD
. KRAVIS QUIVERS HERE. GROVE
GROVE. HERE ATKINS HERE. ATKINS
HERE. CORN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT.
WELCOME EVERYONE, AND WE DO
ANTICIPATE A FOUR COMMITTEE
TODAY, SO I KNOW THAT SENATOR
ALCOA BOG WILL BE HERE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED AND BEFORE WE GET INTO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR, I'M GOING TO SEE IF
WE CAN DISPENSE WITH SOME ITEMS
FAIRLY QUICKLY. WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER TWO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR. AH AND
THESE ARE APPOINTMENTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION AND STATE
FAIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS TO F AND
G. DO I NEED TO SEPARATE THOSE
OUT, OKAY? SEEING. AH NO
INDICATION TO SEPARATE. I WOULD
CALL FOR A MOTION ON ITEMS TO F
AND G. THANK YOU, MADAM VICE
CHAIR. MADAM SECRETARY, WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? LAYERED I
OCHOA BUG GUYS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
! QUICK ASIDE, GROVE GROVE I.
ATKINS ATKINS DIET FIVE TO 05 TO
ZERO. THANK YOU. WE WILL TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER THREE BILL REFERRALS
THAT'S REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEES. EMOTION THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THERE'D DIÆN BOG TROUBLED. I
SMALLWOOD CREVASSE. SMALL
EQUIVALENCY GROVE GROVE. I
ATKINS ATKINS I FIVE TO 05 TO
ZERO. THANK YOU. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR IS OUR 2024 SENATE HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE. VERY IMPORTANT. UH
THANK YOU, MADAM. VICE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. LAIRD BIOKO, BORG GUYS.
SMALL EQUIVALENCE. SMALLWOOD
CLEVER SEAGROVE. GROVE I. ATKINS
FIVE TO 05 TO ZERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY ITEMS FIVE
THROUGH NINE OR FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT REQUESTS FROM
OUR COLLEAGUES TO RECOGNIZE
GROUPS AND INDIVIDUALS AS PART
OF OUR SESSION SCHEDULE, I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR ITEMS
FIVE THROUGH NINE. THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY, WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL? LAIRD COBURG PATROL GUY,
SMALL EQUIVALENTS. OVERSIGHT
GROWTH. ATKINS I FIVE TO 05 TO
ZERO. WONDERFUL WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH QUITE A LOT. SO
NOW I WILL START WITH OUR FIRST
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AND LET ME INVITE
HARRY LEGRAND AND MARY SALUS UP
TO THE TABLE IN FRONT. THESE ARE
APPOINTMENTS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COLLEGES BOARD
OF GOVERNORS. LET ME SAY WELCOME
TO BOTH OF YOU. AND, OF COURSE,
UH, IT'S SO GOOD TO HAVE YOU
BACK. UH I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
CALL YOU, FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S FORMER MAYOR.
GOOD FRIEND. IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU, UM MARY UM, BUT I WILL
INVITE YOU TO DO IS, UH WHY
DON'T WE START WITH YOU, HARRY?
AND HAVE YOU SORRY, MR LEGRAND?
HARRY'S FINE. THANK YOU, UM,
TRYING TO WORK ON THE DECORUM
HERE. ESPECIALLY TODAY. SINCE
THIS IS MY LAST SESSION AS RULES
CHAIR I WELCOME YOU INVITE YOU
TO MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS YOU
WANT ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE? AND THEN AFTER YOU
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS WILL GO RIGHT
TO THE HONORABLE MISS ALLISON
ASKED HER TO MAKE COMMENTS
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE SHE WANTS,
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM HERE AND SENATE
MEMBERS. I'M HARRY LEGRAND. IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY AND
REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE BEEN
SELECTED TO SERVE IN THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE. I'M JOINED TODAY
BY MY WIFE OF 46 YEARS, DENISE
LEGRAND. THANK YOU. SO WE'RE
HIDING. AND ALSO, UM, TWO OF MY
AMAZING COUSINS, DR CALVIN
WHEELER AND SARAH JANE WHEELER,
AND I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
THEIR SUPPORT. TODAY THEY'RE
SITTING BEHIND ME. I HAVE BEEN
IN HIGHER EDUCATION SINCE
GRADUATING FROM UC IRVINE IN
1975. I SPENT THE LAST 35 YEARS
OF WORK AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, BERKELEY. I WORK IN
STUDENT HOUSING FROM 1975 UNTIL
2007. I SERVED AS VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR STUDENT AFFAIRS
FROM 2007 UNTIL I WRITE UNTIL I
RETIRED IN 2016. SINCE RETIRING.
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF SERVING
AS INTERIM VICE PRESIDENT OF
STUDENT AFFAIRS HAD THREE CS
USED AND ONE PRIVATE SCHOOL.
KELL ARTS. I'VE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OVER THE PAST 10 MONTHS SINCE MY
APPOINTMENT, AND I CAN SEE THE
IMPACT AND ROLES THAT ARE CLOSER
TO MILLION STUDENTS CAN HAVE ON
THE ECONOMY OF OUR STATE. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WELCOME TO YOUR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WERE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
HERE TODAY. MS SALUS? YES, UM
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SENATOR
ATKINS AND ALL THE OTHER
SENATORS, IT REALLY IS A
PRIVILEGE FOR ME TO BE HERE MANY
TIMES. PEOPLE ASK ME, WHY WOULD
YOU WANT TO JOIN A BOARD? THAT'S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF HARD WORK
AFTER RETIREMENT, AND I HAVE TO
TELL THEM THAT I WOULDN'T BE
HERE EXCEPT FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SO IF YOU DON'T KNOW
MY BACKGROUND AND MY STORY UM, I
WAS MARRIED AT A VERY, VERY
YOUNG AGE. I WAS A PREGNANT
TEENAGER, AND WHEN I FOUND
MYSELF IN A SITUATION WHERE I
WAS BEING DIVORCED AND HAD TWO
CHILDREN TO RAISE I REALLY,
REALLY HIT ME HARD. BUT I HAD TO
TAKE STOCK OF MY LIFE AND SEE
WHAT I WANTED THE FUTURE OF MY
CHILDREN TO LOOK LIKE I WANTED
THE FUTURE OF MY CHILDREN TO
HAVE A MOTHER THAT WAS A ROLE
MODEL TO THEM. I WANT THE TO
HAVE A FUTURE WHERE I COULD
PROVIDE FOR THEM IN DIGNITY. AND
SO I WAS A COLLEGE FRESHMAN AT
37 YEARS OLD. AND MY FIRST ENTRY
WAS INTO SOUTHWESTERN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. HAD NOT THE COLLEGE
BEEN THERE. I KNOW I WOULDN'T
HAVE EVENTUALLY TRANSFERRED TO
STS YOU WHERE I EVENTUALLY GOT A
DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK. UM AND I
GRADUATED MAGNA CUM LOUD. I MET
SO MANY PEOPLE IN THAT JOURNEY
THAT WERE MY MENTORS AND THAT
WE'RE PUSHING ME ALONG AND HAD
FAITH IN ME. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
SO PASSIONATE ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE I
KNOW FIRSTHAND HOW THE
INSTRUCTORS HOW THE COLLAGEN
STRUCTURE AND STRUCTURES ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL REALLY
LOOK AFTER THEIR STUDENTS AND
ARE THERE FOR THEM. UM MY
SERVICE FOR ALMOST A YEAR NOW ON
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BOARD
OF GOVERNORS. HAS EVEN SPARKED
MORE OF A PASSION FOR ME TO
SERVE IN THAT CAPACITY, SEEING
WHAT THE ORGANIZATION IS DOING,
SEEING ALL THE NEW INITIATIVES
THAT ARE BEING DRIVEN TO FOCUS
ON STUDENTS. IN THEIR NEW MANNER
OF LEARNING, AND WE DO HAVE TO
CHANGE OUR MANNER OF LEARNING.
WE HAVE TO MOVE ON TO TECHNOLOGY
JUST AS THEY HAVE AND SO I'M
READY TO SERVE AND I REALLY AM
HUMBLED AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND START
WITH MADAM VICE CHAIR AS SHE'S
GETTING SETTLED AND SEE IF HE'LL
KICK US OFF. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRO TIM. THANK YOU, BOTH OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE. I APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH. UM, I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. I KNOW WE
TRY TO LIMIT OUR QUESTIONS
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE THAT WANT TO
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSE AND
THEY WANT THEIR TIME AS WELL. UM
AYE. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
HAVE IS OBVIOUSLY SINCE OCTOBER
7TH. THIS HAS BEEN A HOT SUBJECT
ITEM ON OUR COMMUNITY, COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND OUR UCS NRC SUS THE
HAMAS TERROR ATTACKS AGAINST
ISRAEL. JEWISH STUDENTS, UM THEY
FEEL BASED ON THE ARTICLES THAT
I'VE READ THAT THEY ARE
THREATENED, AND THEY DON'T HAVE
A SAFE PLACE TO COME TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR ARE YOU
SEE SYSTEMS? SO UM, THERE'S A
CONCERNING TREND THAT JEWISH
STUDENTS ARE PLEADING FOR
COLLEGE LEADERS TO DO SOMETHING.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT YOU GUYS
HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED? THAT
YOU INTEND TO IMPLEMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR JEWISH STUDENTS
ARE SAFE AND THAT THEY CAN
PURSUE THE EDUCATION THAT THEY
HAVE CHOSEN TO PURSUE. IT CAN GO
TO BOTH OF YOU, OKAY? I'LL TRY
TO TAKE A STAB AT IT BECAUSE
THERE'S 73 DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
RIGHT THAT IMPLEMENT THEIR OWN.
POLICIES AND SO, UM, I'M SURE
THAT THEY ARE EXPLORING THESE
SITUATIONS. I KNOW FROM A
STANDPOINT OF AT LEAST A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CLOSEST TO ME
SOUTHWESTERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THAT WE WANT TO CAMPUS AS I'M
SURE ALL THE CHANCELLOR'S DO
THEY WANT TO CAMPUS THAT'S SAFE
FOR ALL STUDENTS, WHETHER YOU'RE
JEWISH OR YOUR PALESTINE,
PALESTINIAN IT SHOULD BE SAFE
FOR EVERYONE. WHETHER YOU'RE
BLACK, WHETHER YOU'RE WHITE THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD BE WELCOMED INTO
THAT SPACE AND THAT NOT ONLY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SPACES, BUT
OUR UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS K
THROUGH 12. THERE HAS TO BE AN
OPEN DISCUSSION OF TOLERANCE AND
LOOK AT HISTORY OF HOW WE GOT
HERE. AND UM, THAT THE HOPE AND
THE CONTINUING HOPE THAT
HUMANITY WILL RISE TO A LEVEL AT
SOME POINT IN TIME. WHERE WE
FEEL THAT IT'S ALL ABOUT
ACCEPTANCE AND LOVE OF OTHERS
KNOWING THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES RIGHT AND THE
ATMOSPHERE AND COUNTRY TODAY IS
REALLY APPALLING TO ME THAT WE
CAN'T HAVE A DISCUSSION THAT WE
CAN'T EXERCISE OUR FREE SPEECH
ON ANY MANNER. UM WITHOUT THE
FEAR OF BEING ATTACKED, AND I'M
TALKING ON THE LIBERAL SIDE AND
ON THE CONSERVATIVE SIDE AS
WELL. WHEN I SEE STUDENTS AT UC
CAMPUSES THAT SHUT DOWN A
SPEAKER BECAUSE THEY'RE OPPOSED
TO THEIR VIEW. TO ME, THEY'RE
LIMITING THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ON EITHER SIDE, RIGHT?
BECAUSE NOBODY IS 100% RIGHT AND
NOBODY IS 100% WRONG AND WE HAVE
TO COME TO BED TOGETHER. WE'RE
BETTER HUMAN BEINGS IN THAT, AND
I BELIEVE THAT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE PLACE TO START.
BECAUSE WE ARE SO DIVERSE AND WE
HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT STUDENTS
HAVE VERY MANY DIFFERENT FAITHS.
THANK YOU, MA'AM. MR LEGRAND.
ADD THAT OUR CHANCELLOR AS WELL
AS OUR BORDER, VERY COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THERE'S A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL OF US
STUDENTS ON THE CAMPUS, AND I
THINK MUCH AS MEMBERS. SALAS HAS
SAID THAT WITH THE 72 DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS AND 116 CAMPUSES, IT'S
HARD TO MANAGE THAT. BUT I THINK
AS BOARD MEMBERS ARE ROLE IS
DESCENT. SET THE STANDARD AND
SET THE TONE FOR THAT, AND WE
CAN DO THAT BY EITHER POLICY
DIRECTION OR WORKING WITH THE
CHANCELLOR TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COLLEGE PRESIDENTS ARE AWARE OF
THE NEEDS TO BE OPEN, HAVING
BEEN ON BERKELEY'S CAMPUS FOR 35
YEARS. PROTESTS ARE NOT UNUSUAL
FOR ME, AND I'VE KIND OF LIVED
THROUGH ALL OF THAT, AND I JUST
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO FOR
STUDENTS TO HAVE A VOICE TO
SPEAK OUT. I THINK THAT, UM IT'S
NOT IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
UNITED STATES OR ANY OF US TO
LIMIT FREEDOM OF SPEECH. WE
ACTUALLY DO NEED TO HAVE ALL THE
VOICES AT THE TABLE AND TRYING
TO RESOLVE THAT, AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE SITUATION
HAS GOTTEN TO THE POINT WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE MIDDLE
EAST THAT IT'S MADE THE
INTOLERANCE BECAUSE EVEN THAT'S
MORE MUCH MORE EXACERBATED HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES, BUT I
THINK OUR ROLE IS TO BE
COMMITTED TO A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR STUDENTS SO THEY COULD LEARN
AND THAT OUR FACULTY AND STAFF
HAVE A HAVE A FREE AND A SAFE
PLACE TO WORK AS WELL. THANK YOU
. THE OTHER QUESTION THAT I HAD
TO ACTUALLY THE DATA. THERE'S
DATA OUT THERE THAT SUGGESTS
THAT 20% OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE APPLICANTS ARE
REALLY FAKE STUDENTS TRYING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE FINANCIAL
AID. HAVE YOU GUYS BEEN
ADDRESSING THAT? IS THERE SOME
PROGRAM THAT YOU HAVE IN PLACE
TO TRY TO STOP THAT? OR ARE YOU
AWARE OF THAT? WHAT TO TELL YOU
THE TRUTH. I AM NOT AWARE OF
THAT. NOR HAVE I HEARD THAT.
THAT IS A FACT. UM CERTAINLY
I'LL GO BACK AND TRY TO, YOU
KNOW, DIG SOME MORE TO SEE. YOU
KNOW WHAT'S BEHIND THAT?
ABSOLUTELY AND IF YOU JUST
FOLLOW UP WITH ME, I REALLY I
SURE WOULD. THANK YOU BOTH THE
SAME QUESTION. SAME ANSWER. YES.
AND THEN MY LAST QUESTION IS
THAT YOU KNOW, IN THE REAL
WORLD. I'M A BUSINESS OWNER. WE
ALL BRING OUR LIVED EXPERIENCES
HERE TO THIS LEGISLATOR.
LEGISLATIVE BODY. I DIDN'T GO TO
COLLEGE. I DON'T HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE, BUT I STARTED A
BUSINESS. IT'S BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR 30 YEARS AND A LOT OF TIMES
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT COME FROM
OUR COMMUNITY. COLLEGE
INDIVIDUALS LOOKING FOR A JOB
AND THERE IS A SEVERE DISCONNECT
TO WHAT WE NEED IN THE IN THE
WORLD OF EMPLOYMENT TO WHAT IS
EDUCATED OR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OR COLLEGES. AND SO HAS THERE
BEEN, UM, LIKE, I DON'T KNOW, A
REACHING OUT OF THE COMMUNITY
AND LIKE CTE PROGRAMS AND HOW
BEST TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT ONCE THESE STUDENTS FINISH
A COLLEGE EDUCATION THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO RIGHT
INTO BE GAINFULLY EMPLOYED. UM
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IN I WANT TO
SAY THE REAL THE REAL WORLD ALL
THE TIME. MY COLLEAGUES GET IT.
BUT IN THE REAL WORLD, IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND SOMEBODY
WITH THAT QUALITY OF EDUCATION.
IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE, BUT IT IS
DIFFICULT AND IF THE COLLEGE WAS
GOING TO ADJUST SOME OF THEIR
CURRICULUM IF THEY SEE A NEW
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES, CARBON
CAPTURE AND MY AREA, JUST
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE COMING
ON THAT ARE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
WHERE I THINK IF THEY'RE GOING
TO BE EDUCATED ON THIS, THE
COLLEGE NEEDS TO STEP UP A
LITTLE BIT. I THINK THE MESSAGE
HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT WHEN YOU DO
A BETTER JOB OF PREPARING OUR
STUDENTS FOR THE WORKFORCE, WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT UNIT WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM NOW
THAT'S ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THAT.
REACHING OUT TO EMPLOYERS TO
FIND OUT WHAT WHAT THE GAPS ARE.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO FILL THOSE
GAPS? AND THEN TOO, I THINK, TRY
TO BE NIMBLE ENOUGH TO MAKE
THOSE KIND OF CHANGES. I WOULD
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE GOOD
THINGS ABOUT THE CAL BRIGHT
SYSTEM BEING AS NEW AS IT IS.
AND NOT, YOU KNOW, UH, IN SOME
WAYS, UM, UH, ENCUMBERED BY KIND
OF THE TRADITIONAL SENSE OF
DOING THAT KIND OF WORK, BUT
THEY CAN BE VERY, VERY FLEXIBLE
AND I KNOW THEY HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN OUT MEETING WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND BUSINESS OWNERS TO
FIND OUT HOW WE CAN BEST ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS, BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY WELL
AWARE OF AND KNOW THAT, LIKE I
SAID, WITH ALMOST 2 MILLION
STUDENTS WE ARE THE ECONOMIC
ENGINE FOR CALIFORNIA INTO OUR
STUDENTS NEED TO BE PREPARED TO
TAKE THOSE JOBS. AND JUST
BECAUSE YOU MR LEGRAND MENTIONED
CAL BRIGHT, YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT
WAS THE FIASCO LOCATION OF WORK
OUT BRIGHT AND BIT WISE KIND OF
HAD THAT COLLAPSE. AND SO I
WOULD. I WOULD HOPE THAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THAT EVERY EVERY
BUSINESS EVERY BUSINESS VENTURE.
EVERY NEW STARTUP HAS FAILURES.
AND I'M NOT JUDGING THIS FAILURE
. I'M JUST SAYING, I HOPE WE
HAVE LEARNED FROM THAT
PARTICULAR FAILURE. IN THAT, BUT
YES, MA'AM, SO I THINK WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM THAT FAILURE AND I
THINK THAT WE'VE REALLY
ADDRESSED A LOT OF THE INITIAL
CONCERNS AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'M REALLY KEEN ON IS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MANY YEARS
AGO, UM I WAS APPOINTED TO
CALIFORNIA TRADING COMMERCE
AGENCY. THAT IS IT. IT'S NOT
HERE ANYMORE. BUT I WAS WORKING
IN THE AREAS OF IMPERIAL COUNTY,
SAN DIEGO AND ORANGE COUNTY, AND
THAT'S WE HEARD IT BACK THEN
THAT THERE WAS A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN EDUCATION AND WHAT WAS
NEEDED IN THE WORK FORCE
CONSTANTLY, BUT I KNOW OF REALLY
GOOD PROGRAMS NOW, FOR EXAMPLE,
IMPERIAL VALLEY COLLEGE THAT IS
REALLY DOING TECHNICAL TRAINING
FOR ALL THESE PEOPLE IN THE NEW
INDUSTRY OF GEOTHERMAL MINING
FOR LITHIUM AND OTHER PRECIOUS
MINERALS, WHICH IS REALLY GOING
TO CREATE A LOT OF JOBS THERE.
FOR A POPULATION THAT IS REALLY
THAT HISTORICALLY HAS ABOUT HAS
HAD ABOUT A 30% UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE. AND SO THE JOBS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, TO BE
TRAINED FOR AND HAVE A GOOD,
LIVABLE WAGE THAT SUPPORTS THEIR
FAMILIES. THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AND FUND ARE
THOSE THAT HAVE A DIRECT
CONNECTION. TO THE NEW
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
ALWAYS, UM, ORIGINATING FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, RIGHT? AND
IF WE DON'T KEEP UP WITH THAT
DEMAND AND EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS
WERE GOING TO FALL FROM BEING
THE FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD, AND I DON'T WANT TO
SEE THAT. UM I WANT TO SEE THAT
CALIFORNIA THRIVES FOR EVERYONE.
AND SO IT'S FOCUSING ON THOSE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SEE RESULTS. AND YOU
CAN SEE SOMEBODY GO TO WORK AND
EARN A LOT OF MONEY AFTER TWO
YEARS. I THINK THAT'S GREAT IF
THEY GO ON TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY AND BECOME THOSE
ENGINEERS AND THOSE DEVELOPERS
OF THOSE INDUSTRIES THAT'S EVEN
BETTER. THANK YOU, MA'AM. THANK
BOTH OF YOU. I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU,
MADAM. THANK YOU, MADAM VICE
CHAIR. LET ME TURN TO SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CREVICE AND ASK YOU TO
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE. I AM
FIGHTING THIS BUG, BUT I WAS
EXCITED TO BE HERE, ESPECIALLY
WITH THE PROTEIN BEING HEARD
LAST SESSION, BUT OF COURSE FOR
YOUR NOMINATION PROCESS TODAY.
REALLY EXCITED TO HEAR YOUR
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS VARY
INSPIRING, AND I WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP ON A QUESTION. THAT MY
COLLEAGUE LIFTED UP ABOUT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. YOU YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE WAYS IN WHICH
YOU ARE TRACKING THE NEW ECONOMY
, THE CLIMATE, RESILIENT ECONOMY
AND TRYING TO CONNECT THE CAMPUS
CURRICULUM AND STUDENTS TO THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. HOW DO THOSE
GREEN EMPLOYERS PLUG IN TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM? AND
WHAT WAYS DO YOU ENGAGE THE
ACTUAL BUSINESSES THAT ARE OUT
OF THE SORT OF THE GREEN SECTOR?
I JUST HAD? I WAS CURIOUS AS THE
FOLLOW UP TO YOU, MS. SALAS.
YOUR RESPONSE? WELL I CAN SPEAK
TO THE EXPERIENCE OF WHAT I KNOW
. IN IN SAN DIEGO AND THE AND
THE OUTREACH AND THE INVOLVEMENT
OF BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS,
THE PARTICIPATION OF CDCS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COUNCILS
AND CHAMBERS. UM AND THERE'S A
CROSS POLLINATION, SO OTHERS
REPRESENTATION OF EDUCATION ON
THOSE BOARDS AND LIKEWISE.
THERE'S A FOCUS GROUPS FROM THE
INDUSTRY THAT ALSO REPORT TO THE
COLLEGE THAT WORK WITH THE
COLLEGE TO TRY TO DEVELOP THESE
THINGS. UM WE HAD A VERY STRONG,
UH, MEXICO COMPONENT AND WHAT
THEY WERE DOING AT THE TIME IS
WORKING WITH THE MAQUILADORAS
AND THE SOUTH IN IN TIJUANA. IT
WAS A GREAT IT STILL IS. AH A
GREAT JOB HUB THAT IS REALLY
LIFTED THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR A
LOT OF MEXICAN CITY SINCE ON
THAT SIDE, BUT WE DO THE R AND D
ON OUR SIDE AND YOU DO THAT
BASED MANUFACTURING OVER THERE.
AND SO IT'S THAT COORDINATION
WITH WITH THE TWO COUNTRIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
DEVELOPING THOSE PROGRAMS AND
CREATING A PIPELINE. OF THOSE OF
THOSE R AND D PEOPLE AS WELL AS
TRAINING THE OTHER WORKERS IT
USED TO BE WHERE THEY WERE DOING
SIMPLE ASSEMBLY OVER THERE, AND
NOW THEY'RE DOING MORE COMPLEX
THINGS. THEY'RE BUILDING
AUTOMOBILES OVER THERE. AND YOU
MAY SAY, WELL, THAT MAY BE A JOB
LOSS. BUT WE NEED WORKERS HERE.
WE HAVE A DEARTH OF WORKERS HERE
AND IF WE CAN'T PROVIDE THOSE
WORKERS WITHOUT THE TECHNICAL
TRAINING THAT THAT THAT THAT
ACCOMMODATES IS GOING TO
CONTINUE. I DON'T KNOW IF I FAST
ANSWER TO QUESTION NO, I
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS GROUPS AND
THE DIFFERENT COUNCILS THAT
BRING EMPLOYERS TOGETHER. AND
I'M CURIOUS WOULD LOVE TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT HOW YOU'RE TARGETING
THOSE EMPLOYERS AND BUSINESSES
THAT ARE STARTING TO EMERGE AND
GROW AS PART OF THE GREEN
ECONOMY. I'LL GO TO MY NEXT
QUESTION, WHICH YOU KNOW, IN MY
UNFORTUNATELY IN MY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT, WE SEE A LOT
OF HOMELESSNESS AMONG STUDENTS
WE HAVE ABOUT 62% OF OUR
STUDENTS, WHO ARE ALSO FOOD
INSECURE ABOUT 19% WHO ARE
HOMELESS, AND, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE DONE AT THE AT
THE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL, ALL THAT
WE CAN GIVEN OUR BUDGET TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT IS HOUSED. I'M
JUST CURIOUS. WHAT ARE THE WAYS
THAT YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS
AMONGST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS? UM I KNOW WE'VE
APPROVED FUNDING FOR SOME OF THE
MORE RURAL CAMPUSES TO ACTUALLY
BUILD HOUSING AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I'M MOST CURIOUS ABOUT IS
HOW YOU THINK ABOUT HOW THOSE
DOLLARS WILL BE USED. MOVING
FORWARD IN TERMS OF NOT JUST
PROVIDING THE HOUSING ITSELF FOR
STUDENTS, BUT ALSO IT BEING A
JOB CREATION OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LOWER INCOME DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS WHO MAY ATTEND THE
COLLEGE TO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD. HAVE YOU
LOOKED AT THE IDEA OF
INCORPORATING A SKILL AND TRAIN
MODEL THAT ALLOWS THE CAMPUSES
TO BUILD THE HOUSING BUT ALSO TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
RESIDENTS. THE STUDENTS, UM TO
GROW IN THAT PARTICULAR SECTOR
AND OCCUPATION. I'LL START I'LL
TAKE A STAB AT IT. I THINK THAT
I WILL SAY THAT WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DID PUT MONEY INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PLANNING. I THINK WHAT I
SAID ON THE SUIT STUDENT, THE
STUDENT THAT STUDENT AID
COMMISSION ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WAS ALWAYS CONCERNED WITH
WAS IN CALIFORNIA. THE COST OF
HOUSING WAS REALLY THE BIG DEBT,
UM, REASON FOR STUDENTS BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO BORROW A LOT OF
MONEY TO PAY FOR THE RENTS THAT
ARE LOCALLY AND HAVING BUILT A
LOT OF HOUSING MYSELF. I KNOW
THAT THAT DEVELOPERS DON'T
REDUCED BY COST BECAUSE I'M
BUILDING STUDENT HOUSING. SO I
DO THINK THAT BY THE STATE DOING
THAT, AND I JUST VISITED SANTA
ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGES, RIBBON
CUTTING TO SEE THERE PARTNERSHIP
WITH NOT ONLY THE MONEY THAT THE
STATE PROVIDED BUT ALSO PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY THAT CAME CAME IN
TO HELP THAT PROJECT BECOME THE
FRUITION AND REALLY, I COULD SEE
HOW IT WAS REALLY ABLE TO KEEP
THE COST OF RENTS DOWN FOR THOSE
STUDENTS. AND SO I THINK THAT'S
A GOOD MODEL TO KIND OF TAKE A
LOOK AT AS WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS FROM A
TRAINING DEVELOPMENT. UH WHAT I
KNOW IS THAT STUDENTS GET A LOT
OF ON THE JOB EXPERIENCE BY
WORKING IN STUDENT HOUSING,
BECAUSE THERE ARE LOTS OF JOBS
THAT ARE THERE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY DO. PICK UP SKILL SETS
THAT THEY CAN USE LATER. I MEAN,
THAT'S KIND OF HOW I GOT MY
START OFF AS AN R A. WHEN I WAS
AT IRVINE AND THEN WENT ON TO
DOING STUFF THAT I NEVER THOUGHT
I'D I'D DO RIGHT OR BE, AND SO I
DO THINK IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO PICK UP
SKILLS THAT ARE, I WOULD SAY,
MAYBE YOUR SOFT SKILLS THAT MAY
NOT BE TECHNICAL. WHAT ARE THE
KIND OF THINGS THAT EMPLOYERS
ARE LOOKING FOR? I KNOW MANY
TIMES I HAD EMPLOYERS CALLING ME
ASKING ME. CAN YOU GIVE ME THE
LIST OF TIARAS AND I'M LIKE,
WELL, WHY? WELL BECAUSE THEY
KNOW HOW TO TEAM BUILDING OR TO
WORK IN GROUPS. THEY KNOW HOW TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS, AND THOSE ARE
THE KIND OF THINGS WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TIME TO TEACH
PEOPLE, BUT WE EXPECT THEM TO
HAVE THOSE SKILLS SETS WHEN THEY
COME TO WORK FOR US. AND SO I DO
THINK ON CAMPUS HOUSING OR
HOUSING PROVIDED BY THE COLLEGE
ALLOWS THINGS THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR ADDITIONAL GROWTH. I DON'T
KNOW IF WE'VE SPOKEN
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT LOOKING AT IT
FROM A TRAINING. PERSPECTIVE BUT
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
TAKE BACK TO THE BOARD AND
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT HOW WE MIGHT
WORK WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AROUND
THE STATE TO DO THAT. AND WE CAN
BUILD THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
NOT ONLY THE DEVELOPERS BUT ALSO
WITH THE BUILDING TRADE TO
COOPERATE, COOPERATE TOO,
BECAUSE THEY NEED THAT THE
BUILDING COMMUNITY ALSO NEEDS A
PIPELINE OF SKILLED WORKERS AS
WELL. AND THOSE ARE GOOD PAYING
JOBS AS WELL. SO I THINK THAT'S
GREAT. THAT THE STUDENTS OF
TODAY THE NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS ARE FACING SO MANY
HARDSHIPS. NOT ONLY IS IT THAT
HOUSING INSECURITY, BUT IT'S A
FOOD INSECURITY IN THE COST OF
TRANSPORTATION. THOSE ARE REALLY
THE DRIVERS OF EXPENSES THAT
CAUSE NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS TO
DROP OUT OF COLLEGE. IT'S NOT
THE TUITION COST. IT'S NOT THE
BOOK COST. THEY CAN MANAGE THAT
WITH HELP, BUT IT'S EVERYTHING
ELSE, ALL THE OTHER PRESSURES
THAT THEY HAVE IN THEIR LIVES
THAT THEY HAVE TO WORK, AND SOME
OF THEM ARE WORKING MORE THAN
ONE JOB, BUT CERTAINLY THAT
HOUSING INSECURITY IS I THINK
THE NUMBER ONE THING AND I, TOO
THINK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
FUNDING THAT AND I KNOW THAT SAN
DIEGO HAS BEEN A GREAT RECIPIENT
OF SOME OF THAT FUNDING, AND
WE'RE READY TO BUILD. AND WE'RE
WILLING TO BUILD AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO BUILD. UM WHILE
OFFERING THOSE THOSE TECHNICAL
AND THOSE CAREER OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OUR STUDENTS APPRECIATE THAT
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU WANTED AND EXPLORING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO MULTIPLY THOSE
RESOURCES. UM, I THINK YOU HAVE
AMAZING CONSTRUCTION PROGRAMS. I
KNOW WE HAVE A PHENOMENAL ONE AT
TRADE TECH COLLEGE, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHERE WE CERTAINLY NEED HOUSING
FOR SURE IN LOS ANGELES, BUT TO
BE ABLE TO TRAIN AND LEARN AND
EARN AND BE CERTIFIED BUILDING
YOUR COMMUNITY, COLLEGE AND
HOUSING COULD BE AN
EXTRAORDINARY OPPORTUNITY. SO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THAT. MY LAST QUESTION HAS TO
DO WITH BLACK STUDENT
PERFORMANCE AND SPOKE EARLIER
JUST ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE
CAMPUS PROVIDES THE MOST. AH THE
SAFEST AND MOST PRODUCTIVE SPACE
FOR STUDENTS OF ALL KINDS. AND I
KNOW THAT TWO THIRDS OF BLACK
STUDENTS ATTEND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, WHICH IS PHENOMENAL,
BUT THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL TRANSFER RATES, AND
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT RATE THAT WE
TRACK TO SEE THE EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS.
ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS
ONLY 35% OF BLACK STUDENTS
TRANSFER AND USUALLY IT'S WITHIN
SIX YEARS AND THAT'S ABOUT 10
POINTS LOWER THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. AND SO I WONDER
WHAT IS DRIVING THAT DISPARITY.
AND WHAT DO YOU SEE THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS DOING TO ADDRESS IT?
WELL I GET AGAIN. I THINK THAT
MUCH OF THAT IS A QUESTION OF
ECONOMICS. OKAY AND UM AND THE
HISTORIC POVERTY AND, UM,
REDLINING THAT HAS OCCURRED. UH,
THAT HAS NOT OPENED THAT THOSE
TYPES OF OPPORTUNITIES TO MANY
STUDENTS. UM THAT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE SO DIVERSE AND SO
THAT'S A FOCUS OF THE COMMUNITY.
COLLEGE BOARD OF GOVERNORS IS
REALLY PROVIDING THAT EQUITY TO
LEARNING. IT'S ALL ABOUT EQUITY
RIGHT IS PROVIDING THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY CHOICES AND MANY
TIMES. UM STUDENTS ARE SO
OVERWHELMED WITH HAVING TO WORK
THAT YOU IF YOU DON'T HAVE
FLEXIBLE COLLEGE SCHEDULES, THEN
THEY'RE THEY'RE LIKELY TO DROP
OUT, AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'M EXCITED ABOUT.
WORKING WITH CAL BRIGHT IS THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WERE WERE
STARTING. WE'RE THAT WE'RE
SHOWING THEIR, UM WITH FLEXIBLE
SCHEDULES, FLEXIBLE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS, AND NOT ONLY THAT,
BUT THE TRACKING TOOLS THAT HAVE
REAL TIME TRACKING TO WHAT THE
STUDENT IS DOING. WHERE THE
STUDENT CAN ANYTIME. LOOK AT
THIS DASHBOARD AND SEE JUST
WHERE THEY'RE LACKING SPACES.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THAT THE
STUDENT IS, UH, IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR REACHING OUT TO THE
INSTRUCTOR. THE INSTRUCTOR IS
ALSO FOLLOWING THAT VERY CLOSELY
SAYING, OKAY, YOU DID NOT DO
WELL IN THESE PARTICULAR
CHAPTERS. I AM GOING TO GIVE YOU
SOME EITHER THE SAME MATERIALS
BACK TO STUDY AGAIN OR SOME
SUPPLEMENTARY MATERIALS THAT MAY
HELP YOU. UM SO THE DROP OUT
RATE IS A LOT OF THINGS, BUT I
THINK IF YOU'RE NOT MEETING THE
BASIC NEEDS OF SOMEONE FOOD
SHELTER. CLOTHING SECURITY, THEN
. EDUCATION FALLS DOWN ON THE
LIST OF PRIORITIES. AND SO
THAT'S A ROLE THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TAKEN ON MORE AND MORE
WITH THEIR FEEDING PANTRIES AND
THEIR THEIR COLLABORATIONS WITH
FOOD, BANKS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE THAT
EXTRA HELP THAT THESE STUDENTS
NEED NEEDS AND WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST COST
OF LIVING IN THE UNITED STATES.
OKAY SO IT'S NOT ABOUT PEOPLE
NOT WORKING AND BEING LAZY AND
NOT WANTING TO EARN. IT'S ABOUT
THE COST OF EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT'S GOING ON. SO WE HAVE TO
BE PART OF THAT. THAT THINKS OF
THOSE SOLUTIONS TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THEIR OTHER THAN
THEIR BASIC NEEDS, THEIR
EDUCATION THAT WILL PROVIDE THEM
THAT BETTER LIVING IN THE
FUTURE. I WOULD JUST ADD THAT I
THINK MOST OF OUR A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITY LICENSE OR KIND OF
GEOGRAPHICALLY BOUND, AND THEY
HAVE FAMILIES AND OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES AND SO THAT
MAKES THE TRANSFERRING TO A FOUR
YEAR SCHOOL SOMETIMES EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE IT MAY BE AWAY
FROM FAMILY. YOU'RE NOT A
RESPONSE FOR YOUR IMMEDIATE
FAMILY, BUT THERE MAY BE PARENTS
OR SOMEBODY ELSE THAT YOU'RE
ALSO DEALING WITH. AND SO I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO GET BETTER AT
IS ACTUALLY TALKING TO HER
STUDENTS ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
REASONS WHY YOU'RE NOT
MATRICULATING THE WAY YOU SHOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR UC AND
CSU PARTNERS WITH OUR
ARTICULATION AGREEMENTS. SEEING.
HOW CAN WE MAKE THAT PROCESS
EASIER? AND I THINK AS A MEMBER,
SALAS IS ALSO SAID THAT IT'S A
RESOURCE ISSUES SO MAKING SURE
THAT THE FINANCIAL AID IS
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE FOR WHEN YOU
MAKE THAT TRANSFER THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY FEEL COMFORTABLE AND
FEEL LIKE YOU'RE NOT LEAVING
YOUR FAMILY BEHIND WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU LEAVE. DO THAT, AND WE DO
FIND OUT THAT YOU KNOW, A
STUDENT WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DEGREE IS GOING TO MAKE
ABOUT $30,000 A YEAR MORE THAN
IF THEY JUST HAD A HIGH SCHOOL
TO COMMENT, SO SHOWING THEM THAT
THERE'S WILLIAMS. SOME BENEFIT I
A POINT OF PRIVILEGE. I'M GOING
TO HAVE BEEN INVITED TO SPEAK AT
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ASSEMBLY IN
MAY AT THEIR CLOSING, AND I
SAID, YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I
THINK WE START TOO LATE WHEN WE
START TALKING ABOUT MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THIS IS A LOW
PERFORMING UNDERREPRESENTED
SCHOOL IN SOLANO COUNTY, AND I
WAS PLEASED THAT THEY INVITED ME
AND I HAD AND THEN I WAS
APPOINTED WHAT I SAID. OH, GOD,
I CAN TAKE SOME SWAG AND REALLY
GET THEM EXCITED ABOUT KIND OF
GOING OFF TO COLLEGE IF THEY
DON'T GO TO A FOUR YEAR BUT AT
LEAST LOOKING AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND OPTION AND THEN I
THINK THAT HELPS EDUCATE THE
PARENTS ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
SUPPORT THEM AND WHAT THEY CAN
DO. TO MAKE THAT AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE CONVERSATION IN IN
THEIR FAMILIES, BECAUSE MANY
TIMES THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT BEHIND THEM TO KNOW THAT
THEY CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AND
I THINK AS THE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT IN THE FIRST OF
MY FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE, I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS FOR MY
FAMILY THAT MY PARENTS AND I DID
THIS AND THEN I MADE AWAY FROM
MY SISTER TO, YOU KNOW, TO
FOLLOW BEHIND ME, AND I JUST
THINK THAT, UM WE HAVE TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE GOING THROUGH
NOW AND HOW WE CAN ACTUALLY HELP
ADJUST OR MAKE THE TRANSITION IS
EASIER FOR THEM, UM I THINK I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT. THIS
CONVERSATION BEFORE. JUST SO THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS IS TRACKING.
THERE'S A METRICS FOR TRACKING
THIS AND IS CAL. BRIGHTER PART
OF IT. IS THAT THE STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT PIECE I'M JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S THE METRICS
FOR IT? AND HOW DO WE MEASURE
BEYOND. JUST SEEING THE NUMBERS
CHANGING. WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN TRACK TO ENSURE THAT
? YOU KNOW WE CAN REDUCE THAT
35% GAP THAT WE HAVE AND
DISPARITIES ACROSS GROUPS. I
WOULD JUST SAY, I DON'T THINK
WE'VE WE'VE DISCUSSED, AT LEAST
NOT SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE BOY.
THERE'S BEEN A SPECIFIC
CONVERSATION AROUND THAT. I KNOW
WE'RE TRACKING A LOT OF
INFORMATION. THIS IS SOMEONE OF
THINGS I THINK WE CAN TAKE BACK
AND GET SOME SPECIFIC ENTERS FOR
YOU BECAUSE WE KEPT CAPTURING A
LOT OF DATA, AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT WE'RE
DOING IT. I APPRECIATE THAT. THE
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS ARE GOING UP,
SO MAKE SURE THAT THE ACADEMIC
SUCCESS GOES ALONG WITH IT. SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO FOLLOWING UP
WITH YOU ON THAT END. GOOD LUCK
WITH YOUR NOMINATION TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. UM BEFORE
I GO TO MY NEXT COLLEAGUE, I
WOULD JUST MAKE THE NEXUS FROM
THIS COMMENT AND QUESTION TO, UM
THE ROADMAP ENVISIONED 2030
GOALS AND THE OUTCOMES OF
DIFFERENT, UM STUDENT GROUPS, SO
I HOPE THAT'S PART OF KIND OF
THAT CONVERSATION. WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT METRICS, I UNDERSTAND. SO
JUST THROW THAT IN THERE. I WAS
GOING TO ASK A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT. BUT I THINK I COULD JUST
DIRECT IT TO THAT AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET SOMETHING BACK ON HOW
YOU INTEGRATE, UM THAT SO THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION, SENATOR
ALCOA. BOGUE, PLEASE. MADAM PRO
TEM. GOOD AFTERNOON. IT'S SUCH A
PLEASURE TO SEE YOU FOLKS AGAIN.
I'M GOING TO I'M JUST GONNA PAY
YOU BACK A LITTLE BIT ON MY
COLLEAGUE'S QUESTION AS FAR AS
TRANSFERABILITY AND I JUST WANT
CLARIFICATION IS THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO TRANSFER ABILITY
FOR STUDENTS, UM GO INTO THE
COLLEGE. UM VERSUS UM IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT AND THE,
UM THE DATA THAT SHOWS HOW MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS DECIDE THAT TWO
YEARS IS ENOUGH TO GET HIM INTO
THE CAREER OR PROFESSIONS OR
WORK THAT THEY ARE WANTING TO
ATTAIN. BECAUSE THE TWO FOR TWO
YEAR COLLEGES, COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MANY AT TIMES THEY GO
THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE PROGRAMS
THAT ALLOW THEM TO GO INTO THE
WORKFORCE RIGHT AFTER COLLEGE
AFTER A TWO YEAR, UM, TWO YEAR
ENDEAVOR IN SCHOOL, UM HOPEFULLY
IT'S TWO YEARS, BUT YOU KNOW,
FIRST, DEPENDING ON THE STUDENT,
BUT IDEALLY, IT WOULD BE TWO
YEARS. SO IS THERE ALSO METRICS
IS TO MAYBE THEY WON'T GO INTO A
FOUR YEAR BUT THEY MAY BE
SUCCESSFUL IN ACHIEVING THEIR
PERSONAL GOALS, ACADEMIC GOALS
IN ACHIEVING THEIR JOB THAT
THOSE TWO YEARS WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO CONTINUE ON BECAUSE THAT'S
SUCCESS AS WELL, RIGHT? THAT IS
A MEASURE OF SUCCESS. ACTUALLY,
I MEAN, OUR OUR STUDENTS ARE
MORTUARY SCIENCE PROGRAM AT
SCIENTIST COLLEGE WOULD BE A
GOOD EXAMPLE. WHEN THEY COMPLETE
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET A JOB
IN GOING TO THE WORKFORCE AND
NOT REALLY HAVE TO CONSIDER
TRANSFERRING TO ANOTHER
INSTITUTION. AND SO THERE ARE
STILL GOOD PAYING JOBS OUT THERE
THAT AFTER TWO YEARS YOU GET A
CERTIFICATE OR SOME KIND OF
CERTIFICATION IN ORDER TO DO
THAT, SO, YES, THAT IS PART OF
THE TRACKING MECHANISMS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. AND I
MENTIONED THAT BECAUSE I KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF TRAINING SCHOOLS
THAT ARE TECHNICAL THAT OUR
STUDENTS PURPOSELY CHOOSE THOSE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO GO TO A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE AND
THEY JUST WANT TO GET A
CERTIFICATE OR TWO YEAR DEGREE
AND GET RIGHT INTO THE WORKFORCE
FOR ECONOMIC REASONS OR WHATEVER
IT MAY BE, BUT THEY BUT THAT
ALSO IS CONSIDERED A SUCCESS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE ACHIEVED THEIR
GOALS AND NECESSARILY BECAUSE
THEY'RE WANTING TO GO TO A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE. SO, UM, JUST. I
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT LIKE,
HOW DOES HOW DO WE FRAME THAT
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT DATA, SAYING THAT THAT IS
STILL SUCCESS AFTER TWO YEARS?
OF COURSE IT IS, AND I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THAT YOU KNOW,
SENATOR GROVE MENTIONED THAT SHE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT FOR YOU DEGREE
AND YET SHE WAS VERY, VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN WHAT SHE CHOSE TO
DO. AND SO LONG AS YOU HAVE THAT
EDUCATION BASE, NO MATTER WHAT
IT IS, AND THEN YOU'RE ABLE TO
LIVE THE WAY THAT YOU WANT TO
LIVE, RIGHT? NOT EVERYBODY WANTS
TO HAVE A YACHT. BUT EVERYONE
BODY WANTS TO HAVE A HOME. AND
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HAVE A CAR
THAT THEY CAN GET BACK AND FORTH
TO WORK TO WANT TO BE ABLE TO
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN IN DIGNITY,
AND THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS MEAN
HAVING A FOUR YEAR DEGREE AND WE
NEED THOSE TECHNICAL SKILLS NOW
I'M A BIG PROPONENT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND GETTING
THOSE VOCATIONAL VOCATIONAL
GOALS MET. SOMETIMES I'M REALLY
DISCOURAGED. I USED TO BE CHAIR
OF THE OF THE CALIFORNIA FOR NYA
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE, AS
MR LAIRD WELL, KNOWS, WE HAVE AN
INSIDE JOKE. UM BUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO A LOT OF OUR
VETERANS AS THEY WERE BEING
FUNNELED INTO THESE FOR PROFIT.
TECHNICAL SCHOOLS AND JUST BEING
FLEECED BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT
WAS PAYING FOR IT. AND THEN
COMING OUT WITH NO MARKETABLE
SKILLS. AND SO AND THEN JUST
BEING FOCUSED ON THAT
TECHNICALITY, AND NOT THE
OVERALL EDUCATION OF A PERSON
THAT THEY DO GET WHEN THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO, UM,
SUCCESS ISN'T MEASURED BY THAT.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
REALLY SUCCESSFUL. AND UM, I
BELONG TO A GREAT MENTORSHIP
GROUP. I HAVE SINCE 1988. AND
OUR MISSION IS TO HAVE EVERY
WOMAN LIVED THE LIFE THAT SHE
WANTS TO LIVE. AND THAT MEANS
SUCCESS IS A HOUSEWIFE. OR IT
MEANS SUCCESS IS A PHD AMEN.
PERFECT WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
UM, SO, UM I JUST WANT TO EVOLVE
IN THAT LITTLE FOR CLARIFICATION
, BUT I DO HAVE TWO QUESTIONS,
AND ONE HAS TO DO WITH THE WITH
THE VISION 2030 PLAN. AS YOU
FOLKS KNOW WHERE A SEVERE BUDGET
. DEFICIT THIS YEAR AND SO BEING
THAT WE DO SIT WITH SENATOR
LAWRENCE ACTUALLY SENATOR SMALL
EQUIVALENTS ON THE BUDGET, UM,
COMMITTEE FOR EDUCATION. UM I
WANT YOU TO EXPRESS WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE S U UH, THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE MUST PAY MOST
ATTENTION TO IMPROVE THE OVERALL
OUTCOMES FOR OUR STUDENTS AND IN
LIGHT OF THE BUDGET THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW, IF THERE WERE TO HAVE
CUTS TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HAS THE BOARDING THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PRIORITIZED
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO
INITIATIVES WILL BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND FUND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN
. SO UM, THIS LAST MEETING WE
GOT OUR FIRST LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE GOT OUR
FIRST BRIEFING ON IT. AND THEN I
HAD A DISCUSSION WITH A BRIEF
DISCUSSION WITH MR SENATOR JOHN
LAIRD. BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW HE
DOESN'T LIKE TO TALK. SO WE HAD
A BROTHER. I HAD A BRIEF
DISCUSSION ABOUT HIM. YEAH. SO,
UM EVEN THOUGH THE INITIAL
BUDGET LOOKS OKAY FOR, UM, FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES, AND
WE'RE REALLY THANKFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR NOT DID NOT CHOOSE TO
CUT FUNDING FROM THAT. WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT SAFE YET. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT, UM, THAT WELL, I
BELIEVE I DON'T KNOW. I BELIEVE.
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
THE BEDROCK OF THE MAJORITY OF
OUR STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON EDUCATING
THAT POPULATION OF STUDENTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
TAKING CARE OF ME IN A COUPLE OF
YEARS, RIGHT? UM I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT MR LAIRD. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, HE SEEMS TO BE ETERNAL,
BUT BUT BUT, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE WE ARE GOING TO NEED
THEM AND WE'RE GOING TO NEED AN
EDUCATED WORKFORCE THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE TO SUPPORT IN
THE FUTURE WITH GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ACTUAL CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR
STREAM OF INCOME. AND OUR
QUALITY OF LIFE, SO I THINK THAT
IT'S ALWAYS A DIFFICULT DECISION
TO MAKE BECAUSE I SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN WE WERE HAVING THE
CRISIS OF 2008 WHERE WE HAD THAT
BIG ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND WE HAD
A HUGE BUDGET. DEFICITS YOU HAVE
TO MAKE THOSE TOUGH TO SIT
DECISIONS. CERTAINLY MY BEING
MAYOR OF MY CITY FOR EIGHT YEARS
AND UNDERSTANDING OUR BUDGET AND
OUR BUDGET PROCESS. THINGS COST.
OKAY AND SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE REVENUE STREAMS THAT
ARE COMING INTO THIS DATA
CALIFORNIA ARE SUSTAINABLE THAT
THEY MAKE SENSE AND RIGHT NOW,
THE WAY THAT WE GET IT, IT'S SO
VOLATILE. YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO
REWORK THAT OTHERWISE WE'RE
ALWAYS GOING TO BE ON THIS
ROLLER COASTER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN MAKE CHOICES
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE. I
WOULD SAY THAT VISION 20 23RD IS
A VERY AMBITIOUS VISIONARIES.
CANCER. CHRISTIAN IS REALLY OUT
OF VISION, AND WE'RE ALL
MARCHING TOWARDS THAT. BUT I
KNOW THAT IN ANY SITUATION, YOU
ALSO HAVE TO HAVE A BACKUP PLAN.
IF IT DOESN'T GO AS AS AS YOU
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE, AND IT'S I
WOULD SAY IT'S A DYNAMIC PROCESS
, SO WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING AT IT
IN RETOOLING IT. AND WE REALLY
HAVEN'T HAD THE CONVERSATION IS
ABOARD HE HAD REGARDING WITH THE
BUDGET WAITING FOR THE BUDGET
CUTS COME. WHAT WOULD THAT
ACTUALLY LOOKED LIKE, BUT I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WELL AWARE OF IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS WELL
AWARE OF THAT. WE MAY HAVE TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE SPEED OF
WHICH WE MAKE THIS STUFF HAPPEN
OR HOW FAR WE ARE ABLE TO GO.
BUT I THINK WE'RE DOING IT IN
WITH INTENTIONALITY. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE HAVE WHEN WE
DECIDE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO, IF
WE HAVE TO CUT SOMETHING, THEN
WE PRIORITIZE WITH THOSE WITH
THOSE CUTS ARE OR WHAT THOSE
AREAS WHERE WE GET THE MOST BANG
FOR A BOOK WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT WE DO HAVE. IF WE'RE NOT
THINKING THAT WAY, THEN WE'RE
DOING OURSELVES AND OUR STUDENTS
DISSERVICE. AGREED THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND MY LAST QUESTION HOW
TO DO WITH THE HOUSING. HOUSING
IS HUGE FOR ME, AND I UNDERSTAND
HOW OUR STUDENT POPULATION OR
SCHOOLS IMPACT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN THERE THE COST OF
HOUSING FOR THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
SO HUGE AND I'VE BEEN A HUGE
ADVOCATE FROM THE GET GO IN
BUILDING HOUSING ON OUR CAMPUSES
, SO AS TO NOT IMPACT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND THAT END MR
LEGRAND. I KNOW. THAT YOU ARE
HOUSING EXPERT ON THAT END, HAVE
YOU IDENTIFIED ANY LEGAL OR, UM
PROGRAMMATIC OBSTACLES THAT.
LOCAL DISTRICT SPACE THAT WE
COULD FIX TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND ACTUALLY SPEED UP
THE CONSTRUCTION OF OUR STUDENT
HOUSING ON CAMPUSES. I ACTUALLY
HAVEN'T THOUGHT OF IT IN THAT
CONTEXT FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE, YET I'M JUST
BEGINNING TO LEARN TO FIND OUT
HOW THE PROCESS ACTUALLY WORKED
WITH SANTA ROSA. AND I KNOW
NAPA'S GOTTA CAMPUSES CAN OPEN
PRETTY PRETTY QUICKLY. I THINK
NEXT FALL AS WELL, UM, BUT I DO
THINK AS I THINK ABOUT THIS IT
IS A PARTNERSHIP AND SO CAMPUSES
THAT ACTUALLY HAVE LAND THAT'S
AVAILABLE THAT COULD BE BUILT
UPON IS ACTUALLY A HUGE COST
SAVINGS BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
NOT GOING OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
AND DOING THAT. AND SO IF WE
WERE, IF WE WERE PRIORITIZING
THE BEST WAY TO STRETCH OUR
DOLLARS FINDING PLACES WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE TO BUY LAND IN ORDER
TO MAKE THAT HOUSING COULD HAVE
THAT HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
HAPPENED MIGHT BE A FIRST STEP
THAT I'D WANT TO LOOK AT OF HOW
TO MAKE THOSE RESOURCES REALLY,
REALLY. REALLY STRETCH AND THEN
SECOND OF IT'S. IT'S ALWAYS A
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP AND SO
FINDING COMMUNITIES OR CITIES
THAT ARE FRIENDLY TO US DOING
THAT, BECAUSE I KNOW IN MANY
CASES THEY DON'T LIKE US TAKING
THE HOUSING STOCK FROM REGULAR
RESIDENTS TO AND SO THEY REALLY
DO LIKE THE FACT THAT
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES ARE
ACTUALLY BUILDING HOUSING
COMMUNITY BECAUSE IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES CAN CONTINUE TO BE
HOUSED THERE AND THAT USUALLY
WHEN WE BUILD IT, WE HAVE MORE
CONTROL USUALLY OVER HOW WHAT
THE COSTS ARE GOING TO BE, SO
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT AT THE
MARKET. WE DON'T WE NORMALLY
WILL SHOOT FOR SOME PERCENTAGE
BELOW MARKET IN ORDER TO MAKE
OUR STUDENTS DOLLARS STRETCH
BECAUSE FINANCIALLY WE'RE ONLY
GO SO FAR AND LOANS WILL ONLY GO
SO FAR. YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
INDEBTED. THEY'D BE TOTALLY
INDEBTED JUST BECAUSE OF HOUSING
AND THAT'S WHERE ALL YOUR DEBTS
COMING FROM, SO I DO THINK IT'S
A, UM THAT'S ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT I'VE EXPRESSED INTEREST
WITH WITH THE WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ABOUT
HELPING THEM THINK THROUGH THAT,
AND SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL CONTINUE
TO MOVE DOWN THAT PATH. I TRULY
TRULY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT END, IF MOVING FORWARD,
THERE ARE ANY OTHER AREAS WHERE
YOU SEE THAT WE NEED TO WORK IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO SPEED THAT
CONSTRUCTION IN OUR IN OUR
CAMPUSES. I WOULD LOVE LOVE TO
HEAR FROM YOU ON THOSE IDEAS SO
THAT WE COULD SEE HOW WE COULD
HELP YOU ON THAT END BECAUSE
THAT IS A PASSION FROM FLYING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. AND LAST,
BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST LET ME
TURN TO SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU, MADAM PROTEIN. DOES HE HAVE
A TIME LIMIT AS THE CHAIR OF
BUDGET SUB ONE? I THINK I'LL
GIVE HIM SOME LATITUDE. BUT
UNDERSTAND. I EXPECT TO TAKE
LESS THAN ALL MY BRIEF
COLLEAGUES HAVE THANK YOU
BECAUSE MUST HAVE THE QUESTIONS
HAVE BEEN ASKED. AND SO LET ME
JUST FIRST SAY THANK YOU FOR
BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE AND LET ME ASK EACH OF
YOU ONE QUESTION AND FOR MR
LEGRAND. ACTUALLY MY COLLEAGUE
STARTED TO GET INTO IT WITH
HOUSING. I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THAT. BUT IT MIGHT ALLOW
FOR THE FOCUS OF HOW YOU SEE
YOUR ROLE. AS A AS A TRUSTEE,
BECAUSE WITH YOUR EXPERTISE ON
HOUSING HOW DO YOU AND AS WE
HAVE DISCUSSED AND ONLY PLACE TO
GOVERNOR RECOMMENDED PULLING
BACK ANY MONEY AND HOUSING WAS
THE LITTLE BIT OF THE EXTRA THAT
HADN'T GONE TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES YET AND SO IN YOUR ROLE
, HOW DO YOU SEE ADVOCACY? AND
HOW DO YOU SEE OVERSIGHT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH REGARD TO
HOUSING SO YOU CAN SORT OF BRING
YOUR EXPERTISE TO BEAR AND BRING
YOUR DESIRE? THAT YOU DISCUSSED
FOR WHAT'S NECESSARY TO BEAR AND
SORT OF ADVOCATING. WELL, I
WOULD SAY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAS BEEN REALLY RECEPTIVE
TO ANY COMMENTS MADE. WE JUST
LOST LISETTE, WHO WAS ACTUALLY
OUR VICE PRESIDENT, THAT WAS
KIND OF LEADING THAT EFFORT. I'M
NOT QUITE CERTAIN WHO'S STEPPING
INTO THOSE SHOES RIGHT NOW. BUT
I WILL BE KIND OF IN LOCKSTEP
WITH THAT INDIVIDUAL AS THEY
CONTINUE TO MOVE DOWN THIS PATH.
I THINK AGAIN. THESE ARE
COMMUNITY AND CAMPUS BASED
DECISIONS. I'VE ACTUALLY HAD A
COUPLE OF DEVELOPERS THAT KNOW
THAT I'M ON THIS BOARD NOW
CALLING OFF. SO WHAT? WHAT ROLE
DO YOU HAVE IN GETTING HOUSING
BUILT IN TOWN X AND I'M LIKE,
WELL, I REALLY DON'T BECAUSE
THOSE ARE LOCALLY LOCALLY MADE
DECISIONS BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THOSE DISTRICT TRUSTEES AND
THE LIKE. IT IS POINT YOU IN
THAT DIRECTION, BUT I DO. I
WOULD SAY THAT, UM YEAH, I'M
PRETTY GOOD ABOUT KIND OF
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX.
USUALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS, AND SO I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THEIR RISK THERE IS
RECEPTIVITY TO SOME OF THE IDEAS
THAT I MAY, UH, COME UP WITH US.
I BEGIN TO THINK MORE ABOUT IT.
BUT AT THIS POINT I HAVEN'T
HAVEN'T GIVEN IT. A LOT OF I
HAVEN'T GIVEN IT A LOT OF BRIEF
PIECE OF ADVICE, AND THAT IS
THAT WHAT YOU SAID, IS EXACTLY
RIGHT ABOUT THE PROJECTS. BUT
THE FUNDING IS AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND THE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HOUSING OF
THE THREE BRANCHES WAS THE ONE
THAT GOT COMPLETELY BALD UP LAST
YEAR, AND IT GOT BALLED UP TWO
WAYS. THERE'S THREE PROJECTS
THAT ARE JOINED WITH EITHER A
CSU OR YOU SEE AND HOW THEY WERE
FUNDED TOGETHER, FINALLY TOOK
èC STANDING UP AND SAYING WE
WILL USE OUR BOND AUTHORITY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE JOINT
AND THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT STILL
HASN'T CLARIFIED HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BORROWING FOR
THIS, SO WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST IS
AS AN ADVOCATE AND AS SOMEBODY
THAT KNOWLEDGEABLE THERE IS A
PLACE FOR YOU WITH THE STATE
FROM THE BOARD LEVEL TO MAKE
SURE SOMEBODY'S PAYING ATTENTION
AND DOGGING FISTS AND JUST
SUGGEST TO YOU. THAT'S A GOOD
ASSIGNMENT RECEIVED. THANK YOU.
AND THEN FOR MISS ALICE, WHEN
YOU MADE YOUR OPENING STATEMENT,
YOU REMIND ME WHY I WAS SO HAPPY
TO SERVE WITH YOU WHEN WE WERE
TOGETHER IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT
WAS HEARTFELT AND IT WAS ON
POINT. I KNOW IT DRIVES PEOPLE.
MY QUESTION TO YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR MEETING TODAY. UM RAHMAN.
THERE HAS BEEN DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, AND IT WAS EXACERBATED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND IT'S SORT OF
COMING BACK. HOW DO YOU SEE THAT
FROM YOUR LEVEL AS A TRUST?
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT. IT WAS
DEVASTATING ON THE MIC. I'M
WE'RE NOT HEARING YOU. VERY
WELL. THANK YOU. SO THERE WAS A
HUGE DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT. BUT
LAST YEAR WE GREW ENROLLMENT BY
8% AND SO WE SEE THAT AS A AS AN
UPWARD TREND NOW. AND SO, UM, I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT ON US TO
REALLY REACH OUT TO STUDENTS AT
A LOWER LEVEL TO EXPLAIN TO THEM
. UM YOU KNOW THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT LIE AHEAD OF THEM WHEN THEY
REACH THAT HIGHER EDUCATION
LEVEL, RIGHT? UM SOMETIMES WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING TO COLLEGE OR
EXCUSE ME HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
THEY CAN'T SEE THEMSELVES IN A
FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY. THEY THINK
IT'S A LIFETIME. AND SO THEY
THINK WHAT ANOTHER FOUR YEARS
I'LL BE IN OLD PERSON. WHEN I
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE, AND SO IF
YOU CAN SHOW THEM A PATHWAY, UM,
THAT THIS IS THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE JUST THAT
COMMUNITY. OKAY THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE LIKE ON THE
GROUND. IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE
ANALOGY OF I WAS AN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN, BUT I DIDN'T HAVE THAT
CONTACT WITH MY CONSTITUENTS.
WHEN I WAS A MAYOR, I WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH MY CONSTITUENTS.
IT'S THE SAME THING ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL. THAT
EACH INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE HAS THAT LEVEL OF
INVOLVEMENT IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND IF THEY DON'T THEY SHOULD.
BUT I'VE SEEN IN SAN DIEGO, UM
IN THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHERE, UM, THAT THE
CHANCELLORS PRESIDENTS MAKE IT A
POINT TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
COMMUNITY FUNCTIONS TO, UH TO
CHAMPION DUAL ENROLLMENT, WHICH
I THINK IS GOING TO BE, UH, YOU
KNOW, IT'S REALLY ALREADY
PROVEN. WE HAVE A STUDENT THAT
GRADUATED FROM BONITA VISTA HIGH
SCHOOL THAT ALSO GRADUATED WITH
HER. HER COLLEGE DEGREE BECAUSE
SHE WAS ALSO CONCURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN DUAL ENROLLMENT AND
SHE WAS 16. SO IT'S PHENOMENAL
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT CAN INSPIRE
STUDENTS TO DO AND LOOK AT
EDUCATION IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN ACHIEVE. WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP. I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT COLLEGE
FOR MYSELF. THAT WASN'T A
TRADITION IN MY FAMILY. YOU
KNOW, MY PARENTS WERE HARD
WORKING. I THINK THEY WERE
SMART. BUT THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
FORMAL EDUCATION. AND SO THEY
DIDN'T PUSH ME TOO, THAT THEY
DIDN'T DIDN'T PUT THAT IN MY
MIND THAT I COULD GO TO COLLEGE.
THEY WANTED ME TO BE A NICE
LITTLE WIFEY, AND THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT. BUT
THINK ABOUT THE POTENTIAL THAT'S
NOT BEING DEVELOPED ON STUDENTS
THAT CANNOT SEE FOR THEM. SO I
THINK THE REAL ROLE OF THE
OUTREACH IS WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVELS AND THAT WE HAVE
TO AS A AS A BOARD OF GOVERNORS
HERE ENCOURAGE THOSE KINDS OF
POLICIES AND ACTIONS THAT WILL
GET STUDENTS INTO THE PIPELINE,
LIKE DO ENROLLMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, AND A CLOSING COMMENT
BECAUSE I HAD A CHANCE TO MEET
WITH MS SALAS, THE WE ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE KEEP ALONG WITH
THE SYSTEM, KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD ON THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA, AND IT IS NOW
IN THE FIFTH YEAR OF A HOLD
HARMLESS, WHICH MAKES YOU WONDER
IF WE KEEP HOLDING HARMLESS
THOSE THAT ARE LOSING WHETHER WE
SHOULD LOOK FOR A MORE PERMANENT
SOLUTION, AND I WOULD JUST EVERY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS MEMBER THAT COMES BY
HERE IS NOT FAMILIAR WITH IT. SO
I WOULD JUST URGE YOU TO GET
FAMILIAR WITH THAT BECAUSE IT
CREATED WINNERS AND LOSERS AND
MOST OF THE LOSERS HAPPENED TO
BE IN MY SENATE-DISTRICT AND
THEIR BUDGET WILL BE CUT BY 10.
IF WE DON'T FIGURE SOMETHING OUT
HERE, SO JUST TO CALL THAT
ATTENTION, THANK YOU BOTH. I
REALLY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IT'S BEEN A REAL PLEASURE
MEETING WITH ALL OF YOU. IT'S
BEEN A VERY, UM LIKE HUMBLING
EXPERIENCE AND I'M GLAD TO BE IN
THE COMPANY OF SUCH GOOD PEOPLE
THAT SERVE OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SENATORS THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU. MY COLLEAGUES HAVE VERY
MUCH COVERED THE QUESTIONS I
WANTED TO ASK. I DID WANT TO ASK
ABOUT YOUR EXPERTISE AND YOU
KNOW FROM CSU AND UC RELATED TO
HOUSING. I KNOW HOUSING IS AN
ISSUE. YOU'VE LONG BEEN ENGAGED
IN, AND I WAS THRILLED TO SEE
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES START TO
THINK CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW THEY
COULD HELP SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE SOME LAND
AND THE ABILITY TO DO THIS, AND
I THINK IT'S REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT. UM YOU KNOW, I LOVE
YOU KNOW SOME OF WHAT YOU SAID,
UM, MISS SALAS RESONATED WITH ME
. MY PARENTS HAD NO EXPERIENCE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO HELP
ME GO TO COLLEGE. SO IT WAS
PEERS AND COUNSELORS AND SUPPORT
STAFF. AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
THAT GAVE ME AND FRIENDS
BASICALLY, THEY GAVE ME THAT
VISION. AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
FAMILIES AND I'VE HEARD SO MANY
GREAT STORIES, WE ALL HAVE
STORIES AND BECAUSE WE'RE SUCH A
DIVERSE LEGISLATURE, THE STORIES
REALLY RESONATE, AND I THINK
THOSE STORIES ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE UM, I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT MOST OF MY
COLLEAGUES, BUT I THINK I DO. I
WOULDN'T BE HERE OR IT NOT FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET AN
EDUCATION AND I DIDN'T KNOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WAS AN OPTION
AND THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE
ONLY OPTION FINANCIALLY. I WOULD
HAVE HAD HAD I NOT HAD THE HELP
OF COUNSELORS. UM SO I REALLY
THINK OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STRUCTURE AND SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IS SO IMPORTANT. WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL èC SYSTEM. WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL CSU SYSTEM, BUT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE WORKING
TOGETHER THE INTEGRATION OF
THESE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
WE REALLY NEED TO BE WORKING
HAND IN GLOVE TOGETHER. AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSES ON THE
2030 VISION. ON CALLE BRIGHT
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, THAT'S BEEN
A DISCUSSION FOR SINCE ITS
INCEPTION, AND GOVERNOR BROWN
PROMOTED IT. OBVIOUSLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC, WE REALIZED HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ALREADY HAD SOME ONLINE
CAPABILITIES, SO I HOPE WE'RE
THROUGH THAT. AND, UM I THINK
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
IMPORTANT. SO I DON'T YOU KNOW,
I DON'T REALLY HAVE QUESTIONS.
AT THIS POINT. I JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSES AND
YOUR HISTORIES THAT BRING YOU
HERE THAT MAKE YOU REALLY GOOD
APPOINTMENTS. UM FOR SOMETHING
SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M GONNA I'M TURN
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC NOW WHO
HAVE BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY, UM
AND SEE IF WE HAVE FOLKS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
I WOULD ASK YOU IF YOU'RE HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT, FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO APPROACH THE MIC. UM
YOU HAVE MADE YOUR CASE QUITE
WELL. IT SEEMS LIKE, UH, THAT IS
GOOD. CLEARLY YOUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY HERE ARE NODDING. YES WE
SUPPORT THEM ARE WE THINK WE
STILL SUPPORT THEM? BUT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET UP AT THIS
TIME. SO WE'LL TAKE THAT AS
ACQUIESCENCE. LET ME JUST ALSO
ASKED. IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
EMOTION. MADAM VICE CHAIR HAS
MADE A MOTION FOR BOTH BOTH
APPOINTEES OR CONFEREES. WE
SHALL VOTE AND LET ME ASK MADAM
SECRETARY TO POLICE CALL THE
ROLL. LAIRD I OR TRELLEBORG GUYS
. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS BESIDE GROVE
GROVE. I ATKINS INSIDE. IT IS 5
TO 0 FROM THIS COMMITTEE. WE
WILL FORWARD THESE APPOINTMENTS
TO THE FULL SENATE FOR
CONFIRMATION. AND WE SAY
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NOTHING LIKE GOOD TROUBLE
TROUBLE. BY AS ONLY HE COULD SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. WE
WILL TAKE ABOUT FIVE MINUTES AND
THEN WE'LL SHIFT TO ITEM NUMBER
C, WHICH IS JAMES COOPER MEMBER
COMMISSION ON POLICE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. SO FIVE
MINUTES AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
UP HERE. THANK YOU. YEAH. I
DIDN'T GET THE PURPLE MINIMUM. I
DIDN'T GET THE PURPLE MEMO WELL.
JUST A MOMENT AS PEOPLE TAKE
THEIR SEATS, AND MY COLLEAGUES
SEEM TO BE PREPARED. LET ME
INVITE SHERIFF JIM COOPER UP
MEMBER COMMISSION ON POLICE
OFFICE APIECE. SORRY PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
AND LET ME INVITE YOU TO DO THE
SAME THING. WELCOME INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. ANY COMMENTS YOU'D
LIKE, THANK ANYONE AND OPENING
COMMENTS AND WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIRMAN. FELLOW SENATORS
CENTERS. GREAT TO BE HERE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ALL.
YOU'RE VERY BUSY. JIM COOPER FOR
THE POST COMMISSION. I'M SURE
FOR SECOND WILL CARRY THE 37TH
SHERIFF. I'M ACTUALLY THE SECOND
BLACK SHERIFF EVER IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA. UM I HAVE
FOUR DAUGHTERS. THEY'RE ALL
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED. THEY'RE
WORKING, SO THEY'RE NOT HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO SUPPORT ME,
LIFELONG SACRAMENTO RESIDENT SON
IN MY 31ST YEAR IN THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. I ALSO SPENT 15
YEARS IN THE FOUNDING MAYOR AND
COUNCIL MEMBER. OF THE CITY OF
AL GROVER, SECOND WORLD SUBURB
ABOUT 178,000 PEOPLE, AND I
SPENT EIGHT YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY FROM
2014 UNTIL 2022. WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LET ME GO AHEAD. I WILL
START IN A DIFFERENT ROUTE.
DIFFERENT DIRECTION. SENATOR
LAIR. DO YOU WANT TO KICK US OFF
TODAY? YES THANK YOU. UM WELCOME
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE. THANK YOU HAD TWO
QUESTIONS AND LET ME ASK THE
MORE POLICY BASED ONE FIRST AND
THAT IS THERE WAS A BILL I THINK
YOU WERE PROBABLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT, UH,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S JONES SAWYER
DID TO ESTABLISH A MODERN
POLICING DEGREE PROGRAM, AND IT
IT IS THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND THERE'S A
REPORT THAT'S BEEN DONE. AND IT
REALLY, UM ENCOURAGES EDUCATION
RELATION TO MODERN POLICING. AND
I WONDERED, UM, JUST AS A POST
MEMBER, WHAT'S YOUR VIEW OF
OVERVIEW WHERE THAT IS AND HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO SORT OF MAKE
SURE THAT THAT IS IMPLEMENTED?
SURE I THINK EDUCATION IS
IMPORTANT. UM THE ISSUE IS WHEN
I FIRST STARTED MANY, MANY YEARS
AGO. I DIDN'T HAVE MY COLLEGE
DEGREE, I WAS GOING TO COLLEGE
AND WORKING FULL TIME AND IT'S
PROBLEMATIC RIGHT NOW IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT BILL AND THE
REASON BEING IS TOUGH TO HIRE
RIGHT NOW. OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT
POPULAR TO BE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER. SO YOU'RE LIMITING YOUR
ALREADY LIMITED GROUP OF ONLY
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS AND THEN
YOU'RE WORKING WEEKENDS
HOLIDAYS. AND MISSING BIRTHDAYS
AND CHRISTMAS AND DEALING WITH
SOME PRETTY PERFECT THINGS AT
TIMES, SO IT'S REALLY TOUGH TO
HIRE TO GET FOLKS IN THAT HAVE
THAT FOR YOUR DEGREE WHEN YOU
CAN MAKE MORE MONEY SOMEWHERE
ELSE. UM ONCE I GOT IN, IF YOU
WANT TO PROMOTE AND MOVE UP, YOU
OBVIOUSLY NEED HIGHER EDUCATION.
SO I WENT BACK TO SCHOOL WITH
KIDS AND GOT MY UNDERGRAD AND
GOT MY GRAD. SO MOST FOLKS DO
THAT. AND YOU LOOK AT THE
COLLEGE RATES. I KNOW THE
CHANCELLOR'S OR THE FOLKS UP
HERE FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, AND IT'S TOUGH GETTING
MINORITIES IN THERE TO HAVE THAT
FOR YOUR DEGREE, SO YOU ALREADY
MAKING IT. THE BILL IS MAKING A
TOUGH JOB EVEN TOUGHER TO GET
PEOPLE AND TO REALLY BE DIVERSE,
AND THAT'S WHEN I CAME IN. LAST
YEAR, I HAD 100 VACANCIES FOR
SWORN OFFICERS AND WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF HIRING. I STILL HAVE 100
VACANCIES. THAT'S REALLY THE
TOUGH PART WITH THAT BILL WHERE
IT IS PROBLEMATIC WHERE YOU'RE
FORCED TO. IT'S TOUGH TO HIRE
PEOPLE. IF SOMEONE HAS RESOURCES
THAT OUR FAMILY CAN PUT THEM
THROUGH THE ACADEMY THEY CAN.
BUT IF YOU'RE A WOMAN, IF YOU'RE
A PERSON OF COLOR, IT IS HARDER
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF
ACADEMIES IN THE STATE OR UM AND
PETER ACADEMIES VERY FEW PAY YOU
TO GO THROUGH. SO THAT'S WHERE
THE BIG ISSUE HAVING THAT
DEGREE, BUT IN OUR DEPARTMENT.
I'VE BEEN THERE A YEAR. MOST
FOLKS THAT PROMOTE THE RANKS,
HEATHER DEGREE THEY GET IT
EVENTUALLY. IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU'D LIKE TO WORK ON TO, LIKE,
MAKE SURE THAT ISN'T THE CHOICE
BETWEEN SORT OF HAVING AN
EDUCATION AND MODEL POLICING AND
NOT BEING ABLE TO AFFORD TO DO
IT ABSOLUTELY AND MY DEGREES IN
BUSINESS, SO I THINK AS LONG AS
YOU HAVE A DEGREE AT SOME POINT,
IT DOESN'T MATTER. YOU'VE YOU'VE
BETTERED YOURSELF, SO I WOULD
DEFINITELY AGREE WITH THAT,
SENATOR. OKAY THANK YOU. AND
THEN A MORE DIFFICULT QUESTION.
UM WE WERE ALL OR SOME OF US
WERE WASTE. I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
EVERYBODY OR PROVIDED A LETTER.
ABOUT A WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT
FINDING ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
AND IN THE BODY OF THE LETTER,
IT SAYS. THAT AFTER CONSIDERING
THE ALLEGATION THE FACTS ON THE
PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE THE
PANEL FOUND INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO SUBSTANTIATE AH,
THAT. THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S,
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS YOU YELLED
AT THE PERSON THAT COMPLIANCE,
BUT THE PANEL DID FIND THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MADE AN
INAPPROPRIATE COMMENT TO THE
PERSON INVOLVED. OTHER FOUND
THAT COMMENT WAS NOT RELATED TO
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION. AND I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK
TO THIS SO THAT WE COULD
UNDERSTAND YOUR FEELINGS ABOUT
THE SITUATION JUST REPEATED WITH
SOMEONE ELSE HAD TOLD ME AND I
SAID THAT PERSON. I MADE IT VERY
CLEAR WHEN SOMEONE ELSE HAD TOLD
ME. SO UM, I'VE ALWAYS BEEN, UH
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE WITH
THINGS, SO I WOULD NEVER MAKE AN
OFF GENDER REMARK FOR ANYBODY.
UM AND, UH, I GUESS THE W C,
WHICH I BELIEVE IN WC YOU
STARTED WHEN I WAS HERE, AND IT
WAS ALL SUBSTANTIATED. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT MORE TO SAY. IT PAINS
ME TO BE UP HERE AND TALK ABOUT
IT. UM BUT IT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU'RE IN POSITIONS LIKE THAT,
AND THEY DID THEIR JOB AND THEY
DID THEIR JOB VERY WELL. AND I
STAND BY WHAT THEY FOUND. DID
YOU LEARN SOMETHING FROM THIS
SITUATION? UM YEAH. UM IT WAS
JUST DIFFICULT AND I WOULD NOT
REPHRASE WITH SOMEONE ELSE TOLD
ME, I WOULD. I WOULD USE A
BETTER CHOICE OF WORDS. BUT THAT
WAS MY FAULT. AND I SAID
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SAYING WHAT
SOMEONE ELSE SAID. THAT'S A LIE
FOR MY SWORD ON THAT ONE. OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. I WILL COME
DOWN ONCE AGAIN TO YOU, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS AND I ASKED YOU
TO GO NEXT. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND GOOD TO MEET YOU,
MR COOPER. I HAVE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT YOU, UM AND THE WORK OF
THE BLACK CAUCUS. UM AND YOU
KNOW, I WANTED TO ASK YOU A FEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT MAYBE A FOLLOW
UP TO MY GOOD COLLEAGUES.
QUESTION ABOUT. THIS PARTICULAR
COMPLAINT IN PARTICULARLY IN
YOUR ROLE AT POST IN YOU SAID.
YOU LEARNED A LOT THROUGH THAT
EXPERIENCE. HOW PART OF POST IS
HELPING TO TRAIN POLICE OFFICERS
, PEACE OFFICERS ON HOW TO
ENGAGE WITH DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. AND DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES HAVE. CERTAIN
PROTECTIONS AND DESERVE, YOU
KNOW, PARTICULAR PROTECTIONS,
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE GET TO, UM,
GROUPS THAT, UM UM OF DIFFERENT
RACES AND GENDER IDENTITY AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION. SO I WONDER
FROM THIS PROCESS. HOW WOULD YOU
GO INTO POST IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
OF CURRICULUM HAVE SORT OF AN
EQUITY COMPONENT TO IT THAT
UNDERSTANDS SOME OF THE NEEDS OF
COMMUNITIES AND HOW THEY NEED TO
BE POLICED. HOW THEY NEED TO BE
PROTECTED. GREAT QUESTION.
TRAINING IS IMPORTANT. TRAINING
IS KEY. OBVIOUSLY. POST MANDATES
24 HOURS OF TRAINING EVERY TWO
YEARS. SO I TAUGHT, UM CULTURAL
COMPETENCY IN THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT BEFORE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME TO HAVE THAT AND TALK
ABOUT THAT, AND THEY REALLY GO
OUT AND I THINK BEING A PERSON
OF COLOR AND BEING THE LEADER OF
AN ORGANIZATION, UM HAS AN
IMPACT, AND THAT'S WHY THE PAST
YEAR I'VE ACTUALLY ATTENDED
EVERY BRIEFING, WHICH WHICH,
VERY FEW LEADERS GO TO EVERY
BRIEFING THE DEPARTMENT TO TOUCH
EVERY EMPLOYEE AND LET THEM KNOW
WHAT YOUR EXPECTATIONS ARE
REALLY TALK ABOUT. THINGS MUST
BE TOO. THERE WAS A LOT OF YOU
KNOW THEY THEY'RE TRYING TO GET
US. IT'S LIKE ON SB TWO. THEY'RE
ONLY I BELIEVE 13 OR 16 STATES
THAT DON'T HAVE A
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS OR SO
WALKING THEM THROUGH THAT, AND
I'LL TELL YOU IT WAS VERY
HELPFUL MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND YOU DO WITH
DIVERSE VIEWS. AND IF YOU DON'T
COMPROMISE HERE, YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET ANYTHING ACCOMPLISHED.
SO YOU KNOW, BRINGING THAT
EXPERIENCE TO FOLKS AND TALKING
ABOUT THOSE THINGS AND REALLY
MAKING THEM AWARE AND HIRINGS
AND TRAININGS. UM IT'S AN
IMPORTANT THING, AND YOU NEED
MORE OF THAT. AND ON THE BILL
THAT SENATOR LYRIC TALKED ABOUT.
IT'S TOUGH ON THE EDUCATION
THING, BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
MAKE LAW ENFORCEMENT LESS
DIVERSE. IT'S NOT THE DIVERS TO
BEGIN WITH, SO IT IS TOUGH WITH
THAT. TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE HIM TO COME,
ESPECIALLY WOMEN, TOO. TRYING TO
GET HIM TO COME IN, AND IT IS A
TOUGH NUT TO CRACK. BUT YEAH,
I'M I'M ALL FOR TRAINING, BUT A
LOT OF HIS TRYING TRYING TO FIND
TIME FOR TRAINING BECAUSE YOU'RE
PULLING PEOPLE OFF OF WORK. SO
YOU'VE GOT TO PAY OVERTIME, SO
POST REIMBURSES TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT. BUT IF YOU WANT TO DO
ADDITIONAL TRAINING ABOVE AND
BEYOND, HOW DO YOU MAKE TIME FOR
DOING THAT? SO SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
DOING THAT AND SPINNING OVERTIME
AND TAKING OFFICERS OUT OF THE
FIELD SOMETIME. TO DO THAT
TRAINING AND A LOT OF IT STARTS
IN THE ACADEMY. SO THERE'S A LOT
OF POST MANDATED CURRICULUMS AND
LEARNING DOMAINS THAT THEY GO
THROUGH. BUT IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS. YOU GOT TO TAKE IT OUT
TO HIDE IF YOU REALLY WANT TO BE
EFFECTIVE. WITH DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSIVE WITH PEOPLE APPRECIATE
YOUR FOCUS ON INCLUSIONARY
TRAINING AND HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE BETTER PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND YOU MENTIONED
SB TWO WAS. THAT WAS ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT I HAD THE BILL BY
SENATOR BRADFORD THAT LOOKS AT
THE DECERTIFICATION PROCESS AND,
UM YOU KNOW? IT IS. YOU'RE NOW
IN THIS ROLE. HOW DO YOU THINK?
POSTS CAN ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
SO MANY DEPARTMENTS ARE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROCESS.
WHAT ARE THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENCOURAGE THAT PROCESS? AND WHAT
ARE THE WAYS THAT WE MAKE? SURE.
THAT THE INVESTIGATIONS THAT DO
THAT ARE HAPPENING ARE DONE IN
AN IMPARTIAL WAY, SO THAT WE GET
IS COMPREHENSIVE. UM A RULING AS
POSSIBLE. SO WE WERE ACTUALLY
TEST AGENCY INITIALLY FOR SB TWO
WITH POST AND COUNTY COUNTY WAS
AND WE GAVE HIM SOME OF OUR OUR
CASES AND WENT THROUGH THAT I
THINK WHERE THE DISCONNECT IS,
IS A LOT OF THESE SMALL AGENCIES
BECAUSE WE HAVE A FULL TIME UNIT
THAT DEALS WITH REDUCTION AND
EVERYTHING REGARDING THIS, AND
THE INVESTIGATIONS AND SMALL
DEPARTMENTS HAVE A TOUGH TIME
WITH RESOURCES. SO I THINK, UM,
IT'S MORE OF THAT. THE CARROT
AND THE STICK A LITTLE BIT HERE
TO TRY TO GET HIM TO COME ALONG,
AND IT'S TOUGH. LIKE I SAID,
SMALLER AGENCIES TO MEET THESE
THINGS AND DO THE RESEARCH.
THEY'VE GOT TO DRAW THAT
PERSONNEL FROM SOMEWHERE, SO
BIGGER AGENCIES ARE MORE ABLE TO
OBSERVE, ABSORB IT. SO I THINK
POSTERS GETTING THERE. NO MAN
HAS BEEN GOOD IN THE ALVAREZ
ABOUT WORKING WITH THOSE
AGENCIES IN TRYING TO GET THEM
THERE TO DO THAT, BUT I THINK
IT'S JUST A HANDFUL OF AGENCIES
OUT OF OVER FOREIGN AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA, SO THAT'S ACTUALLY
PRETTY GOOD. BUT WE WANT 100%
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT, AND I
THINK WE GET THERE. IT'S JUST SO
SMALL AGENCIES YOU HAVE TO DOING
IT. IT'S LAW ENFORCEMENT IS VERY
DIFFERENT IN CALIFORNIA, SO WE
DEFINITELY HAVE TO GET THEM
ALONG HERE, AND I THINK I THINK
WE GET THERE. I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC. IS YOUR STRATEGY DO
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT INVESTING
MORE MONEY FOR CERTAIN SIZED
APARTMENTS? OR IS IT LIKE, WHAT
IS THE MECHANISM FROM A POST
PERSPECTIVE? IS IT JUST THE
TRAINING TO SHOW HOW IMPORTANT
THE SP TWO IN THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS IS? I'M JUST TRYING TO
THINK. HOW DO YOU BRING THOSE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND I THINK
IT'S ABOUT 16 RIGHT? THAT. YEAH
I MEAN, I THINK THE COMBINATION
REALLY OF THE OTHER TWO AND LIKE
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T
REALLY KNOW ABOUT SB TWO. AND
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT IT AT A VERY
HIGH LEVEL, I THINK SOME FOLKS
GET IT. SO THAT'S REALLY THE BIG
PART OF EDUCATING THOSE FOLKS IN
THIS, HMM. THANK YOU FOR THAT. I
JUST, UH NO, THIS IS A SHERIFF'S
ROLE ON POST AND, UM GLAD TO SEE
THAT, UH YOUR APPROACH TO
DECERTIFICATION IS ONE OF
EDUCATING AND TRYING TO INFORM
AND IMPROVED THE NUMBERS OF
DEPARTMENTS DISSIPATING IN THAT
AND I HOPE TO HEAR MORE AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD IN TERMS OF WHAT
ARE THE WAYS THAT WE CAN TRACK
THOSE 16 DEPARTMENTS TO SEE
WHETHER THE THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO PERSIST
PATE IN THE PROCESS, SO I'D LOVE
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO. AND I TOLD MY
FOLKS HEY, GLUTTON. DO YOUR JOB.
YOU KNOW THE LAW. FULL ON YOUR
FINE. YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT STUFF. JUST OBEY THE LAW
AND DO THAT, AND YOU'RE OKAY AND
PEOPLE NEED TO BE REASSURED AND
TOLD THAT BECAUSE YOU WANT HIM
GOING OUT THERE AND BEING
PROACTIVE IN DOING THINGS BUT
BEING SMART, SO I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON LEADERS AND WE
NEED TO SEE MORE OF THAT. AND UM
I THINK FROM LEADERSHIP BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THERE'S A VACUUM, AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE ARE, YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO REALLY MONITOR
PEOPLE AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
DOING WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING,
AND FOR THE MOST PART, THEY ARE.
SENATOR AKO BOG. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON,
COOPER YOU AGAIN AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. UM SO AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU DIDN'T
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSE SB TWO.
AT THE TIME. IT WAS DUE TO
SEVERAL CONCERNS THAT YOU AND
OTHERS HAD REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM.
NOW THAT YOU'RE SURE OF ONE POST
ARE THERE ANY OTHER CONCERNS OR
FIXES THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE
WITH REVERSE? ITTY IMPLEMENTING
SB TWO? I THINK IT'S TOUGH TO
RETROACTIVE PART MADE IT TOUGH
GOING BACK FOR THOSE CASES IN
TRYING TO GET THAT, SO IT'S
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO. I
KNOW THAT WE'VE USED A LOT OF
RESOURCES TO TRY AND COMPLY WITH
SB TWO. AND IT HASN'T BEEN EASY.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE MADE IT BUT WITH
THE RESOURCES TO PULL FROM OTHER
AREAS, SO I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
TOO DID SOME GOOD THINGS AND
SOME THINGS THAT COULD BE DONE
BETTER. SO THAT'S WHY I LAID OFF
ON THAT VOTE, BUT I THINK THERE
HAS A PLACE IT'S DOING HIS JOB,
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO DO A LOOK
BACK AND GO BACK AND OBVIOUSLY
POST HAS A LOT OF INPUT WITH
THAT ON THINGS THAT WE CAN
CHANGE TO MAKE IT BETTER AND
MODIFY IT. SO IN THAT WAS
ACTUALLY THE QUESTION IS TO WHAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE AS A FIXER
SOME? WHAT DO YOU SEE? NOW THAT
YOU'RE IMPOSED? WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE FIXES THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEE? NOW THAT YOU'RE ON SHARE
FOR THE POST, WELL POST, HAVING
A TOUGH TIME HIRING AT 150
SOMETHING 100 SOME POSITIONS.
PLUS THEY ONLY HIRED 52. IT IS
TOUGH TO HIRE RIGHT NOW. AND
PART OF THAT PROBLEM IS THAT THE
STATE PAY IS NOT THAT BIG. NOT
THAT GOOD. I'LL BE HONEST WITH
YOU FOLKS GO TO LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES I SHERIFF'S OR
POLICE AGENCIES AND MAKE MORE
MONEY SO WE WANT TO HAVE GOOD
INVESTIGATORS AND GOOD STAFF AT
POST BUT WE'VE GOT TO BE
COMPETITIVE SO THAT THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE WITH THAT, AND LIKE I SAID
, IT'S A COMPETITIVE MARKET. SO
UM I CAN'T SPEAK FOR POST THAT'S
MANY JOB, BUT YEAH, THEY DO NEED
THE FUNDS TO HAVE THOSE
EQUIVALENT SALARIES TO HIRE THE
BEST TALENT POSSIBLE BECAUSE YOU
WANTED THEY'RE ACTUALLY WEEDING
OUT. UM PEOPLE THAT SHOULDN'T BE
A LAW ENFORCEMENT SO TO ME, THE
BEST INVESTIGATORS AND STAFF
PROFESSIONAL STAFF POSSIBLE SO
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THE REQUISITE
SALARIES. BUT THAT'S JUST MY
OPINION. AND THAT'S FINE. THAT'S
ALL I'M ASKING. IS YOUR OPINION
BASED ON THE PERSPECTIVE OF YOUR
EXPERIENCE OF SITTING THERE, SO
THAT'S PERFECT. AND THEN THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS
, UM, HOW DOES THE COMMISSION
PRIORITIZE REPORTED ALLEGATIONS
DOES IT THREE YEARS THE CAUSES
FOR IMMEDIATE ATTENTION OR AH!
OR BASED ON THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE COMPLAINT. BOTH SO IT'S A
TRIAGE OBVIOUSLY SERIOUSNESS,
DEPENDING ON WHAT HAPPENS THE
LEVEL OF THE COMPLAINT. THEY'LL
DO THAT, SO THEY ARE TRIAGED.
PERFECT UM ALRIGHT. THAT'S ALL I
HAVE FOR YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR KOBACH MET IN VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU, MADAM PRO TIM.
I HAVE WAITED FOR THIS DAY. FOR
THOSE OF YOU IN THE AUDIENCE ARE
ON THE LISTENING OR WATCHING
ONLINE. I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
COOPER WHEN I SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND UM AND WORKING
ALONGSIDE ALL OF OUR SHERIFFS
MIGHT. HILLARY COUNTY SHERIFF'S
IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFF'S LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION. AND SO
I GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
WITH OTHER SHERIFFS AROUND THE
STATE, AND SHERIFF COOPER IS ONE
OF THEM. AS SOME OF MY QUESTIONS
ARE ACTUALLY MOST OF MY
QUESTIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ASKED ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD
WAS ABOUT, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY
NOT HAVING ENOUGH LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON STAFF. WHY DO WE
HAVE SO MANY OPEN VACANCIES MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE FOLLOWED UP ON
THAT IN YOUR ANSWERS WERE
COMPLETELY UM, ADEQUATE, AND I
HAVE NO QUESTIONS ON THAT. I, UM
MY OTHER QUESTION WAS ON SB TWO
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE'S
100 AND THREE POSITIONS FOR
THESE INVESTIGATORS OPEN AND
YOU'VE ONLY FILLED 52. I GET
JUST EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID. SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE ON
THAT GOING TO GO TO SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT ON MY QUESTIONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH. FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS. THERE WAS A
BILL WHEN YOU WERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND THIS IS JUST YOUR
OPINION. THERE WAS A BILL IN THE
ASSEMBLY WAS AUTHORED BY, UM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S BILK WORK, AND
IT WAS ASSEMBLY BILL 2188 IT
ACTUALLY IT WAS. IT WAS PROBABLY
BECAUSE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAD A BALLOT MEASURE ABOUT
LEGALIZING MARIJUANA, AND THIS
PARTICULAR PILL MADE BILL MADE
MARIJUANA A PROTECTED CLASS.
UNDEREMPLOYMENT LOT RACE,
RELIGION, GENDER, GENDER
IDENTITY AND EVERYTHING. THE
BUILDING TRADES WERE EXCLUDED
FROM THIS BECAUSE OF OBVIOUSLY
WORKING IN AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
SAFETY SENSITIVE POSITION. UM
LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS NOT. UH AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FEEL. I DO
WANT TO KNOW YOUR PERSONAL
OPINION. LET YOU KNOW MINE. SURE
IF YOU'RE GOING TO CARRY A GUN,
AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN A HIGH
SPEED CHASE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD BE IN PRISON, BUT FROM
THE REQUIREMENTS REQUIREMENTS TO
ALLOW THEIR PERSONNEL TO SMOKE
POT. I MEAN, THAT'S JUST ME, AND
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE APPROVED OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. BUT LIKE I
SAID, IF YOU'RE GOING TO CARRY A
GUN, AND YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATIONS AND
YOU'RE GOING TO BE A HIGH SPEED
TRACE WITH A VEHICLE. ONE
ACCIDENT, ONE SHOOTING, UH, IN
THE GUIDE TESTED POWER, THE GIRL
TEST POSITIVE IT'S GOING TO BE A
LAWSUIT TOWARDS THE CITY OR THE
COUNTY AND RESOURCES ARE JUST
GONNA BE FLOODED INTO FUNDING
LAWSUITS. NOW THAT'S JUST MY
OPINION. BUT YOU'VE BEEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE YOUR POSITION. AS THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF AND ON
THE SHERIFF STATE, CALIFORNIA
SHARES BOARD AND THEN ALSO BEING
ON POST. JUST SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS WITH ME ON THAT. YEAH
THANK YOU, SENATOR. IT IS
PROBLEMATIC AND THE BIG ISSUE
WITH THAT IS, UM, SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND WE SEE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE BUILDING
HERE WHEN I WAS HERE, I HAD TWO
EMPLOYEES THAT HAD ALCOHOL
PROBLEMS, AND WE SEE IT A LOT IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WHERE SOMEONE
COMES TO WORK UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF MISSING TIME FROM
WORK. THAT IS A PROBLEM IN ANY
JOB SECTOR BY YOU SEE IT QUITE
OFTEN, MORE OFTEN, LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO WE BUILT ON DAILY
BASIS. AND WITH THE NEW BILL,
YOU KNOW, I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
SEE MORE OF THAT PEOPLE ARE
GONNA TRY THAT. AND YOU'RE
RIGHT. YOU HAVE THE POWER TO
TAKE SOMEONE'S LIFE. I MEAN THAT
IT'S A PEACE OFFICER, SO YOU
DON'T WANT ANYBODY ON THE
INFLUENCE. AND YOU DON'T WANT TO
BEING IMPACTED OR IMPAIRED AND
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DO
IT. THAT'S THAT'S THE PROBLEM,
AND THAT'S THE ISSUE WITH THAT.
SO I THINK BECAUSE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY, ENORMOUS
RESPONSIBILITY THAT A PEACE
OFFICER HAS, UM, THEY DON'T GET
TO DO CERTAIN THINGS YOU GET IN
TROUBLE FOR DOING CERTAIN THINGS
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE DON'T
FURTHER JOBS. YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY A DIFFERENT JOB. YOU
DON'T GET TIME OFF. IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT EITHER GET
TERMINATED, OR YOU GET
SIGNIFICANT TIME OFF FOR DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE HER BEING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE AT WORK. SO
YEAH, YOU ARE HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD, AND WE WANT OUR PEACE
OFFICERS HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND
PROFESSIONAL, SO THEY REALLY
SHOULD BE EXEMPTED FROM THAT
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT SOMEONE
TO COME INTO CALL AND LIKE I
SAID OVER THE YEARS UH, NUMBER
OF PROBLEMS I'VE DEALT WITH
ALCOHOL. DAY IN AND DAY OUT WITH
PEOPLE AND THIS IS JUST GOING TO
ADD TO THE PROBLEM WITH IT.
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE CALLING
ALREADY. RIGHT RIGHT NOW. HEY,
WE CAN DO IT NOW, AND IT'S A BE
CAREFUL BECAUSE ON THE FEDERAL
PART OF OUR FEDERAL TASK FORCE
IS PREVENTED FROM IT, BUT YEAH,
IT'S PROBLEMATIC. I DO
UNDERSTAND THE TERMS SOME
EXTENSIONS. YOU HAVE A CLASS B
LICENSE. YOU DRIVE HEAVY
EQUIPMENT AT THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE OR WHATEVER. THEN YOU
WHAT? YOU ARE EXEMPTED. YOU
CANNOT BE SMOKING POT. BUT LIKE
I SAID, MY AND NOTHING AGAINST
RANK AND FILE NOTHING AGAINST
ANY OF THAT. BUT IT'S JUST MY
CONCERN ABOUT THE LIABILITY AND
THE EXPOSURE THAT WE HAVE.
ESPECIALLY NOW IT IS A PROTECTED
CLASS UNDER EMPLOYMENT AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT, FIRST RESPONDERS
FIREFIGHTERS THEY WERE NOT
EXEMPTED. UM BUT THERE WAS AN
EXEMPTION FOR BUILDING TRADES
AND CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE THEY
FELT LIKE THAT WAS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY SENSITIVE
POSITIONS, DRIVING HEAVY
EQUIPMENT BUILDING A BUILDING,
BUT I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
CARRYING A GUN AND DRIVING A
VEHICLE AND THOSE RESPONSES THAT
YOU'RE INDIVIDUALS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEALS WITH EVERY DAY
, THEY SHOULD BE EXEMPTED FROM
THAT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
MANDATED AS WELL. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR OPINION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. IT'S
MY HONOR TO SUPPORT YOU. AND I
WISH YOU NOTHING BUT THE BEST
AND YOU ARE REALLY A CLASS ACT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM.
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU. I'M GLAD MY
COLLEAGUES ASKED A LOT ABOUT SB
TO THE CERTIFICATION AND I HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT IT, BUT I THINK
YOU KIND OF FULLY ANSWERED IT
RELATED TO THE INVESTIGATORS AND
, YOU KNOW, KEEPING UP
PARTICULARLY THE LOOK BACK. I
DID FOLLOW UP. CLEARLY, I
SUPPORTED THAT. LEGISLATION
ALONG WITH SENATOR BRADFORD AND
I DID FOLLOW UP TO KIND OF GET A
SENSE OF THE LOOK BACK AND WHAT
THE DILEMMAS AND THE CHALLENGES
WERE. SO ASIDE FROM STAFFING,
WHICH IS CRITICAL AND VERY
IMPORTANT AND APPRECIATE YOUR
SHARING WITH US, THE STATE PAY
PIECE OF IT, UH, A NUMBER OF OUR
OTHER AGENCIES ARE HAVING
TROUBLE AS YOU INDICATED FUNDING
INVESTIGATORS. A LOT OF IT
BECAUSE OF SALARY AND NOT
ENOUGH. PEOPLE ARE AVAILABLE OR
WANTING TO DO THE JOB. UM SO THE
FEEDBACK IS REALLY HELPFUL.
OTHER THAN THAT, I MEAN, POST
HAS PRETTY MUCH FULLY ACCEPTED
KIND OF THE IMPORTANCE OF SB TWO
TO COMMUNITY AND THE LEGISLATURE
. YOU FEEL THAT THAT IS REALLY
TRUE FOR THE BOARD AS A WHOLE
HAS DONE A GREAT JOB, THE STAFF
GRADE. YOU'VE GOT A VERY SOLID
BOARD. I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A LOT OF GOOD THINGS FROM
THE BOARD, AND IT'S JUST TOUGH
TO GET THROUGH THIS AND GET
STARTED. AND SO I CHAIRED SUB
FOUR BEFORE WHICH THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND YOU KNOW, YOU
WOULD THINK THAT AN INVESTIGATOR
ACROSS THE STATE LEVEL WOULD BE
THE SAME SALARY, THEIR SIDE
LETTERS FOR EVERYBODY AND
DEPENDING ON DOJ MAKES 15% MORE
THAN SOMEONE THAT CANNABIS OR
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. IT'S JUST
CRAZY, AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
HURTS. I THINK FROM MY
EXPERIENCE THAT'S WHAT'S HURTING
POST IS JUST THE STATE AND
STATES SO BIG, JUST A SALARY
LEVELS. WHAT'S REALLY KILLING US
AND NOT JUST POST BUT A LOT OF
STATE AGENCIES BECAUSE THEY GO
AROUND. TO THE BEST PAYING
AGENCIES THAT THEY GET THAT THEY
CAN GET. AND WELL, THANK YOU. I
THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR A BIGGER KIND OF COMMENT. I
WANT TO MAKE IT THE END. I WANT
TO TURN TO. OBVIOUSLY YOU WERE
HERE WHEN WE DID IN 2019 8392
THE USE OF FORCE. AH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WEBER SHIRLEY
AT THAT TIME, WEBER AND THEN
ALSO, WE DID SP 230, WHICH WAS
CAVALLERO. TWO DIFFERENT PIECES
OF LEGISLATION. THAT SORT OF
WORKED HAND IN HAND IN TERMS OF
POLICIES THAT PROVIDE GUIDELINES
TO USE OF FORCE DE ESCALATION,
ALL OF THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND
SO THAT'S DONE. THOSE ARE PIECES
OF LEGISLATION CLEARLY IN
RESPONSE TO WHAT'S GOING ON
ACROSS AMERICA, NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IN OTHER PLACES,
AND YOU TALKED IN YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS ABOUT UM, YOU KNOW,
OFFICERS NOT WANTING TO SERVE
BECAUSE OF THIS DOUBLE DILEMMA
OF YOU KNOW HOW THEY'RE
PERCEIVED AND HELP ME THIS IS
SORT OF A ESOTERIC QUESTION. NOT
EXACTLY A DATA DRIVEN ONE. BUT
WHAT CAN WE DO TO, UM, REALLY
FIND A BALANCE BETWEEN AND NOT
JUST A BALANCE? WE'VE GOT TO
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE COMMUNITY WAS SAYING.
IN LOOKING AT THOSE GUIDELINES
AND CHANGING POLICIES AND
SUPPORT AND PIECES OF
LEGISLATION BUT ALSO THE NEED TO
HAVE PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS. LAW
ENFORCEMENT. YOU KNOW, THE
COMMUNITIES WANT TO BE SAFE. WE
ARE NOW GOING THROUGH A RASH OF
RETAIL THEFT. HUGE HERE. YOU'RE
DEALING WITH IT. UM HOW DO WE
STRIKE THAT BALANCE? HOW DO WE
CONVINCE LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT IT
IS A NOBLE PROFESSION? THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS YOU AND AT THE
SAME TIME, UNDERSTAND? WE DO
EXPECT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND WE WANT THE
DIVERSITY IN THE POLICE FORCE.
YOU REPRESENT PART OF THAT. SO
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT, UM THERE
IS NO RIGHT OR WRONG ANSWER. I
JUST THINK WE NEED TO GRAPPLE
WITH WITH ALL SIDES OF THIS AND
WE ARE LACKING. UM WE'RE LACKING
. I MEAN, EVERY DEPARTMENT YOU
MENTIONED YOUR VACANCY RATE. I
TALKED TO OUR SHERIFF. I TALKED
TO OUR POLICE CHIEF IN SAN DIEGO
. SAME SAME COMMENTS. I THINK
THE SOCIAL SOCIAL STIGMA REALLY,
THAT'S THE BIG THING. AND WHAT'S
CRAZY RIGHT NOW? YOU HAVE SMALL
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THAT OFFER
SIGNING BONUSES. SO LIKE BARRY
DEPARTMENTS, $75,000 SIGNING
BONUS TO COME WORK FOR HIM. A
LOT OF TINS 20 $30,000 SIGNING
BONUS IS TRYING TO ATTRACT
OFFICERS BECAUSE THE POOR SOUL
LIMITED AND I THINK YOU KNOW,
LIKE I SAID, IT'S A JOB WHERE
YOU WORK, YOU WORK WEEKENDS, YOU
WORK HOLIDAYS. UM YOU'RE GETTING
CALLS BECAUSE SOMEONE'S HAVING A
CRISIS OR NOTHING GOOD HAPPENING
, SO IT'S SO IT'S NEGATIVITY. SO
A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE HAVE STEERED
AWAY FROM THAT. AND HOW DO WE?
YOU'RE RIGHT. THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION. MADAM SPEAKER, MADAM
PROTEIN. HOW DO WE BRING PEOPLE
BACK WITH THAT? BECAUSE THE PAY
IS GOOD. THE PAY IS ABSOLUTELY
GOOD, BUT THERE'S OTHER JOBS YOU
CAN DO WHERE YOU ARE OFF ON
WEEKENDS AND ESPECIALLY NOW WITH
HAVING TO TELECOMMUTE AND FOLKS
CAN WORK FROM THEIR HOME. SO
IT'S JUST TOUGH. I DON'T KNOW
HOW HOW WE HOW WE GET THERE IS
TOUGH. I MEAN, WE'VE DONE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS AND WE'VE
REACHED OUT, BUT IT'S STILL AND
EVERYONE'S HAVING THE SAME
PROBLEM. BUT I THINK WHAT IS
REALLY HURTING THE MOST IS JUST
THE SOCIAL STIGMA. DON'T WANT TO
BE A COP. I TALK TO YOUNG KIDS
ALL THE TIME. HEY, IT'S A GREAT
JOB. COME IN. I DON'T WANT TO BE
A COP. I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
IT'S JUST I DON'T I WISH I HAD
AN ANSWER. THAT WAS PERFECT FOR
YOU. I DON'T HAVE ONE IN RIGHT
NOW. I'M A YEAR IN ABOUT IT'S
FROST. I'M ON MY STAFF AND STAFF
CONSTANTLY FOR EVERY 100
CANDIDATES THAT APPLY, YOU MIGHT
GET FIVE. THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
TO GO THROUGH. AND YOU KNOW, WE
DO DETECTOR TEST. WE DO A LOT OF
TESTING BECAUSE YOU WANT THE
RIGHT PERSON IN THERE. AND THESE
YOUNG KIDS THESE DAYS. UM THEY
DO SOME THINGS THAT ARE SILLY. I
CAN'T GET INTO. BUT IT'S JUST
THAT'S JUST YEAH, IT'S TOUGH, SO
YOU TRY TO WEED PEOPLE OUT, AND
THAT'S IT'S A TOUGH PROCESS TO
GET THROUGH. IS THERE A WALL
THAT POST PLAYS IN TRYING TO
MESSAGE OR SET A FRAMEWORK FOR
KIND OF THE BIGGER PROFESSION?
THEY DO? THEY DO A VERY GOOD JOB
. LIKE I SAID, IT'S JUST IT'S A
SOCIETAL THINGS RIGHT NOW. AND I
THINK WE GET THERE AT SOME
POINT, BUT POST HAS A ROLE IN
IT. DEFINITELY AND THEN THEY DO
THAT, SO I'M EXCITED TO WORK
WITH THEM AND BRING SOME THINGS
TO THEM ALONG WITH THE OTHER
POST COMMISSIONERS AND WE'VE GOT
A REALLY GOOD COMMISSION. THEY
GOT A LOT OF WOMEN WOMEN
SHERIFF'S ON THERE. I THINK
THERE'S 44 OTHER ONES HAD
CONFIRMATIONS OF THESE
CANDIDATES WHO ARE APPOINTEES
WHO WERE INCREDIBLE THAT'S
UNHEARD OF IN THE IN THE
SHERIFF'S AGENCIES. WELL THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
I THINK, UM, YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES
THE PUBLIC THINKS THAT WERE
THERE ALL THIS WAY OR ALL THAT
WAY. AND YOU KNOW, THIS IS
COMPLICATED. AND YOU KNOW, WE'RE
THE LARGEST STATE IN THE
COUNTRY, AND I THINK YOU KNOW,
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REALLY HAVE AN OPEN LINE OF
COMMUNICATION ABOUT HOW TO DO A
BETTER JOB. AND SO IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THESE THINGS I THINK ARE
COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY
LEGISLATORS WANT TO KNOW WHAT
CAN WE DO TO HELP? YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE WE'RE THE ONES MAKING
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE STRUGGLING. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
SO WHAT? IT WOULD BE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION OR HAT YOU
WEAR, IF ANY, AND VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS, MAINLY BECAUSE WE HAVE
TWO MORE PEOPLE WAITING IN THE
QUEUE TO BE APPOINTED, SO NO
PRESSURE, BUT BREVITY IS GOOD.
WE DID BETTER TODAY. I THINK
COLLEAGUES SO FAR. SO THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME. THANK YOU, TIM
TAYLOR WITH NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF INDEPENDENT BUSINESS. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT OF SHERIFF COOPER
DID THE COMMISSION, PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
UM WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH AND I
HESITATE TO CALL HIM SHERIFF
BECAUSE WE WORKED WITH HIM FOR
SO MANY YEARS, AND HE'S WORN SO
MANY HATS AS MAYOR, ASSEMBLYMAN
IN SHERIFF AND HE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN SOMEBODY THAT WE GO TO WHEN
WE DISCUSS RETAIL THEFT OR OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES. HE HAS
BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
POLICE OFFICERS AND ALSO SMALL
BUSINESSES AT THE SAME TIME, WE
AGAIN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT AND HOPE
THAT YOU WILL CONFIRM HIM TODAY.
HE'S OUTSTANDING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT SPEAKER WELCOME THANK
YOU, MADAM. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS,
ERIN REED. VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE
. UH THE GOVERNOR DID. WELL WE
LOVE THIS GUY. I'M GOING TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF BRIAN MARVEL,
PRESIDENT OF IRAQ WHOSE
UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF TOWN AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HIGHWAY PATROLMAN
JAKE JOHNSON, WHO'S ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF TOWN, OR
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
SURE. ABSOLUTELY BUT THEY HAVE
MEETINGS THEY COULDN'T GET OUT
OF. SO I GET THE PLEASURE OF
DOING THIS AND SAYING TO YOU, WE
WORK WITH THIS MAN FOR EIGHT
YEARS IN THE LEGISLATURE, HE'S
NOT JUST PASSIONATE ABOUT HIS
OFFICERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HE'S PASSIONATE ABOUT THE PUBLIC
AND PROTECTING THE PUBLIC. AND
SO ARE THE GROUPS THAT I
REPRESENT. AS YOU KNOW, MADAM
CHAIR. YOU'VE WORKED WITH US ON
MANY BILLS, AND WE DON'T SHY
AWAY. WE COME TO THE TABLE. WE
TALK AND WE TRY TO WORK THINGS
OUT. AND THAT'S THE MODEL THAT
JIM COOPER SETS FOR EVERYBODY
AND HIS TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY. HE
WORKED LOTS OF AMENDMENTS TO
BILLS TOOK BAD BILLS MADE THEM
BETTER CARRIED A LOT OF GOOD
BILLS. WE CAN'T THANK HIM ENOUGH
FOR THAT. BUT HE'S GOING TO
BRING A LOT OF TALENT AND
EXPERTISE TO POST AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT. SO WHEN I THANK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR I'M SURE I
MEAN, I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY
PROBLEM, BUT WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING HE DOES,
AND HE COULD HAVE TAKEN EASY
STREET. HE COULD HAVE RETIRED
YET 30 YEARS WITH THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT, HE COULD BE OUT.
ENJOYING HIMSELF TRAVELING
AROUND THE WORLD, BUT HE DIDN'T
HE SPENT EIGHT YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND HE SPENT NOW A
YEAR AS SHERIFF. I MEAN, HE'S AN
ENERGIZER BUNNY, SO CAN'T HOLD.
GOOD MAN DOWN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS,
PLEASE WELCOME. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COREY CELLS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFSASSOCIATION HAPPY TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SHERIFF
COOPER TODAY, I WOULD JUST SAY
TO YOUR QUESTION MADAM PRO TEM
ABOUT THE PROFESSION AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITY.
CAN'T UM, EVERY DAY I SEE
SHERIFF COOPER IN THE COMMUNITY
WITH DIFFERENT GROUPS WITH HIS
STAFF HE WAS WITH THE A SHIFT
LAST NIGHT IN CORRECTIONS IS
CONSTANTLY WITH HIS STAFF. HE'S
CONSTANTLY IN THE COMMUNITY AT
DIFFERENT EVENTS, AND JUST I
THINK A TREMENDOUS EXAMPLE OF
NOT ONLY THE LEADERSHIP THAT WE
HOPE FOR AND EXPECT OUT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXECUTIVE BUT A TRUE
MEMBER OF HIS COMMUNITY WHO
REALLY FIGHTS FOR THE PROFESSION
AND REALLY STANDS FOR THE BEST
OF PEACE OFFICERS EVERYWHERE SO
VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SHERIFF COOPER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HIGH
WELCOME. NEXT WITNESS. NEIL
FLOOD, VICE PRESIDENT FOR
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION, AND WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT JIM COOPER,
SHERIFF COOPER AND WE WORKED
WITH HIM IN A FEW DIFFERENT
ROLES IN THE PAST AND FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE DEFINITELY THINK
THAT HE WILL HELP GUIDE THE
FUTURE OF WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TO
BE IN THE COMMUNITY AND WHERE
YOU END UP IN REHABILITATION, SO
WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF SHERIFF
COOPER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS WELCOME. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRO TEM. SENATORS BRANDON
MARQUEE, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION PROUD TO
SUPPORT SHERIFF JIM COOPER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HIGH. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU.
TISH RYLANDER, FORMER ASSEMBLY
STAFFER OF OVER 20, PLUS YEARS
LONG TIME CONSTITUENT AND VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE AND SUPPORT OF
THE SHERIFF'S APPOINTMENT TODAY,
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS. WELCOME
THANK YOU, MADAM PRO TEM AND
SENATOR SKYLAR WANAKA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION, AS WELL
AS A FORMER 10 YEARS STAFF
MEMBER OF ASSEMBLYMAN COOPER AS
HIS COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR. I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW GREAT IT WAS
TO HAVE THE ASSEMBLYMAN AS A
BOSS. HE WAS ALWAYS PROFESSIONAL
, COURTEOUS AND JUST AN ABSOLUTE
AMAZING LEADER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS.
WELCOME. CHRIS LINDSTROM,
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL BUSINESS
LINES. WE'VE KNOWN JIM MANY
YEARS. THE MEMBER TRIBES WORK
WELL WITH THEM. HE'S UH, ALWAYS
BEEN THERE TO TALK ABOUT HOW TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY IN IN
PARTICULAR RELATED TO MM I P
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PERSONS AND TRAFFICKING OF
PERSONS OF PARTICULAR NATIVE
AMERICANS, AND WE'RE HOPING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM ON PL
280 GETTING A FIRM UNDERSTANDING
OF JURISDICTIONAL ROLES AND
TRIBAL LANDS, AND HE'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH. AND UH,
OVER THE YEARS, AND WE HOPE YOU
CONFIRM GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI WELCOME NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. TAYLOR, RUSSIAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERIES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SHERIFF COOPER AND THANK HIM
FOR HIS SERVICE. THANK YOU. HI.
WELCOME. HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
BRENDA BASS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SHERIFF COOPER'S
NOMINATION OR APPOINTMENT, SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI NATALIE
BASTARD. THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
SHERIFF JIM COOPER'S
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HI. WELCOME. LAWRENCE
GAINING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT OF SHERIFF COOPER'S
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU. OKAY? I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THOSE IN
SUPPORT. LET ME ASK THOSE WHO
ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO COME
UP AGAIN. SAME THING NAME HAD,
IF ANY, THAT YOU WEAR AND BRIEF
COMMENTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM PROTHOM AND
SENATORS. MY NAME IS TERRY
SHAWN'S ON THE 20 YEAR EMPLOYEE
OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY AND STATE
SENATE IN APRIL OF 2022
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S JIM COOPER,
SEXUALLY HARASSING AND
THREATENED ME WITH WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE DURING WORK HOURS ON
THE FIFTH FLOOR COMMON AREA OF
THE SWING SPACE IN THIS BUILDING
DURING AN 8.5 MINUTE DIATRIBE,
WHICH WAS CAPTURED ON SECURITY
FOOTAGE. JIM COOPER DEGRADED AND
DEMEAN ME BECAUSE I WAS NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF HIS CAMPAIGN FOR
SACRAMENT COUNTY SHERIFF AS HE
CONTINUED TO DEMEAN ME, HE BEGAN
SHOUTING. WHY DO YOU QUOTE? WHY
DO YOU HAVE A HARD ON FOR
MILITARY? FOLLOWED BY AT LEAST
10 AFFIRMATIVE STATEMENTS FROM
HIM YELLING YELLING AT ME! YOU
HAVE A HARD ON FOR ME AND YOU
HAVE A HARD ON FOR ME. AS A GAY
MAN. THIS WAS HIGHLY OFFENSIVE
AND HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE WAY TO
SPEAK TO ME OR ANY PERSON AFTER
THIS DIATRIBE, JIM COOPER THEN
LEANED INTO ME IN THE EYES AND
SAID, WELL, I HOPE YOU CAN SLEEP
WELL AT NIGHT AND THEN WALKED
AWAY. IN SHOCK. I WENT TO MY
OFFICE AND BEGAN TO FILE A WC WC
YOU COMPLAINT AGAINST JIM
COOPER. BUT AS I WAS TYPING HIS
WORDS, I HOPE YOU CAN SLEEP WELL
AT NIGHT ECHOED LOUDER AND
LOUDER MY MIND KNOWING THAT JIM
COOPER HAD RECENTLY BEEN
DETAINED AT A LOCAL AIRPORT FOR
ATTEMPTING TO TAKE A LOOK AND
WEAPON LOAD. EXCUSE ME A LOADED
GUN ONTO AN AIRPLANE AND WIDELY
KNOWN ACCOUNTS THAT JIM COOPER
CARRIED A LOADED GUN WITH HIM AT
ALL TIMES. INCLUDING AT HIS
SWIMMING SWING SPACE OFFICE. I
BECAME FEARFUL FOR MY SAFETY AND
THE SAFETY OF MY HUSBAND, WHO
ALSO WORKS FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AFTER MEETING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY CHIEF SERGEANT AT ARMS,
SHE DETERMINED THAT JIM COOPER'S
THREATS AGAINST ME WAS CREDIBLE
AND OFFERED TO HAVE ARMED
SERGEANT AT ARMS ESCORT ME TO
AND FROM THE STAFF PARKING
GARAGE TO MY OFFICE FOR A WEEK.
THIS BEHAVIOR IS UNBECOMING OF
ANY PUBLIC OFFICIAL WHETHER THEY
BE A LEGISLATOR, A LOCAL SHERIFF
OR AN APPOINTEE OF THE GOVERNOR.
JAMIE COOPER'S ACTIONS TO
SEXUALLY HARASS AND INTIMIDATE
ME IN MY WORKPLACE IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND UNBECOMING OF
ANY PUBLIC OFFICIAL. JIM COOPER
LACKS FUNDAMENTAL ETHICS AND
MORALS AND THE MORAL CAPACITY
NEEDED TO PROVIDE OBJECTIVE
GUIDANCE TO THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU REJECT HIS APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU, MR SHAWN'S THANK YOU.
YOU CAN LEAVE THAT. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE THAT LETTER. THANK YOU, UH,
OTHER WITNESSES. OKAY UM,
COLLEAGUES HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
WITNESSES FURTHER COMMENTS,
OKAY? UM I WOULD. I WOULD SAY WE
DID RECEIVE THE LETTER. THANK
YOU. MR SHAWN'S FOR THAT. I KNOW
THAT WAS PROBABLY NOT EASY,
WHICH WAS WHY WE ALSO MADE SURE
WE WERE ABLE TO GET. UM WE DON'T
AS THIS BODY, THE SENATE HERE.
ASSEMBLY COMPLAINTS TO THE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT. I
GUARANTEE YOU WE HAVE OUR OWN
AND WE WILL HAVE ONE TODAY AFTER
IN EXECUTIVE SESSION, SO WE DO
TAKE THESE ALLEGATIONS VERY
SERIOUSLY. WE DID ASK FOR THAT.
THE COMMENT THAT WE COULD GET
FROM THE ASSEMBLY RESPECTING
THAT. THERE ARE SEPARATE HOUSE.
WE DID RECEIVE THAT LETTER. I
THINK SENATOR LAIRD MADE
REFERENCE TO THAT. SO IT IS
DEFINITELY PART OF THE RECORD
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMING
FORWARD. UH COLLEAGUES, MADAM
VICE CHAIR NOMINATION, OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONFIRMATION. MADAM SECRETARY,
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
THEY'RE DIÆN BUG TROUBLE, GUY
SMALLWOOD QUIVERS. FORWARD CUEVA
SIDE, GROVE GROVE. I CAN INSIDE
5 TO 0. THANK YOU. WE WILL MOVE
YOUR CONFIRMATION TO THE FULL
SENATE FOR CONFIRMATION. WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE ABOUT A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS AND WE WILL COME
BACK AND I JUST WANT TO SAY TO
THOSE OF YOU WAITING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
PATIENTS. WE PROMISED TO BE
TIMELY AND BE RIGHT BACK AND
READY TO GO. GO ON.
YES, SITUATED BEFORE WE BEGIN. I
WAS LIKE I WAS REALLY LOOK AND
FEEL, MAN. THE ADDRESS.
OKAY I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE COMMITTEE BACK TO ORDER. AND
I KNOW THAT OUR VICE CHAIR WILL
BE RIGHT BACK. BUT WE HAVE
ENOUGH MEMBERS HERE TO CONTINUE
ON. LET ME AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE, AND TAMIKA FOSS,
THE UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATIONS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
WELCOME AGAIN AGAIN AGAIN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. UM I WANT
TO INVITE YOU TO DO A SIMILAR
THING, WHICH IS INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. FEEL FREE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT YOU WANT
TO MAKE OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WELCOME. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. UM I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE
YOU TODAY. I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE MY HUSBAND IN THE
AUDIENCE. KIM AND MY PARENTS WHO
DROVE SEVEN HOURS TO BE HERE. GO
AHEAD AND TELL US YOUR HUSBAND
AND YOUR PARENTS' NAMES OF MIKE.
AND MOM AND MY DAD IS MARVIN AND
MY MOM IS JANINE. LIKE IT SAID
THEY DROVE OVER SEVEN HOURS TO
BE HERE TODAY. MY BIGGEST FANS
RIGHT THERE. WELCOME WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY. UM MY
KIDS WOULD BE HERE, BUT THEY
HAVE JOBS AND LITTLE CHILDREN
WHO WOULD NOT BE AS PATIENT AS
SOME OF THESE OTHERS. SO THEY
ARE WATCHING THEM ON THE VIDEO.
SO I WANT TO THANK THEM, TOO,
FOR THEIR THEIR DEDICATION TO MY
CAREER, ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
WERE YOUNG AND I WORKED LONG
HOURS AND HOLIDAYS. SO UM
APPRECIATE THEM WATCHING. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE NUMEROUS
FRIENDS, MY CDCR FAMILY AND MY
MENTORS THAT HAVE SUPPORTED AND
GUIDED ME THROUGH THE CAREER.
MANY OF THAT ARE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE TODAY. I BEGAN MY
CAREER AT CDCR IN 1996 AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AT PELICAN
BAY STATE PRISON. I'VE HELD
NUMEROUS POSITIONS SINCE THEN
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT. AND I
WAS HONORED TO BE APPOINTED TO
THIS ROLE BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
BECAUSE I CARE ABOUT THIS
DEPARTMENT AND THOSE WE SERVE. I
CARE ABOUT THE STAFF WHO COME TO
WORK EACH DAY IN THESE DIFFICULT
ENVIRONMENTS, AND I ALSO CARE
ABOUT BEING A CHANGE AGENT AND
THE LIVES INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
GIVING THEM HOPE AND LEADING
THEM TO GO HOME AS SUCCESSFUL
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMUNITY. AND
BE OUR NEIGHBORS. EACH POSITION
I'VE HELD HAS PREPARED ME TO BE
EFFECTIVE AS THE UNDER SECRETARY
OF OPERATION. I AM EAGER TO MAKE
A LASTING IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA
THROUGH OUR EFFORTS TO FOSTER
CORRECTIONAL ENVIRONMENTS
FOCUSED ON REHABILITATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES, WELLNESS AND
STAFF DEVELOPMENT. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
POINTING ME TO THIS CRITICAL
ROLE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT, AND
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE SENATE
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. I VALUE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
MEANINGFUL CHANGE TO THIS
DEPARTMENT AND I WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A LONG CAREER. LET ME UM SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
CERTAINLY TO THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. UM SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. I'M GOING TO START AGAIN
WITH YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY. I'M
SORRY I WAS ILL. I REALLY WANTED
TO SPEND TIME WITH YOU BEFORE
TODAY'S HEARING, BUT I'M RELATED
TO GET A CHANCE TO CONNECT. UM I
JUST SAW MY GOOD FRIEND NEIL
FLOOD. WE WERE IN NORWAY
TOGETHER, AND WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME LOOKING AT THE NORWAY MODEL
AND THINKING. A LOT ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN AND YOUR ROLE IS
JUST GOING TO BE SO IMPORTANT TO
THAT TRANSFORMATION INTO A PLACE
WHERE PRISONS CREATE THE GOOD
NEIGHBORS THAT WE NEED BECAUSE
SO MANY FOLKS WILL COME HOME AND
HOW DO THEY COME HOME IN A WAY
WHERE THEY ARE CONTRIBUTING AND
SUPPORTING THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
WHERE THE WORKERS INSIDE OF THE
FACILITIES ARE SAFE? UM THE
QUESTION YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE
IS, YOU KNOW I SPENT MLK. WE GET
YOUR CHILA. WE WENT TO TOUR, THE
WOMEN'S PRISON, GOT TO SPEND
SOME TIME WITH THE NEW WARDEN.
THERE WHO HAS THE ABSOLUTE
CONFIDENCE OF THE RESIDENTS WHO
ARE THERE, BUT WE WERE STILL
INFORMED OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS THAT
ARE CONTINUING TO HAPPEN, UM
INSIDE OF THAT PRISON, WE KNOW
OF, YOU KNOW, ACCORDING TO
REPORTS, YOU KNOW THAT THERE WAS
ONE OFFICER, A CEO, A CEO WHO
WAS CHARGED WITH 96 COUNTS OF
SEXUAL UM, MISCONDUCT AGAINST 22
INCARCERATED WOMEN ABOUT 1% OF
THE PRISON POPULATION WAS ABUSED
BY THIS. INDIVIDUAL AND UM. WE
ALSO LEARNED FROM WOMEN WHO
REPORTED THOSE INSTANCES.
OFTENTIMES THEY FACED
RETALIATION AND UM, IN MANY
WAYS, LOSING THEIR PROGRAMMING
OR EDUCATIONAL CLASSES, UM THEIR
ABILITY TO BE AN UNRESTRICTED
HOUSING. UM SO THERE WAS THEY
WERE VICTIMIZED, AND THEN THEY
WERE VICTIMIZED AGAIN BY THE
SYSTEM. UM YOU KNOW, IT'S CLEAR
FROM THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
WOMEN THAT THIS IS A DEEPLY
SYSTEMIC ISSUE. IT'S NOT ABOUT
ONE ACTOR. IT'S ABOUT THE
SYSTEM. AND YOU KNOW THE PROCESS
TO REPORT THESE INCIDENCES AS
WELL AS TO MAKE FOLKS IN THOSE
IN THOSE FACILITIES SAFE. UM
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND YOU KNOW,
GIVEN YOUR LONG HISTORY AND
THIS, UM, DEPARTMENT AND YOUR
ROLE CAN YOU SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOU KNOW? WHAT DO YOU SEE?
THAT CAN BE PROACTIVELY DONE? TO
PREVENT THESE KINDS OF
INCIDENTS, INSTANCES FROM
HAPPENING. AND ALSO HOW DO WE
STRUCTURE. UM A GRIEVANCE
PROCESS THAT DOES NOT RETALIATE
AGAINST THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
HARMED. WHAT IS THE WAY WE COULD
CREATE SOME STRUCTURED
PUNISHMENT? UM THAT IS, UM
REALLY WHEN THINGS GO WRONG, UM,
BUT NOT WHEN SOMEONE HAS BEEN
VICTIMIZED. AND YOU KNOW, IS
THERE IN YOUR SENSE OF HOW THESE
FACILITIES ARE CREATED, UM REAL
SAFE HAVENS FOR WOMEN INSIDE OF
THE PRISONS THAT AREN'T
RESTRICTED HOUSING BUT A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN BE MADE WHOLE
HAVE A CHANCE TO HEAL AND BE
SUPPORTED WHEN THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH THIS KIND OF AN
INCIDENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. I TAKE THESE
ALLEGATIONS EXTREMELY SERIOUS
AND YOU KNOW, I WAS COMPLETELY
DEVASTATED ABOUT THIS INCIDENT.
UM, WHEN I WAS APPOINTED AS
UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATION THAT
VERY FIRST WEEK I WENT TO
CHOWCHILLA PRISON AND I SAT DOWN
AND I MET WITH THE WOMEN THERE
BECAUSE IT JUST IT BOTHERS ME TO
MY CORE THAT THIS WAS THIS
HAPPENED. IT HAPPENED OVER SUCH
A PERIOD OF TIME. UM, AND THAT
WE DIDN'T CATCH IT SOONER. I'M
COMMITTED THAT THIS WILL NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN. I THINK WITH THE
NEW LEADERSHIP THAT WE HAVE
THERE, THE NEW WARDEN SHE'S
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING. SHE IS OUT
THERE AND SHE TALKS TO THE
POPULATION. UM I AM STRONGLY.
STRONGLY CONDONE ANY STAFF
MEMBER CONDEMN ANY STAFF MEMBER.
DOES THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR. UM
THAT PERSON WILL BE PROSECUTED
AND SHOULD BE AND. MY GOAL IS TO
NEVER LET THIS HAPPEN AGAIN, AND
I THINK LEADERSHIP STAFF
TRAINING IS SUPER IMPORTANT TOWN
HALL MEETINGS WITH EVERYBODY
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ONLY IMPACT,
INCARCERATED POPULATION AND ALSO
IMPACTS THE STAFF THAT WORKED
THERE THAT WANT TO DO GOOD AND
ARE DOING A GOOD JOB EVERY DAY.
IT IMPACTS THEM AND THEIR TRUST
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS IN US. THAT
WE ARE PROTECTING PEOPLE. I
THINK THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
PEER SUPPORT SO OTHER
INCARCERATED POPULATION THAT
THOSE WOMEN CAN LEAN ON. ALSO
USING OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO COME IN, UM WE
HAVE A WORKGROUP OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT WORKGROUP NOW AND
PREVENTION. UM, THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. WE'RE DOING ALL KINDS OF
PROACTIVE THINGS. WHAT I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE IS BE REACTIVE TO
THESE KIND OF INCIDENTS. I WANT
TO HAVE A PROACTIVE AREA. LIKE
YOU SAID A PROTECTIVE AREA WHERE
WOMEN FEEL COMFORTABLE COMING
FORWARD AND SHARING AND TALKING
ABOUT IT. OUR POPULATION OF ARE
INCARCERATED WOMEN. MANY
COMMANDERS VICTIMS. THEY'VE
ALREADY HAD TRAUMA BEFORE THEY
EVEN COMING IN THROUGH OUR INTO
OUR SYSTEM. SO FOR THEM TO BE
VICTIMIZED AGAIN. IT'S JUST
DEVASTATING AND IT SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN. AND I CAN PROMISE YOU IN
THIS ROLE. I WILL. I WILL NOT
LET IT HAPPEN. I'M GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE. WE HAVE AN
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR NOW OF THE
FEMALE OFFENDER PROGRAM WHO GOES
AND VISITS BOTH THE
INSTITUTIONS. UM CCW, THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR WOMEN
AND THE ONE IN CHOWCHILLA. SHE
MEETS WITH THE POPULATION
QUARTERLY. UM AND THEN, WITH THE
NEW LEADERSHIP THAT WE HAVE, YOU
KNOW, JUST BEING OUT THERE AND
BEING AWARE WE'VE ALSO
ESTABLISHED WHERE ANY SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATION GOES OUT
OF THAT INSTITUTION DIRECTLY TO
OFFICE. INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
REVIEW. THAT STARTED IN JANUARY
OF 22. SO THAT IS A KIND OF A
FAIRLY NEW PROCESS WHERE YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT JUST LOOKED AT BY
THE INSTITUTION AND THE STAFF
THAT WORKED THERE BUT BY
EVERYBODY, WE ALSO MONITOR THOSE
CASES. SO IF SOMEONE COMES
FORWARD WITH AN ALLEGATION OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, WE MONITOR
THAT INDIVIDUAL. TO ENSURE
THERE'S NO RETALIATION FOR A
MINIMUM OF 90 DAYS. THAT MEANS
NO BED MOVES. NO PROGRAM CHANGES
, NO WRITE UPS FOR THINGS WE
MEET WITH THEM TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE NOT FEELING RETALIATED
AGAINST, SO I THINK THOSE NEW
PROCESS AS WELL HELP I STILL
THINK WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
UM WE HAVE TO ENSURE OUR STAFF
ARE COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD
WHEN THEY EVEN SUSPECT SOMETHING
IS GOING ON. UM AND IN THIS CASE
THERE. THIS WAS A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME AND WE HAVE TO. WE HAVE TO
KNOW THAT OUR STAFF ARE
COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD. SO I
CAN TELL YOU I'M COMMITTED TO
THIS, AND I JUST RECENTLY WENT
BACK TO THE WOMEN'S INSTITUTION
TWO WEEKS AGO, AND I SAT WITH
THE SAME WOMEN'S ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND I WALKED AND I
TALKED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE AND IT
FELT BETTER. IT JUST IT FELT
BETTER FROM THE FIRST TIME I WAS
THERE, SO I DO SEE IT GETTING
BETTER AS FAR AS PEOPLE ABLE TO
TALK AND BE MORE OPEN. I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WAS VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE PEER SUPPORT TEAMS AND THE
ADVISORY GROUP AND WOULD LOVE TO
STAY IN TOUCH WITH YOU. AS YOU
LOOK AT THAT METRICS IN TERMS OF
HOW WE'RE BETTER PROTECTING
WOMEN AND UM AFTER WONDER WHY
DON'T WOMEN JUST PROTECT WOMEN
INSIDE OF THESE FACILITIES, AND
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT. HOW DO WE
UNTRACKED WOMEN TO PROTECT AND
SUPPORT WOMEN INSIDE OF OUR
FACILITIES? HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION FOR YOU, MAINLY BECAUSE
YOU ARE IN CHARGE OF FACILITIES,
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
REALLY, UM, INTERESTING TO ME. I
WAS PART OF A BILL SB 150, WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT COMMUNITY
BENEFITS. AS A WAY OF
STRENGTHENING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. SO WHERE WE ARE
MAKING INVESTMENTS TO BUILD
ROADS, FOR EXAMPLE, WE ARE
LOOKING. HOW DO WE BUILD LOCAL
HIRE TARGETED HIGHER, INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF APPRENTICES AND
REALLY CALLING IN COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES? AND I WONDER, YOU
KNOW, INSIDE OF OUR PRISON
SYSTEM. I HAD A CHANCE TO MEET
WITH SOME RESIDENTS FROM
LANCASTER STATE PRISON. WHO, UM,
WE'RE WORKING AS PLUMBERS
ESSENTIALLY INSIDE OF THE STATE
PRISON. THEY WERE MAKING ABOUT
EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR. AND WHAT I
ASKED THEM IF THEY KNEW WHAT A
PLUMBING UNION WAS. THEY DID NOT
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT. IT
STRUCK ME AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE UTILIZE OUR
CONTRACTORS. INSIDE OF OUR
SYSTEM AND HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT
, YOU KNOW, A REQUIREMENT OF
BUILDING SKILLS AND
APPRENTICESHIP USING THE
CONTRACTORS THAT WE HAVE TO HELP
MAINTAIN OUR VARIOUS FACILITIES,
MEANING A SKILL AND TRAIN MODEL,
A LEARNING MODEL. AND I WONDER.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA MODEL WOULD BE OPEN
TO FACILITATING SORT OF LOOKING
AT? WHERE ARE THERE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS KIND OF
CONTRACTING METRICS, WHICH WOULD
BRING IN LOCAL RESIDENTS AND
HOPEFULLY BUILD SKILLS AND, YOU
KNOW, A NEW GROUP OF NEIGHBORS
WHO ARE COMING OUT WITH INDUSTRY
NETWORK. SO I'M CURIOUS WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ABOUT THAT. I
LOVE THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THROUGH
CAL P I L P I WE HAVE FOR THEM.
UM AND WE HAVE THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PIECES. THEY
AREN'T QUITE 100% APPRENTICESHIP
. THEY DON'T COME OUT WITH A
CERTIFICATE, BUT THEY GET REALLY
GOOD LEARNING SKILLS THERE WITH
THOSE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE, UM, I WELCOME ANYONE THAT
WANTS TO COME IN AND WORK WITH
US ANY LABOR UNIONS. I WOULD
LOVE FOR MORE PEOPLE TO REACH
OUT TO US AND SAY WE WANT TO
COME IN AND BE A PART OF THE
CORRECTION ENVIRONMENT AND TEACH
SKILLS AND HAVE MEANINGFUL JOBS
FOR PEOPLE WHEN THEY GET OUT OF
THE OUT OF OUR INSTITUTIONS. WE
HAVE A PROGRAM AT SOLANO, THE
DELANCEY STREET PROGRAM, WHICH
TEACHES PEOPLE SKILLS IN MONEY.
UM IT'S A IT'S A RESTAURANT.
IT'S REALLY JUST A LITTLE
RESTAURANT. IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN,
YOU REALLY SHOULD GO. THEY COOK
REALLY GOOD MEALS, BUT WE TEACH
THEM. YOU KNOW, FOOD ORDERING
CHEF SKILLS WAITING ON TABLES.
CASH REGISTER SKILLS. THEY'RE
LEARNING AN ENTIRE RESTAURANT
BUSINESS. REALLY IT'S A REALLY
GREAT PROGRAM, IN ADDITION TO
CODING PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
VALLEY STATE PRISON, WE JUST
STARTED A TINY HOUSE PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THE HOMELESS WHERE
THEY'RE LEARNING TO READ
BLUEPRINTS AND EVERYTHING IN
CONSTRUCTION ON UP TO FINISHING
THE HOUSE. I JUST RECENTLY
VISITED THE PROGRAM TO SEE HOW
IT WAS GOING THERE JUST WAITING
FOR SOME MORE TOOLS, BUT THEY'VE
ALREADY GOT THEIR POPULATION IN
THEIR EXCITED TO START THAT
PROGRAM. UM I'M ALWAYS EXCITED
TO LOOK FOR NEW PROGRAMS. I
TALKED TO SENATE SENATOR KOEBERG
YESTERDAY ABOUT JOINT VENTURES.
UM AND WE DO HAVE ABOUT FORGE
RIGHT VENTURES CURRENTLY IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS, BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO EXPLORE
MORE. CAN WE GET MORE BUSINESSES
COMING IN AND USING OUR
POPULATION AND TEACHING THEM
SKILLS AND GIVING THEM LEARNING
EARNING WAGES THAT THEY CAN PUT
IN SAVINGS FOR WHEN THEY GET
OUT? SO I LOVE ANYONE THAT WANTS
TO COME KNOCK ON OUR DOOR AND
COME INTO OUR TO OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND HELP,
ESPECIALLY LABORERS AND
CONTRACTORS. QUESTIONS RAISED
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
APPRENTICESHIP IN PRISONS IS
SPACE FOR TRAINING AND
FACILITIES. AND I'M ALWAYS
CURIOUS AS YOUR CREATING SORT OF
EMPTY FACILITIES. HOW IS IT THAT
WE ARE SHORT ON SPACE TO DO
TRAINING AND EDUCATION INSIDE OF
OUR PRISONS? CAN YOU TALK MORE
ABOUT THE FACILITIES ISSUE AND
DO WE DO WE NOT HAVE ENOUGH ROOM
FOR CLASSROOMS OR WE OR OR ARE
THEY LOCATED IN DIFFERENT? LOOK
I'M I'M CURIOUS. WHAT IS THE
CHALLENGE AROUND THE FACILITIES
PIECE? I THINK YOU KNOW, UM,
WHEN HIS PRISONS WERE DESIGNED
THEY WERE NOT DESIGNED FOR
REHABILITATION. THEY WERE
DESIGNED FOR JUST HOUSING THE
POPULATION. SO WE DIDN'T HAVE A
LOT OF CLASSROOM SPACE. WE
DIDN'T HAVE A BIG MENTAL HEALTH
PART. WE DIDN'T HAVE A BIG
HEALTHCARE PIECE, AND NOW WE DO.
A LOT OF OUR SPACE HAS BEEN
TAKEN UP. BY YOU KNOW, UM, THE
NEEDS OF THE POPULATION. THE
MENTAL HEALTH, THE MEDICAL. WE
HAVE A VERY ROBUST SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM. UM WHICH TAKES
UP A LOT OF SPACE. WE DO HAVE
CLASSROOM SPACE. WE HAVE TO GET
CREATIVE WITH THE SPACE THAT WE
HAVE. WITH THE REDUCED
POPULATION. IT HAS HELPED. UM,
TO GET SOME OF THOSE SPACES LESS
CROWDED AND LESS OF A WAIT LIST
FOR PEOPLE TO GET INTO THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE DO HAVE, UM,
BUT WE HAVE TO GET CREATIVE WITH
THE SPACE WE HAVE. WE USED
VISITING ROOMS WHEN THEY'RE OFF
THE HOURS. WE USE DINING ROOMS
WHEN THEIR OFF HOURS OUR
CLASSROOMS BECOME SELF HELP
PROGRAMS ARE JIM'S BECOME
PROGRAMMING AREAS. SO WE DO TRY
TO USE THE SPACE WE HAVE FOR,
YOU KNOW, UM, IN EVERYTHING, BUT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE CLOSED
PRISONS AND THE CLOSED
FACILITIES THIS IS JUST KIND OF
KNEW WHERE WE'VE JUST RECENTLY
CLOSED SOME YARDS WITHIN
INSTITUTIONS. UM FOR EXAMPLE,
PELICAN BAY CLOSED THEIR SHOE
PROGRAM ON ONE SIDE. UM IF WE
CAN USE THAT FOR PROGRAM SPACE,
I THINK THAT WE WOULD DEFINITELY
DO THAT. AND SAME DOWN IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO. WE CLOSED THE
FACILITY OVER THERE IF WE CAN
STAND UP AND VOTE PROGRAM OVER
THERE, THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THANK YOU. I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONFIRMATION AND MAYBE
WORKING WITH YOU ON THESE
EFFORTS AROUND REHABILITATION
AND HOW TO MAXIMIZE OUR SPACE
FOR BUILDING THE KINDS OF FOLKS
WE KNOW WE CAN BUILD AND BRING
BACK HOME AND TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. SO THANK YOU. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. AND WHAT TO ME WHETHER YOU
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
ALCOA BOG. SO WE HAD QUITE A
LENGTHY CONVERSATION, AND I
THINK WE SHARE THE SAME GOALS
AND VISION. FOR MANY OF THE
PROS, WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
IMPLEMENTED WITH OUR, UM. ARE
IMPRISONED POPULATION ON THAT
END, I'M GOING TO, UM I THINK
YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT? I THINK
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE HAD OR SOME OF THE
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS THAT WE
ACTUALLY DISCUSSED YESTERDAY. SO
I'M GONNA I'M GONNA LEAVE IT AT
THAT. SO I'M GOING TO GO TO A
DIFFERENT ONE, WHICH HAS TO DO
WITH THE LAST STATE AUDIT OF THE
CDCR REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
FOUND FOUND. SORRY. THE QUESTION
IS, THEY FOUND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD FAILED TO PLACE
PEOPLE IN PROGRAMS BASED ON
THEIR REHABILITATIVE NEEDS. AH,
WHAT WAS DONE TO ADDRESS THE
AUDIT'S FINDINGS TO ENSURE
INMATES ARE PRIORITIZED FOR A
WEEK REHABILITATION PROGRAM IS
BASED ON THE RISKS AND
REHABILITATIVE NEEDS BEFORE THEY
ARE RELEASED. WE LOOK AND
EVALUATE ALL OF OUR POPULATION
ON THEIR NEEDS. THEY GO THROUGH
A INTERVIEW WITH A COUNSELOR. WE
LOOK AT THEIR EDUCATION NEEDS IF
THEY CAN'T READ OR WRITE, WE TRY
TO MATCH THEM WITH A PURE
LETTERS. THREE PROGRAM, UM WE
TRY. TO INDIVIDUALIZE EVERY
SINGLE INCARCERATED PERSON
COMING INTO OUR INSTITUTIONS. IT
STARTS AT THE RECEPTION CENTER
WHERE WE LOOK AT THEIR NEEDS,
AND THEN WE TRY TO MATCH THEM TO
WHAT INSTITUTION HAS THOSE
PROGRAMS. UM. I WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE TO GET MORE INFORMATION ON
THE AUDIT REPORT THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT TO GET YOUR
DETAILS ON IT. UM AND ON THE
WAIT LIST, BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT WE? WE ARE WORKING STRONGLY
HARD TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS THE
RIGHT PERSON IN THE RIGHT PRISON
IN THE RIGHT PROGRAM. THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR
REHABILITATION AND RE ENTRY AND
GOING HOME. ONE THING I REALLY,
REALLY LIKE A LOT THAT WE DO AND
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT ON IS OUR MALE COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAMS AND ARE FEMALE
COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAMS. THEY
DO SUCH A GREAT JOB OF TAKING
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
INCARCERATED. THEY GET TO GO OUT
AND WORK IN THE COMMUNITY. THEY
GET, UM THEY GET COUNSELING.
THEY GET REAL LIFE EXPERIENCES
BEFORE THEY'RE ACTUALLY RELEASED
TO GO HOME AND GET REAL JOBS. UM
SO I MIGHT NOT HAVE UNDERSTOOD
YOUR QUESTION, BUT, UM SO I
APOLOGIZE. NO WORRIES. NO
WORRIES. I THINK I SHOULD HAVE
PROBABLY PUT A LITTLE MORE INTO
CONTEXT. THIS IS JUST GIVING YOU
THE QUESTION. SO, UM UM SO. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE THAT HAS
COME TO MY ATTENTION IS THAT, UM
THE CDCR REPORTS THAT IN THE
FALL OF 2020 TO 34% OF PEOPLE
LEFT PRISON WITHOUT THEIR
ACADEMIC NEEDS BEING MET. 71%
LEFT WITH OTHER EMPLOYMENT IS
BEING MET IN 39% LEFT WITHOUT
THEIR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
NEEDS BEING MET. SO DATA ALSO
SUGGEST THAT THESE TRENDS TINT
10 TRENDS EXTEND TO THE PAROLE
POPULATION, FOR EXAMPLE, IN 20
TO 36% OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAD
BEEN ON PAROLE FOR AT LEAST ONE
YEAR HAD NOT PARTICIPATED IN ANY
CDCR OFFENDED PROGRAMS THAT MITT
THAT REHABILITATIVE NEEDS. WE
BRIEFLY TOUCHED YESTERDAY ON THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW, IN PUBLIC
SAFETY, WE SAW SEVERAL BILLS
THAT HAD TO DO WITH THE
ALLOCATION OF THE FUNDING FOR
THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE THE
INMATE POPULATION HAD ACCESS TO
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE, UM
CONDUCIVE TO THE ACTUAL NEEDS OF
THE POPULATION. SO WHEN WE LOOK
AT THESE BILLS THAT ARE
BASICALLY ARE ADDRESSING
CONCERNS WITHIN THE SYSTEM, AND
THEN WE HAVE THESE DATA THAT
SHOWS THESE PROGRAMS I WANT TO I
WANT I WANT. I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW HOW WE'RE ADDRESSING THESE
AUDIT FINDINGS IN THE DATA THAT
SHOWS THESE FACTS AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO REMEDY THAT MOVING
FORWARD. OKAY THANK YOU. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
QUESTION. UM WE DO HAVE WAITLIST
FOR PROGRAMS AND WE TRY TO
MAXIMIZE THOSE GOING HOME TO
ENSURE THEIR IN SOME TYPE OF
PROGRAM BEFORE THEY ARE
RELEASED. WITH OUR PAROLE
POPULATION. WE HAVE RE ENTRY
PROGRAM. NOW THAT IS FOCUSING.
WE HAVE A NEW DIRECTOR THAT JUST
RESTRUCTURED DURING COVID. WE
KIND OF GOT AWAY FROM, UM
ENSURING PEOPLE HAD REENTRY
SERVICES UPON RELEASED. THEY'VE
SINCE RESTRUCTURED, AND WE NOW
HAVE THAT REENTRY PEACE UPON
PAROLE WHERE THEY'RE LOOKING AT
ALL OF THOSE, UM, IMPORTANT UH,
YOU KNOW, JOBS, JOB SKILLS AND
WHATNOT IN MEETING WITH THEM AND
ENSURING THE COMMUNITY HAS
SERVICES FOR THEM AND PRIOR TO
GETTING OUT. UM WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT WITH OUR DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION PROGRAM
ESTABLISHING REENTRY PROGRAMS IN
ALL OF OUR INSTITUTIONS. WE HAVE
PRE PAROLE PEOPLE THAT WORK
INSIDE OUR INSTITUTIONS. UM BUT
WE REALLY GOT TO MATCH PEOPLE UP
WITH THOSE IMPORTANT JOB SKILLS
AND WHAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY GET
OUT SOMETIMES YOU KNOW, AND I
WAS JUST TALKING TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS AT VALLEY STATE
PRISON THAT ARE LIFERS THAT ARE
DOING PEER SUPPORT, AND THEY'RE
DOING REENTRY PROGRAM
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOUNGER
POPULATION COMING IN. UM AND
THAT PEER SUPPORT THAT ONE ON
ONE SOME PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THEY
DON'T WANT THE PROGRAMMING AND
WE NEED TO PUSH THEM IN THAT
DIRECTION, SO HAVING
INCARCERATED POPULATION WORKING
WITH THE POPULATION THAT'S KIND
OF ON THE FENCE ABOUT GOING INTO
PROGRAM HAS BEEN HUGE. UM SO
WHEN I TALK TO THEM, YOU KNOW
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO BETTER.
THEY SAID, THIS KIND OF PROGRAM
OR WE'RE HERE. TALKING TO THE
POPULATION IS VERY HELPFUL
BECAUSE I CAN TELL SOMEONE ALL
DAY LONG. YOU NEED TO GO TO
PROGRAM YOU NEED TO, YOU KNOW,
AND I SOUND LIKE THEIR MOM SO
THEY DON'T QUITE LISTEN TO ME.
BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS, YOU KNOW
THEY THEY'VE DONE A LONG TIME
THEY CHANGE THEIR WAYS. AND WE
TALKED ABOUT HOW CAN WE GET MORE
PEOPLE INTO PROGRAMS AND WANT TO
BE A PART OF THE PROGRAM? I
THINK WHEN THEY GET THERE YOU
KNOW THEY SOME SOME OF THE
POPULATION, YOU KNOW, GET FORCED
TO GO INTO SOMETHING. THEY DON'T
REALLY WANT TO DO IT, BUT IT'S
MIGHT GIVE THEM SOME CREDITS. SO
THEY DO IT. THEN THEY REALLY
LIKE IT, AND THEN THEY START
GROWING AND THEY GO INTO MORE
AND MORE. ONE THING THEY DID
TELL ME, THOUGH, IS SOMETIMES
WHEN THEY'RE COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM, AND THEY HAVE SHORT
SENTENCES. WE'RE NOT GIVING THEM
THE TIME TO REHABILITATE SO
BECAUSE THEY DON'T EVEN GET A
CHANCE TO GET INTO A PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE GETTING OUT. SO I WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE DATA AS FAR
AS THE 30 34% IN 22. UM IT MIGHT
BE RELATED TO, UM IT MIGHT BE
RELATED TO COVID AT THE TIME,
YOU KNOW, AND IT'S COMING OUT OF
IT, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE WE HAD
SHUT DOWN A LOT OF PROGRAMS. UM,
AND A LOT OF SELF HELP. PEOPLE
YOU KNOW, COULDN'T COME INTO OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND, UM, SO THAT
DATA MIGHT BE A REFLECTION OF
THAT. AND I REALLY SEE NOW THAT
WE'RE IN A GROWING PERIOD OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEXT AUDIT IS
PROBABLY WHAT I SHOULD SAY. AND
I BET THE NUMBERS WILL LOOK
BETTER. OKAY AND THEN A FOLLOW
UP ON THOSE AND THAT COURSEWORK
IN THOSE PROBLEMS THAT ARE BEING
GIVEN GRANTED. I'M GLAD YOU MADE
THAT DISTINCTION ABOUT WHEN THIS
THIS THIS DATA WAS RELEASED IN
2022. I DIDN'T HAVE NOT MADE
THAT CONNECTION ON THAT END, BUT
THERE'S A AND THERE'S ANOTHER,
UM THERE WAS ANOTHER AUDIT. UM
THAT WAS RELEASED IN JANUARY OF
2019. AND IT WAS HAD TO DO WITH
THE CDCR S COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY PROGRAMS. THAT FOUND
THAT PROGRAMS HAD NOT REDUCED
RECIDIVISM. SO UM, IT SAYS HERE
THAT IT FAILED TO ENSURE THAT
THE VENDORS PROVIDING THE CBT
PROGRAMS WHERE USING EVIDENCE
BASED CURRICULA. IN ADDITION,
THE AUDIT FOUND THAT THE CDCR
HAD FAILED TO PLACE PEOPLE IN
PARAMUS BASE AND REHABILITATIVE
NEEDS. SO THAT WAS ALSO AND THAT
62% OF THE PEOPLE RELEASED FROM
PRISON. OH HERE WE GO. HERE'S AN
UP. WELL NOT UPDATED. THIS IS
STILL 67 YEARS AGO. WE HAVE
STATED NEEDS THAT 62% OF THE
PEOPLE RELEASED FROM PRISON IN
2017 AND 18 HELP MET. NONE OF
THEIR REHABILITATIVE NEEDS. SO
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH REGARDS TO
THE QUALITY OF THE EVIDENCE,
BASED, OF COURSE, WORK THAT IS
BEING PROVIDED, UM CURRENTLY, UM
IN IN IN OUR PRISONS. WE ARE
CONSTANTLY LOOKING AT THE
COURSEWORK AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF RELOCATION
PROGRAMS. UM HAVE A NEW DIRECTOR
THERE RIGHT NOW, A MATTER OF
FACT AND UM, WE'RE CONTINUALLY
LOOKING AT WHAT WE'RE TEACHING.
UM AND IS IT IS IT VALUABLE TO
WHEN THEY GET OUT? I MEAN, I
THINK WE'RE CONSTANTLY LOOKING
AT OUR CURRICULUM. UM I THINK WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER. WE REALLY LOOK AT
THAT POPULATION BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE MADE UP OF. A LOT OF
OUR POPULATION HAS DRUG PROBLEMS
. UM AND REALLY FOCUSING ON ON
THAT, BUT ALSO I THINK WE'RE
CONTINUALLY LOOKING AT OUR AT
OUR CURRICULUM TO MAKE IT
BETTER. UM TO SEE IF IT'S
RELEVANT TO TODAY'S COMMUNITIES
AND WHAT'S BEING TAUGHT OUT
THERE. I. I DON'T REALLY HAVE A
SOLID ANSWER ON THIS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T LOOK AT THAT REPORT
BEFORE COMING IN HERE TO REALLY
ANALYZE THE DATA, BUT I CAN I
CAN DEFINITELY GET YOU AND
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU, UM, ON
DETAILS OF DATA OF LIKE, WHAT IS
RELEVANT AND WHAT WE SEE AS
BEING, YOU KNOW, UM IMPORTANT.
TO MAKING SURE THAT THESE KIND
OF AUDITS YOU KNOW NUMBERS
AREN'T OUT THERE. OKAY AND WE'RE
INCREASING OUR YOU KNOW OUR
NUMBERS TO LOOK BETTER. MY GOAL.
HONESTLY AS YOU KNOW, I LOOK AT
NUMBERS ALL DAY LONG. BUT MY
GOAL IS REALLY THE RIGHT PRISON,
THE RIGHT PERSON AND THE RIGHT
PROGRAM AND ENSURING THAT
INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE I LOOK AT
EVERYBODY LIKE AN INDIVIDUAL
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE, AND ARE WE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO REHABILITATE
THEM? AND ARE WE GIVING THEM
WHAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY GET OUT
OF PRISON AND FOLLOWING THEM? ON
THEIR PAROLE JOURNEY TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST CHECKING A
BOX, BUT MAKING SURE THAT THEY
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY
GET OUT FROM HOUSING TO JOBS TO
FAMILY SUPPORT, WHATEVER IT IS
THAT THEY NEED, UM SO YOU KNOW
WHEN IT I DO LOOK AT THE AUDITS,
BUT I REALLY TAKE IT MORE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL. I'VE GOT TO GO DOWN
TO THE INDIVIDUAL AND WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE. AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE IS NOT
CONCERNED BY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
LENSES THAT I HAVE IS TO ENSURE
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ACTUALLY DO
BENEFIT. THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
YES. HAVE THEM COME BACK. I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE FOR ME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. IT WAS
NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. MAN INVITED HERE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRO TIM. HOW
ARE YOU TODAY, MA'AM. THERE IS A
LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED
, UH, FULL DISCLOSURE REPRESENT
CURRAN COUNTY OR OIL INDUSTRIES
TO PROVIDE EMPLOYEES,
OPPORTUNITIES AND UPWARD
MOBILITY UPWARDS $300,000 A YEAR
. IF WE GET OUR PERMITS BACK,
I'LL TAKE EVERY SECOND CHANCER
YOU HAVE BECAUSE WE WENT FROM
30% DOWN TO 13% BUT NOT BECAUSE
WE WERE LAYING PEOPLE OFF. THAT
WAS SECOND CHANCERS AND WISHES
TO TREMENDOUSLY OFF BECAUSE WE
IMPORT OIL HERE THAT WE USE
INSTEAD OF PRODUCING HERE, BUT
IF YOU IF WE EVER GET OUR
PERMITS BACK, MAYBE WITH THE NEW
GOVERNOR SOMETHING, UH. JUST
SAYING WE WOULD TAKE EVERY
SECOND CHANCE OR YOU HAVE
BECAUSE THANK YOU. ANYBODY A
SKILL IN THE TRADE THAT'S
WILLING TO SHOW UP AND DO THE
JOB AND SO JUST THROWING THAT
PLUG IN THERE. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. I KNOW A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES FOLLOWED UP
ON, YOU KNOW. THE BAD THINGS
GOING ON IN THE PRISON, BUT I
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT STAFF. I KNOW
THAT STAFF GOES INTO THAT
FACILITY OR THOSE FACILITIES
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND STAFF
DEALS WITH A LOT OF THINGS. I
TOURED CURRENT VALLEY PRISON,
PELICAN BAY AND OTHERS, AND, UM,
IT'S A. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. AND MY
COLLEAGUE MR KOBACH, I AGREE
THAT THEY NEED TO BE PREPARED
WHEN THEY GET OUT BECAUSE THE
BEST SOLUTION TO POVERTY IS A
JOB SO THAT THEY DON'T GO BACK
AND THEY'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEMSELVES, AND HOPEFULLY WE
TAKE A LOT OF WE HAD TO DO A
BILL. I THINK A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO FOR NONCONTIGUOUS PAROLE
COUNTY CONNECTION BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO LEAP FROG. LOS ANGELES
OVER OTHER COUNTIES OR WHATEVER
TO GET TO CURRENT SO THEY COULD
GO TO WORK IN THE OIL INDUSTRY
WHEN IT'S THRIVING, AND THEY HAD
TO HAVE BEEN CONTINUOUS COUNTY.
SO WE FIXED THAT. SO I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE PROGRAMS
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT
AND KEEP A JOB AND HAVE A JOB
AND WE SHOULD PROVIDE THEM WITH
REHABILITATION IN THE SKILL SET
TO DO THAT. YOU NEED THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT. AND I
AGREE WITH THAT. BUT WHEN I
TOURED PELICAN BAY WENT TO THE
SHOE WE WENT TO, YOU KNOW, WHICH
WAS THE PRISON INSIDE THE
PRISON. AND, UM AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO BE STEREOTYPICAL AND
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE. BUT WHEN I
LOOKED AT SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE
IN THAT SHOE I THOUGHT, THANK
GOD THEY ARE THERE. AND WHEN I
GOT THERE, BACKGROUND I WAS
LIKE, SO GRATEFUL THEY WERE
THERE AND NOT OUT IN MY
COMMUNITY. SO I REALIZED THAT
THERE'S A PUSH TO CLOSE DOWN
PRISONS AND REMOVE PEOPLE FROM
THE PRISON ENVIRONMENT. BUT I
REALIZED ALSO THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE IN PRISON
AND WE NEED TO PROTECT SOCIETY
FROM THEM. AND I REALIZED THAT
YOU HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO MAKE
SURE MORALE AND, UM THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT GO INTO THOSE
PRISONS HAVE FECES THROWN ON HIM
THAT ARE IN, YOU KNOW,
CONSTANTLY ATTACKED. I SAW I SAW
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT HAPPENED
IN THAT PRISON, THE STUFF THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH. IT'S UM I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
IMPROVE THE MORALE IN PRISON
SPECIFICALLY WITH THAT THAT I
JUST MENTIONED AND PRISON
CLOSURES WHERE THESE WERE STAFF
GOING TO MOVE PRISON CLOSURES IN
CALIFORNIA CITY, OTHER PHYSICAL
IN 2024. YOU GOT ANOTHER PRISON
IN 2025, THE PRISON UP IN DALI'S
DISTRICT THAT CLOSED THE DAY WE
HAD A CONFIRMATION FOR THE LAST
DIRECTOR, WHEN NOBODY EVEN KNEW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING. WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE STAFF? WHAT HAPPENS TO
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM IS THEIR
PLACEMENT. ARE YOU MOVING THEM
OR THEY? YOU KNOW, WHICH IS A
BAD THING AGAIN. YOU KNOW, IT'S
I GUESS IT'S THE WORST OR THE
BEST OF ALL EVILS BECAUSE UPROOT
YOUR FAMILY AND MOVED FROM
CALIFORNIA CITY, TOO. WHEREVER.
AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
IMPROVE THE MORALE OF STAFF
BECAUSE WHEN I TALKED TO SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE WHEN I MEET WITH
THEM, AND I'M NOT TALKING
LOBBYISTS AND PEOPLE UP HERE,
I'M TALKING MY PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND IN TEHACHAPI PRISON, AND
THEY'RE VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE
NOTICE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET
AND THE CITY IS VERY WORRIED
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
MAINTAIN ALL THOSE PEOPLE
LEAVING THAT AREA. IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL MOUNTAIN COMMUNITY
FOUR SEASONS, SO THESE IMPACTS
OF CLOSING THESE FACILITIES AND
THE MORALE OF THE STAFF IS A
HUGE CONCERN FOR ME. AND IF YOU
CAN ADDRESS THOSE THINGS, I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT. YEAH I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU. THE
PRISON CLOSURES. ARE VERY
TRAUMATIC FOR OUR STAFF. THE
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO IN THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION. UM AND
EVERYONE'S WAITING FOR THE NEXT
NOTICE. UM AND I LIVED IN
CRESCENT CITY WHERE PELICAN BAY
IS. THEY FIGURED THEY WERE GOING
TO BE CLOSED. I LIVED IN
SUSANVILLE. I WAS THE CHIEF
DEPUTY WARDEN. HIGH DESERT STATE
PRISON. UM, PRIOR, SO I KNOW
THAT COMMUNITY. IT'S A SMALL
COMMUNITY. UM THEY WERE. THEY
WERE DEVASTATED OVER THE PRISON.
NEXT DOOR CLOSING, UM THE CAMPS,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF GOING INTO
ONE. IT'S REALLY, REALLY HARD.
TO TALK TO STAFF THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH HAVING TO THINK ABOUT
MOVING, UM OR LOSING THEIR JOBS.
IF THEY DON'T MOVE, AND I'M WE
DO WORK VERY CLOSE WITH THEM. WE
HAVE A VOLUNTARY TRANSFER
PROCESS, SO IF THEY WANT TO
LEAVE AND GO TO ANOTHER
INSTITUTION, WE HELP THEM WITH
THAT, UM CLOSING THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE NEAR
ANOTHER INSTITUTION HELPS
RELOCATE THAT STAFF, YOU KNOW,
SO THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO UPROOT
THEIR FAMILIES ALSO LOOKING AT
OUR POPULATION, AND INSTEAD OF
CLOSING THE WHOLE PRISONS AND
JUST CLOSING THE FACILITIES
WITHIN THE PRISON AND BEING ABLE
TO KEEP THE STAFF THERE. AND
HAVE THEM MOVE OVER TO THE OTHER
AND STAYING IN THEIR
INSTITUTIONS HAS BEEN ALSO
HELPFUL. TRYING TO RECRUIT STAFF
TO COME IN RIGHT NOW, THOUGH,
WHEN WE'RE CLOSING PRISONS HAS
BEEN A STRUGGLE. WE WERE
STRUGGLING, JUST LIKE SHERIFF
COOPER SAID WITH YOU KNOW OUR
VACANCIES AND GETTING PEOPLE TO
WANT TO COME TO WORK FOR US. I
THINK THE BIGGEST CHEERLEADERS
WE HAVE FOR COMING TO WORK IN
THE DEPARTMENT IS OUR OWN STAFF.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE THE BAD MORALE
BECAUSE OF PRISON CLOSURES, AND
UM, AND THE TERRIBLE INCIDENTS
THAT HAPPENED WITHIN OUR PRISONS
, I MEAN, I'VE HAD MY ENTIRE
FACE BROKE IN AN INCIDENT BY
INCARCERATED PERSON, UM, WHEN I
WAS AN OFFICER, SO I UNDERSTAND
THE CONDITIONS THAT THEY HAVE TO
GO THROUGH AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY THE NORWAY THAT CALIFORNIA
MODEL UM CHANGING THE WAY WE
TREAT OUR STAFF AND HAVING THEM
BE A PART OF THE SOLUTION.
HAVING THEM BE A PART OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING INSIDE THE
INSTITUTION. TO PREVENT
INCIDENTS FROM HAPPENING. I
THINK THEY NEED TO FEEL VALUE IN
THEIR JOBS. I THINK THEY NEED TO
BE HEARD. UM I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THEY WANT. WHAT WOULD MAKE THEM
HAPPY? AND THE INSTITUTIONS? I'M
A BIG WALKER AND TALKER WHEN I
WAS A WARDEN, I NEVER SAT DOWN.
I WAS OUT IN THE INSTITUTION AND
I WAS CONSTANTLY TALKING TO THE
STAFF. UM AND THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION, SO MORALE I THINK
HAS TO START WITH THE LEADERS
ARE WARDENS WERE LOOKING AT OUR
WARDENS A LITTLE DIFFERENT NOW
TO ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF
PERSON ARE YOU? ARE YOU GOING TO
BE OUT THERE? CHAMPIONING OUR
STAFF DOING THINGS. EMPLOYEE
WELLNESS. I THINK WE HAVE A
REALLY ROBUST EMPLOYEE WELLNESS
NOW WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ISSUE, WE'RE WORKING WITH
YOU. WE'RE NOT FIRING YOU
ANYMORE. THAT WASN'T HEARD OF
BACK WHEN I STARTED, YOU WOULD
BE FIRED. UM WE'RE REALLY TAKING
PEOPLE INTO ACCOUNT AND REALLY
LISTENING TO THEM. WHAT WOULD
MAKE THIS A BETTER DEPARTMENT WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM THEM. WE
RECENTLY UM ALLOWED CELLPHONES
TO COME IN FOR STAFF IN ONE OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS. THEY'RE ABLE
TO BRING THEIR CELLPHONES IN SO
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR FAMILIES
WHEN THEY'RE IN AN INSTITUTION
FOR 16 HOURS. WE'RE TRYING IT AT
ONE INSTITUTION TO SEE HOW IT
GOES. IT'S GOING WELL. WE'RE
GOING TO EXPAND IT TO ANOTHER
INSTITUTION AND SLOWLY ROLL THAT
OUT. BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE STUCK
IN A IN A CONTROL BOOTH IN A
PRISON FOR 16 HOURS WITH NO
CONTACT WITH YOUR FAMILY, AND
YOU HAVE LITTLE KIDS AT HOME.
IT'S HARD. IT IS HARD, SO WE'VE
GOT TO RECOGNIZE THOSE THINGS.
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW, WE'RE
IN A PLACE RIGHT NOW WHERE WE
HAVE A SECRETARY THAT WANTS
CHANGE. AND HE THINKS OUT OF THE
BOX. UM MY OTHER
UNDERSECRETARIES I WORK WITH.
YOU KNOW, DIANA TOSH IS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF HEALTH CARE.
SHE'S ALWAYS GOT CRAZY IDEAS,
BUT WE LOVE THEM. UM AND WE
RECKON WE JUMP ON THEM, AND WE
TALK ABOUT THEM. UM WE HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OUT THERE. I THINK WE'RE AT A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF LEADERSHIP
RIGHT NOW THAT WE WANT TO KNOW
WHAT TO DO ABOUT HER, AND WE
AREN'T AFRAID OF MAKING CHANGE.
WE LIKE THINKING OUT OF THE BOX
AND STAFF TO ME IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHEN THEY GO IN EVERY
DAY HOW THEY TREAT THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION. UM.
WILL MAKE OR BREAK THE NEXT
PERSON COMING ON THAT SHIFT. AND
IF THEY'RE HAPPY, AND THEY'RE
SAYING GOOD MORNING, AND THEY'RE
TREATING THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION HAPPY THEY'RE GOING
TO GO HOME HAPPY. THE NEXT
PEOPLE COMING IN ARE GOING TO BE
HAPPIER. UM, I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW, IT'S JUST THAT CHANGE OF
HOW WE ALL HAVE TO START
TREATING PEOPLE KINDER AND THIS
PRISON CLOSURE IS HARD FOR
PEOPLE. IT'S HARD FOR ME WHEN I
HEAR IT. I WENT TO SUSAN MILL
WHEN IT WAS HAPPENING. I WALKED
AROUND HIGH DESERT. I WALKED
AROUND. THE PRISON THAT WAS
CLOSING NEXT DOOR. I TALKED TO
PEOPLE ABOUT IT AND I TELL THEM,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO BE HERE
FOR YOU, UM, AND ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE PERSON DID END UP GETTING
A JOB AT HIGH DESERT OR
VOLUNTARILY MOVED. THERE WAS A
COUPLE THAT WERE LAID OFF, AND I
JUST HEARD TWO WEEKS AGO THAT
THEY'VE BOTH BEEN HIRED BACK AT
THE INSTITUTION. SO I LOVE
STORIES LIKE THAT, AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN DO THAT WITH THE
UPCOMING PRISON CLOSURES WHERE
WE DON'T SEE THE BIG IMPACT AND
I HOPE WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
PRISON CLOSURES BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT WE'RE IN A REDUCED
POPULATION. BUT WITH THIS
CALIFORNIA MODEL AND WHAT WE
WANT TO DO WITH STAFF MORALE,
INMATE PROGRAM WE NEED THAT
SPACE AND I LIVED IN THE
OVERCROWDING DAYS. WHEN THERE
WAS TRIPLE BUNKS IN THE GYM, AND
IT WAS HARD TIMES THERE WAS
NOBODY THAT WAS HAPPY DURING
THOSE TIMES, INCARCERATED
POPULATION, THE STAFF YOU'RE ON
EDGE THE WHOLE DAY. YOU HAVE TO
WAIT IN LINES TO GET YOUR
MEDICATION. YOUR CANTEEN
PACKAGES. UM STAFFER ON EDGE
BECAUSE THERE THERE'S SO MANY
PEOPLE ON THE YARD. YOU'RE JUST
TENSE. SO THIS REDUCED
POPULATION HAS ALLOWED US TO
HAVE A BETTER RELATIONSHIP, I
THINK WITH INCARCERATED
POPULATION AND GO HOME FEELING
BETTER ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING.
WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAYS TO GO.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE 60,000 EMPLOYEES
, UM APPROXIMATELY AND CHANGE IS
HARD AND THE DIRECTION WE WANT
TO GO WITH THE CALIFORNIA MODEL
AND UM TEACHING PEOPLE WHAT IT
MEANS TO THEM BECAUSE IT IS
REALLY ABOUT EMPLOYEE WELLNESS
TO ME. IT REALLY IS ABOUT MORALE
AND PEOPLE BEING PROUD OF THE
JOB THEY'RE DOING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND I APPRECIATE NÓI. THE
QUESTION WAS A LITTLE LIKE MORE
ONE SIDED BECAUSE I FELT LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES COVERED THE OTHER
SIDE. BUT I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THERE THAT YOU'RE PROMOTING
A DECENCY AND RESPECT WITH THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION AND THE
OFFICERS OR THE INDIVIDUALS, THE
PERSONNEL THAT WORKED THERE. UM
BECAUSE I THINK THE OVERCROWDING
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
IN THE PAST AND THE WHOLE BATON
THING AND EVERYTHING THAT GOES
ON THE YOU SEE IN THE OLD MOVIES
THAT IS COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE,
AND I DON'T SUPPORT OR CONDONE
THAT IN ANY WAY, SHAPE OR FORM.
UM BUT I JUST UM, LIKE I SAID, I
SAT DOWN. I'VE BEEN INSIDE
PRISONS I'VE TALKED TO. I WENT
TO. AS A MATTER OF FACT, SOME OF
THE SERGEANT'S TOOK ME TO A
PRISON IN I MET WITH ALL AND I
WAS SHAKING EVERYBODY'S HAND. HI
I'M ASSEMBLYWOMAN GROVE AND
THEY'RE LIKE, STOP SHAKING THEIR
HANDS. AND THEN I WENT INTO A
CLASSROOM AND SOMEBODY WAS, YOU
KNOW, AND THIS IS A GROWN MAN
RIGHT? A GROWN MAN THAT WAS
INCARCERATED POPULATION AND HE
LIKE HIT HIS PAPER. AND I SAID,
WHAT DO YOU READ? WHAT ARE YOU
DOING? AND IT WAS A CLASSROOM
LIKE SCHOOL AND HE GOES. I'M
LEARNING. I'M TAKING MY SPELLING
TEST. HE'S GOT HIS HANDS ALL
OVER THIS PAPER, AND I'M LIKE
MOVING HIS HANDS AND I SAID,
WHAT IS IT? AND IT WAS, UM LIKE
FOX. THEY IT'S LIKE A 40 YEAR
OLD MAN. WHAT'S LIKE FULL? IT'S
FOX. NOT FOLKS, YOU KNOW, AND HE
SAYS, SO. WHEN I PASSED THIS
TEST, I'LL GET TO GO ON TO
ANOTHER. GREAT. IT'S GOOD FOR
YOU, YOU KNOW? AND SO I REALIZED
THAT, UM, I KNOW THAT IF YOU IF
YOU TREAT ALL PEOPLE WITH
DECENCY AND RESPECT, INCLUDING
THOSE IN THE SHOE, UM BUT I
WOULD PREFER HONESTLY ON THE
RECORD THAT THEY STAY THERE. BUT
UH, BUT THOSE THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COME OUT. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE JOBS
BECAUSE, LIKE I SAID, IT'S THE
BEST UPWARD MOBILITY AND WAY TO
KEEP THEM OUT, AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR BALANCE. WITH STAFF MORALE
AND WHAT'S GOING ON WITH STAFF.
I MET WITH STAFF WHEN YOU KNOW I
WENT AND MET WITH THE OTHERS,
AND I'M GETTING READY TO ANOTHER
PRISON VISITATION. UM AND I LOOK
AT AND I'M NOT GOING TO OUT
ANYBODY. BUT I LOOK AT THE
PEOPLE THAT WE AT THE SENATE
HAVE HIRED THAT HAVE COME FROM A
PERSON SETTING AS SECOND
CHANCERS, AND THEY ARE THRIVING
AND ONE DAY WHEN ONE OF THEM
WALKED UP TO ME BECAUSE I GIVE
HIM A BAD TIME. SOMETIMES THAT
WE'VE HELPED HIM GET SETTLED AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. HE SHOWED ME
HIS PRISON. I D IN HIS
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. I D.
AND HE IS SO PROUD OF THAT. AND
IF YOU MET THAT YOUNG MAN TODAY,
YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW THAT HE HAD
EVER BEEN INCARCERATED. EITHER
OF THEM. THERE'S SEVERAL OF THEM
HERE. BUT IF YOU MET THEM
BECAUSE THERE IS OPPORTUNITY ON
THE OUTSIDE AND YOU JUST HAVE TO
GIVE THEM AN ABILITY TO DO THAT,
BUT THEY HAVE TO BE WILLING
THEMSELVES TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT PROCESS AS WELL. AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING BALANCED. THANK
YOU HAVE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS.
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE YOU KNOW THAT. IF CURRENT
COUNTY WERE STATE, IT WOULD BE
THE FOURTH LARGEST OIL PRODUCING
STATE IN CASE YOU MISSED THAT,
UM HE TO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ASKED MANY THINGS IN AND HAVE
DONE A GOOD JOB. SO TWO
QUESTIONS AND THE FIRST ONE WAS
RAISED BY SOMETHING YOU SAID
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT. THE PEOPLE
AND THE WORKERS WITH REGARD.
PRISON FACILITIES, BUT WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THE
FACILITIES AND YOU MENTIONED SAN
LUIS OBISPO WHERE I'M GOING IN A
COUPLE OF DAYS, AND BECAUSE IT
HAD TWO UNITS IN ONE UNIT IS
CLOSED. WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THE
UNITS? AS YOU SCALE DOWN THAT
SOUNDED LIKE YOU WERE USING IT
FOR PRISON RELATED. THINK THAT
YOU DIDN'T HAVE THE SPACE FOR
BEFORE. SO HOW DO YOU HANDLE
THAT? AS WE GO THROUGH THIS WITH
VARIOUS I HONESTLY THINK THAT
DAVE LEWIS, WHO'S UP NEXT FOR
HE'S ACTUALLY OVER FACILITY
PLANNING AND COME DOWN TO ASK
HIM, BUT YOU OPENED THE DOOR AND
I MEAN, I THINK HE WOULD
PROBABLY BE THE BEST ONE TO ASK
IT. I DON'T EVEN NO. IF WE'RE
ALLOWED TO GO IN THERE AND USE
IT FOR PROGRAM SPACE, HONESTLY,
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE IT FOR, YOU
KNOW, UH, PUTTING IN. YOU KNOW
IF I CONTRACTOR WANTED TO COME
IN, AND, UH, TEACHER
INCARCERATED POPULATION, A
TRADE, I WOULD LOVE IT, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE ALLOWED TO
PASSED IT OFF TO DAVID. IF
EITHER OF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT
NOW WE'LL GET BACK TO US. WE
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING MORE ABOUT
IT THAN I DO. NOTHING I WOULD
SUBMIT THAT SENATOR LAIRD WOULD
BE WILLING TO MAKE SURE THAT HE
WOULD ASK WHOEVER NEEDS TO BE
ASKED. YES HAVE THAT FACILITY.
YES, BUT I WOULD PAY FOR THAT
OIL COMMENT, RIGHT? I WOULD. I
WOULD LOVE TO USE THE USE THE
SPACE. I THINK THAT, UM WE'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO, YOU KNOW, PUT
OUR POPULATION. I UNDERSTAND THE
POPULATION, BUT I JUST KNOW
RIGHT. SECOND YOU WERE USING IT
FOR RELATED PROGRAM AND I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUIRE BUDGET OR
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY. SO THAT
WOULD BE A GOOD REASON FOR US TO
HEAR BACK QUESTION. I WANTED TO
ASK YOU AND YOU ALLUDED TO IT
EARLIER, BUT I THOUGHT I'D PUT A
FINER POINT ON IT. YOU WERE A
RANK AND FILE OFFICER IN THE
FIRST YEARS, AND NOW YOU'RE
DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING. WHAT
DOES SHE GO THROUGH EACH DAY? DO
YOU SORT OF DRAWN FROM THAT DOES
EXPERIENCE I WAS LIKE, JEEZ, I
KNOW THAT DOESN'T WORK OR JEEZ,
THAT'S NEW, OR I CAN'T BELIEVE
THEY'RE THINKING THAT WHEN THIS
IS REALLY HOW DO YOU DRAW ON
THAT EXPERIENCE IN YOUR CURRENT
JOB? I THINK OF ALL THE
POSITIONS THAT I'VE HELD IN MY
JOBS HAS PREPARED ME FOR THIS SO
EARLY ON AS AN OFFICER. YOU
KNOW, I DIDN'T REALLY EVEN KNOW
WHAT A SECRETARY OR
UNDERSECRETARY WAS. I KNEW WE
HAD A DIRECTOR AND ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR, AND SO AS I GREW IN MY
CAREER AND I DIDN'T TAKE THE
TRADITIONAL ROUTE OF SERGEANT
LIEUTENANT FROM OFFICER. I WAS
VERY INTERESTED IN THE BUDGET.
SO I BECAME A BUDGET ANALYST,
AND THEN I WANTED TO. I WANTED
TO LEARN HOW TO BUY STUFF LIKE
HOW DOES THE CARS COME IN? AND
HOW DO WE GET THIS? SO I BECAME
THE PROCUREMENT OFFICER AND A
BUSINESS MANAGER, AND I HAD A
VERY CURIOUS MIND OF HOW THE
DEPARTMENT WORKED AND UM IT'S
BENEFITED ME SO WELL IN MY
VARIOUS JOBS. I EVEN JUMPED OVER
ON THE HEALTHCARE SIDE AND
WORKED FOR THE RECEIVER AS THE
DIRECTOR OF CORRECTIONS SERVICES
DURING COVID, UM AND WAS THE
INCIDENT COMMANDER AND I'VE I'VE
LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT EVERY
LITTLE PIECES AND NUANCES OF THE
DEPARTMENT. UM, I'M NOT AN
EXPERT IN ANY OF IT, BUT ENOUGH
TO KNOW WHERE TO LOOK AND WHERE
TO RESEARCH AND WHERE TO PULL
THE BEST INFORMATION FROM I DO
KNOW, AND FROM MY EXPERIENCE
THAT IN THE EARLY DAYS WHEN IT
WAS OVERCROWDED, AND PELICAN BAY
WAS A VERY ROUGH PRISON WHEN I
WAS THERE, THERE WAS A LOT OF
VIOLENCE. I'VE SEEN A LOT OF
THINGS AS A YOUNG CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER. UM I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD SEE IN MY LIFE. THERE WAS
VERY TRAUMATIC. SO WHAT I DRAW
ON NOW, AND HE'S EVEN WHEN I WAS
A WARDEN IS I WANT MY STAFF TO
NOT HAVE THAT TRAUMA. I WANT
THEM TO COME TO WORK EVERY DAY
AND DO THE JOB THAT THEY WERE
HIRED TO DO WITH WITHOUT SEEING
THE VIOLENCE AND TO DO THAT WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION. GIVE
THEM HOPE THAT THEY CAN GET OUT.
UM AND THAT'S HOW I APPROACH HOW
I APPROACH IT. AND WHEN I THINK
ABOUT ALL THE JOBS I'VE HAD THE
ONE THING I'VE LEARNED THE MOST
AS THEY'RE JUST PEOPLE THAT ARE
INCARCERATED. JUST LIKE JUST
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WE ARE PEOPLE.
THEY WERE PROBABLY IN A
DIFFERENT LIFESTYLE THAN THAN I
WAS. THEIR PARENTS PROBABLY
WEREN'T SITTING IN THE AUDIENCE
THAT THEIR GRADUATION UM SO
TAKING THAT INTO ACCOUNT WHEN I
WHEN I YOU DEAL WITH THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION THAT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME.
UPBRINGINGS AND HAVING OUR STAFF
. TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT. UM I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE LOWER
POPULATION RIGHT NOW. UM, I
THINK IT HELPS GREATLY OUR
STAFF. BEING ABLE TO BE OUT
THERE AND DO THE JOB THEY NEED
TO DO IN A RESPECTFUL MANNER. SO
FOR EVERY EVERY POSITION I HAVE
HAD IS PREPARED ME FOR THIS AND
LET ME TELL YOU IT'S NOT BEEN
THE TRADITIONAL CUSTODY ROUTE.
I'VE BOUNCED AROUND, UM, TWO
DIFFERENT POSITIONS BECAUSE I
ALWAYS WANTED TO LEARN A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT EVERYTHING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT THAT'S WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD,
UM AT THIS POINT, A LOT OF
GROUND HAS BEEN COVERED, AND I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT. UM
COUPLE THINGS ONE. THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT PRISON CLOSURES
, AND I DO THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE ENOUGH SPACE
TO DO THE WORK YOU NEED TO DO.
BECAUSE I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA MODEL. I'VE HEARD
FROM LOTS OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
WENT TO NORWAY. WE'VE LISTENED
TO THE SECRETARY TALKED ABOUT
HIS VISION OF THAT, BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THOSE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AND
OPPORTUNITIES EXIST FOR ALL
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IN
EVERY SINGLE PRISON, AND WE CAN
HAVE A WONDERFUL EXAMPLE. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT. OF A NEW
MODEL, BUT I DON'T WANT ANYONE
TO NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCESS REHABILITATIVE SERVICES,
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. UM AH
TECHNICAL SKILLS. WHATEVER IT IS
, THEY WANT TO DO TO CHANGE
THEIR ABILITY TO HAVE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. SO I'M EXCITED
TO SEE THIS. GO FORWARD. I'M
GLAD MY COLLEAGUES BROUGHT IT
UP. UM ON THE CLOSURES. UM I DO
WANT TO SAY, I THINK WE KIND OF
LEARNED ABOUT PREVIOUS CLOSURES
AT THE LAST MINUTE. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT. YOU KNOW, I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION HAS TO
MAKE SOME HARD CALLS. IF WE ARE
GONNA, YOU KNOW, CLOSED PRISONS,
AND WE'RE GOING IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION. WE WANT FEWER PEOPLE
INCARCERATED. WE WANT THESE
PROGRAMS TO WORK, SO YOU KNOW
THAT WE CONTINUE TO LOWER
POPULATION AND THE PEOPLE WHO
SHOULDN'T BE IN PRISON. SHOULD
NOT BE IN PRISON. THEY SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO UM, JOB TRAINING
OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON SYSTEM,
THEY SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
HEALTH CARE OUTSIDE OF THE
PRISON, THEY SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO EDUCATION OUTSIDE OF PRISONS,
SO THAT YOU KNOW ALL THOSE
THINGS ARE WHAT WE'RE AIMING
FOR. IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF OUR,
UM YOU KNOW OUR SOCIETY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA? THE CLOSURES.
HOWEVER, I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE,
AND I KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
HERE. UM I REALLY BELIEVE WE
HAVE TO APPROACH THIS SOONER AND
EARLIER BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC, UM,
IMPACT IN A COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
TO THE EMPLOYEES AND FOR THEM TO
KNOW AND BE ABLE TO PLAN AND IT
DOESN'T GET ANY EASIER JUST BY
TELLING SOMEONE LATER AS OPPOSED
TO EARLIER AND TRYING TO PLANET
WE STILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
SAME CRITICISM THE SAME
COMPLAINTS. THE SAME LOBBYING TO
KEEP THIS PRISON OPEN VERSUS
THAT ONE, AND WE STILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
CITIES AND COUNTIES WHO COUNT ON
THAT ECONOMIC IMPACT, SO WE
SHOULD HAVE AN ECONOMIC IMPACT
STATEMENT AND WE SHOULD BACK UP.
SO THE CORE ADMINISTRATION HAS
HEARD ME SAY THIS THE LAST
COUPLE OF TIMES. SO UM, I JUST
WANTED TO REPEAT THAT SO THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR POSITION
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO SAY,
WELL, I WAS ASKED BY THE
LEGISLATORS TO SAY THAT THEY
WANT THIS INFORMATION SOONER, SO
I'M JUST POINTING THIS OUT. SO
THAT WERE PART OF A BIGGER
PROCESS TO DO THIS THE RIGHT
WAY. ABSOLUTELY I AGREE. I WILL.
I DON'T REALLY MIGHT HAVE ONE
QUESTION, BUT I REALLY WANT TO
UNDERSCORE WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
OVER HERE SAID ABOUT YOUR
EXPERIENCE, STARTING AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AND REALLY
WORKING YOUR WAY UP TO
UNDERSTAND EVERY ASPECT. I THINK
THERE'S GREAT VALUE IN THAT. I
THINK THERE'S VALUE IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND WHAT YOU BRING TO
IT. AND WHEN I COMPARE YOUR YOUR
28 YEARS 2027 27 YEARS. TO ALSO
THE ATTITUDE. I'M HEARING
DISPLAY TODAY ABOUT CULTURE
SHIFT AND CHANGE. WHEN I PUT
THOSE TWO THINGS TOGETHER, I'M
I'M THRILLED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOU TODAY AND I THINK
WE'RE LUCKY. IF THIS IS THE
DIRECTION WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
IN. I ONLY HAVE ONE SIMPLE WELL,
IT'S NOT SIMPLE, BUT ONE
QUESTION IS, UM FENTANYL IN THIS
DAY AND TIME HOW IT'S IMPACTING
EVERY SINGLE THING IN OUR
COMMUNITY INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF
JAILS AND PRISONS. BUT HOW BIG A
PROBLEM IS FENTANYL COMPARED TO
OTHER ILLICIT DRUGS FOR YOU, AND
IT'S A DEVASTATING HONESTLY, UM
IT'S SUCH A SMALL DRUG AND EASY
TO SMUGGLE IN. EITHER THROUGH
MALE STAFF. UM DRONES. DRONES
HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM. IT'S SO
TINY AND OUR POPULATION
OVERDOSES. SCARE ME BECAUSE. IT
DOESN'T TAKE MUCH, UM, I THINK
ARE I THINK WE REALLY ARE DOING
A GOOD JOB WITH OUR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER, TREATMENT PROGRAMS
OR MEDICAL ASSISTED TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. UM REALLY EDUCATING
THE POPULATION ABOUT FENTANYL
AND WHAT IT CAN DO A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT OF WHAT IT CAN DO WELL
WILL KILL THEM. UM, WE'RE REALLY
WE'RE REALLY CHAMPIONSHIP
CHAMPION THAT ALSO WORKING WITH
OUR HEALTHCARE PARTNERS. UM, WE
HAVE WE HAVE DEPLOYED NARCAN TO
THE POPULATION. WE'RE GIVING
THEM TO THEM WHEN THEY'RE COMING
IN, UM FROM THE IN FROM JAILS TO
US WHEN THEY COME IN RECEPTION
WERE ALSO THE CORRECTION
OFFICERS NOW HAVE ACCESS TO THEM
WHERE WE HAD HAD THE SERGEANT'S,
UM, THERE NOW HAVE THEY HAVE
ACCESS IMMEDIATELY TO IT, BUT
ALSO, YOU KNOW, PILOTING SOME
INSTITUTIONS WHERE THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION IS
KEEPING IT IN THEIR CELL. WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN WHERE IT'S SAVED A
FEW LIVES WHERE THE THERE'S SOME
MATES HAVE USED IT ON THE OTHER
INCARCERATED PERSON. WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO TACKLE THIS
FROM EVERY ANGLE, JUST LIKE THE
COMMUNITIES ARE, BUT IT IS AN
IMPACT. UM THE WE HAVE 68 K 9
DOGS THAT CAN, YOU KNOW? GO OUT
AND SEARCH FOR THE DRUGS. I'M WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND THAT ALSO
HAVE THE PASSIVE RESISTANCE DOGS
WERE THEY CAN PASS BY VISITORS
AND STAFF TO ENSURE THERE'S NO
DRUGS ON THEM. UM, WE'VE HAD
ABOUT 100. MM. VISITORS ARRESTED
THIS LAST YEAR FOR TRYING TO
BRING CONTRABAND IN THOSE ARE
THE ONLY ONES WE CATCH, THOUGH
WE STILL KNOW BECAUSE, LIKE I
SAID, IT'S JUST SUCH A SMALL
AMOUNT IT TAKES, YOU KNOW, AND
IT'S SO DEADLY. UM WE'RE TRYING
TO TACKLE IT FROM EVERY SINGLE
AREA, BUT IT IS A HUGE IMPACT
FOR US. I THINK THE NARCAN OUT
THERE IS VERY HELPFUL. UM WELL,
THANK YOU IF YOU LEARN OF OTHER
MECHANISMS THAT YOU KNOW WOULD
BE HELPFUL WOULD BE GOOD TO
KNOW. YEAH, ABSOLUTELY. WE HAVE
HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATION, SO
I'M GOING TO TURN TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC NOW AND ASK IF THERE
ARE THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AGAIN. YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION OR HAT YOU
WEAR, IF ANY, AND YOUR BRIEF
COMMENTS ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I SEE A FEW FOLKS
HEADING TOWARDS THE MICROPHONE
AND LET ME JUST THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENTS. I'VE NOTICED
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE STANDING
ALONG THE BACK OF THE WALL AND
IN THE AUDIENCE, SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE. WELCOME GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS RYAN
SOUZA. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THREE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING AMITY
FOUNDATION HEALTH, RIGHT? 360 IN
THE WEST CARE FOUNDATION. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE COMBINED
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE WORKING IN
CDCR AND IN RE ENTRY AND REALLY
JUST WANT TO RELAY THEIR
WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT FROM MISS
FOSS. THEY HAVE SEEN THE ARE
COME IN 2009. THEY HAVE SEEN THE
DECADE OF SHIFTING CULTURE
CHANGE, AND TAMMY FOX REPRESENTS
EXACTLY THAT. SHE'S WHAT CDCR
NEEDS. NOW SHE'S WHAT THE STAFF
NEEDS. SHE'S WHAT TREATMENT
NEEDS. ONE THING THAT'S REALLY
PARTICULAR ABOUT MISS FOSS AND
HOW SHE REACTS WITH THE
PROVIDERS, AND SHE'S WILLING TO
SIT DOWN TACKLE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS AND ADDRESS
PROBLEMS THAT COME UP AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT JUST
REPRESENTS THE CHANGE IN CDCR
THAT YOU SEE THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT NOW, WHICH IS
THE WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS AN
ISSUE DONE THE RIGHT WAY AND NOT
JUST THE EASY WAY. AND SO WE
URGE YOUR I VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
TESTIMONY. VERY GOOD TO HEAR.
WELCOME COME ON UP YOUR NAME
EVENING. MY NAME IS USUALLY
MCDUFFIE. I'M THE REASON OF
MANAGING ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION. I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF MS UNDERSECRETARY. FALSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WELCOME.
PEACE POWER AND POSITIVITY. HOW
YOU DOING? MY NAME IS SEAN GAUGE
. I'M ALIVE CULTURE WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION HOPING
REDEMPTION TEAM AND PLEASE
FORGIVE ME. BUT MADAM VICE MADAM
CHAIRMAN, I WAS IN THE BACK OF
THE ROOM ONE O'CLOCK WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING I HAD I
HAD TO DO THAT, UM, I MYSELF
SERVED 27 YEARS WITH A SIDE OF
CDC. BACK WHEN IT WAS PRETTY
MUCH AT ITS WORST. TODAY I STAND
HERE AS SOMEBODY WHO'S REFORMED,
REHABILITATED NOW GO BACK INSIDE
THE INSTITUTIONS. UM MADAME
FOSTER IS AN ADVOCATE OF THAT.
I'VE SAT AND TALKED WITH HER, UM
, EVERYTHING SHE'S SAYING IS WHO
SHE IS. AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU. WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHAWN ROBINSON,
AND I AM A LIFE COACH FOR ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AS WELL. UM
I AM IN SUPPORT OF TAMIKA FOSS.
I WAS ALSO CURRENTLY IN COURSE
OF WORLD FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
I DID I SERVED 22 YEARS OF MY
LIFE. AND NOW I'M GONNA
REHABILITATED WOMAN. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY. HI.
WELCOME GOOD EVENING, EVERYONE,
UM MY NAME IS TYSON WIND AND I'M
WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION. I WAS SERVING MOST OF
MY TIME AT HIGH DESERTS ALIVE.
MET MISS FOSTER. UM PERSONALLY
AND WHAT I SEE WHAT YOU SEE
TODAY IS WHAT YOU GET. SO I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT HER. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AS WELL.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS BRANDON PATTERSON. AND I'M A
LIFE COACH WITH THE HEART TEAM
AT THE ENTIRE CITIZEN COLLISION
AS A FORMER LIFE IN MAY. I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF MISS FOSS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND
LET ME SAY CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU AS WELL. HI WELCOME, MADAM
CHAIR, DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS.
FIRST I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR DEDICATION. AND
DILIGENCE TO THE COMMUNITY TO
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS, SO THANK
YOU, UM I AM NEIL FLOOD, THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF CCPOA, A COVER
MY NORWAY PARTNERS HERE. UM WE
ARE HERE TO SUPPORT TAMMY FOSS.
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTING SOMEONE THAT WOULD BE
OUR BOSS WHEN WE'RE WEARING A
UNIFORM, SO WE'RE NOT ALWAYS IN
AGREEANCE WITH THEM, BUT WE HAVE
ENJOYED WORKING WITH HER. SHE
DOES MAKE THE SECRETARY'S JOB
MUCH EASIER BECAUSE I ALMOST
NEVER HAVE TO CONTACT HIM NOW
BECAUSE SHE ANSWERS THE PHONE
EVERY TIME WE NEED AN ISSUE
ADDRESSED OR SOMETHING TO BE
FIXED. SO WE HOPE AS WE GO
THROUGH THESE MAJOR CHANGES, AND
WE BEGIN TO HAVE A NEW WAY OF
DOING OUR JOB THAT SHE WILL HELP
GUIDE US, UM AND WE JUST WANT TO
KNOW WE SUPPORT YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'LL MAKE SURE THE
SECRETARY GETS THAT COMMENT. WE
HAVE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SECRETARY AS HE PROMISED US
HE WOULD DO IN THE EARLIER DAYS
WHEN WE WEREN'T GETTING SO MANY
POSITIVE COMMENTS FROM FROM
EVERYBODY, AND HE HAS KEPT THAT
PROMISE TO MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE, SO THANK QUÊ AND WE WILL
PASS THAT MESSAGE ON. WELCOME
THANK YOU. I'M LEVI LINDEMANN
AND I REMEMBER OF AIR SEA AND I
SUPPORT MISS FOSS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. HI. WELCOME
GOOD EVENING PANEL. MY NAME IS
DANIEL CHESTING. I'M ALSO PART
OF THE HEART TEAM IN A R. C.
CHANGE. IS POSSIBLE CHANGE IS
GOOD. I'VE ALSO BEEN IN THE
SHOE. AND WE'RE AMONGST A BUNCH
OF LIFERS 29 YEARS MYSELF. THANK
YOU. FOR WHAT YOU ARE ATTEMPTING
TO DO AND THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT
IT MEANS FOR US TO HEAR FROM
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
SYSTEM THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT'S WORKING. THAT MAKES ALL
THE DIFFERENCE TO THOSE OF US
WHO ARE TRYING TO DO THE JOB
WHEN WE DON'T ALWAYS UNDERSTAND
IN GREAT DETAIL EVERY ASPECT. OF
WHAT GOES INTO IT. SO UM, I
CANNOT THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
TAKING THE TIME WELCOME. GOOD
EVENING AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. MY NAME IS
JOSEPH OSORIO AM THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ON BEHALF OF OUR C.
OUR STAFF ARE MEMBERS. WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE NOMINATION, MISS WOZ
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE AND CONTINUING
THE COLLABORATION, NOT JUST WITH
YOU WITH CDCR. UM AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR SERVICE TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OTHER
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. AGAIN
ASSUMING THE FAMILY'S ARE FULL
SUPPORT, SO THEY'RE SMILING. UM
RIGHT. AH OKAY. I WANT TO ALSO
GIVE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE HERE IN
OPPOSITION, AND THAT'S ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT TO GET THAT FEEDBACK.
ANYONE HERE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. UM YOU KNOW, I AM
GOING TO SAY I'VE BEEN ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE MY ENTIRE TIME
IN THE SENATE, WHICH IS SEVEN
YEARS AND I RECALL THE DAYS I
WANT TO THANK HRC. IN
PARTICULAR. THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE PAID
VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO THESE
ISSUES, AND, UH, IN ADDITION TO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
EMPLOYEES AND THE UNION, AND, UM
, THE STAFF WHO COME AND MAKE
THEIR POSITIONS KNOWN. I JUST
WANT TO SAY WHEN I WILL SAY IT
AGAIN WHEN WE HEAR FROM A RC
BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD MOMENTS
WHERE YOU'VE BEEN HERE AND
YOU'VE HAD SOME FEEDBACK THAT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO GET AND I WANT YOU
TO KNOW WE HAVE FOLLOWED UP ON
EVERYTHING WITH AN INCREDIBLE
STAFF OF THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AND UM, WHEN, UM MR FLOOD TALKED
ABOUT ABOUT NORWAY PALS. WE HAD
LEGISLATORS, BUT WE ALSO HAD THE
SECRETARY OF OUR SENATE GO
BECAUSE SHE SITS HERE AND HERE'S
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND TO MY
VICE CHAIR. UM YOU KNOW, UM SHE
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE YOU KNOW
VERY FEW THAT THAT TALKS THE
TALK AND WALK THE WALK AND
SUPPORTS FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE. AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT WORK FOR US VERY
PROUD OF BEING ABLE TO OFFER AN
OPPORTUNITY, AND SHE'S DONE IT
IN HER OWN BUSINESS AS WELL. SO
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A SPECIAL IT'S
GOOD TO AND MR LEWIS, YOU WILL
GET THE SAME WONDERFUL
TREATMENT. I'M SURE BUT BE
PREPARED ON THIS FACILITY
QUESTIONS. BUT HAVING SAID THAT,
UM THIS FEELS GOOD BECAUSE WE
REALLY CARE ABOUT WHAT YOU DO
AND THE CHANGE THAT YOU ARE
MAKING WITHIN THIS SYSTEM, AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO US, SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
ANSWERS TODAY. I APPRECIATE THE
TIME YOU SPENT WITH US, AND I
KNOW THAT WE APPRECIATE REALLY
YOU TAKING THE TIME TO MEET WITH
US? THANK YOU. WHO WANTS TO MAKE
THE MOTION? MADAM VICE CHAIR.
MADAM PROTEIN. IT'S MY HONOR TO
FURTHER NOMINATION OF TIMOTHY
COST TO THE FLOOR FOR FULL
CONFIRMATION. YOU, UM. JUST
BRIEFLY. WE INTERVIEW A LOT OF
APPOINTEES OR A LOT OF COUNTRIES
THAT THE GOVERNOR SENDS TO US.
YOU DID THIS INTERVIEW WITH NO
NOTES. UM WITH HEART WITH
PASSION. UM YOU GET IT AND
YOU'RE DEFINITELY THE RIGHT
PERSON FOR THE JOB, SO I BE
HONORED TO NOMINATE ONE VOTE FOR
YOU FULLY ON THE FLOOR AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM.
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? LAIRD I OWE TUBORG
TROUBLE. GUY SMALLWOOD QUIVER.
QUIVER, PSYCH GROVE GROVE. I
ATKINS INSIDE FIVE TO THINK
FORWARD THIS TO THE FULL SENATE
FOR FULL CONFIRMATION.
CONGRATULATE. RELATIONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME IS
ABSOLUTELY. OKAY GREAT RESPECT
TO MR LEWIS. WE'RE TAKING THREE
MINUTES AND THREE MINUTES ONLY,
AND THIS IS MORE FOR OUR COURT
REPORTER AS OPPOSED TO MY
COLLEAGUES, SO THREE MINUTES AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
AND MR LEWIS, LET ME THANK YOU.
AH SOMEONE HAD TO GO LAST. BUT
I'M THINKING WE SAVED THE BEST
FOR LAST. UM I WANT TO WELCOME
YOU AND AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INCREDIBLE PATIENTS AND
ALSO ASK YOU TO DO THE SAME
THING, WHICH IS TO MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS YOU WANT
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FOLKS YOU WOULD
LIKE TO, AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MANAGER AND
SENATORS. UM I DON'T HAVE ANY
FAMILY WITH ME TODAY. MY WIFE'S
A TEACHER'S. SHE FELT IT WAS
MORE IMPORTANT TO EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN THEN TO COME SIT
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BIT BECAUSE
WE'VE GONE SO LATE. I'M SURE
SHE'S ONLINE WATCHING THIS AT
THIS TIME. SO UM, UH AND MY
CHILDREN ARE ALL ADULTS AND HAVE
THEIR OWN THINGS THAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH. SO UM, INCLUDING
SMALL KIDS SIMILAR TO TAMMY. UM
SO BEFORE WE BEGIN, I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PEOPLE HAVE
SUPPORTED ME THROUGH MY CAREER
WORKING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK MY
FAMILY. FOR ALL THE SUPPORT THEY
HAVE GIVEN ME ALSO WANT TO THANK
GOVERNORS TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
THIS APPOINTMENT AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEPARTMENT FOR
SUPPORTING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEAD FACILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT DIVISION
ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
HARDWORKING STAFF THAT WORK IN
FACILITY PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT. SOMETIMES IT'S A
THANKLESS JOB, AND THEY ASSIST
ME IN TACKLING ALL THE NEEDS OF
THE DEPARTMENT WITH REGARDS TO
FACILITIES. AS WE MOVE FORWARD,
CDCR IS PRIMED TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN
IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MODEL. WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CREATE POSITIVE AND LASTING
CHANGE THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
PEOPLE LIVE AND WORK IN HAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THAT
CHANGE, AND I'M THANKFUL FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO PART
OF THAT CHANGE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. HAVE MET HAVE HAD
TO MEET WITH WILL ONLY ONE OF
YOU THIS TIME, BUT, UH, BUT AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
FOR ME TODAY. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, AND WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT TEACHERS ARE, SO WE
KNOW THAT YOUR SPOUSE IS FULLY
IN SUPPORT OF YOU. UM THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. UM, SENATOR
LAIRD, LET ME START ON THIS END
OF THE DIOCESE AND LET YOU GO
FIRST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
YOU KNOW IN THE LEGISLATURE IF
WE'RE IN A LONG SESSION, AND YOU
WANT TO TAKE UP THE BILL YOU
WANT TO TAKE IT UP JUST BEFORE
EVERYBODY HAS TO LEAVE FOR THE
AIRPORT. SO YOU YOU MIGHT HAVE
ENDED UP GETTING THE BEST. UH
BLAKESPEAR LET ME JUST ASK THE
FOLLOW UP TO THE QUESTION AND
WHERE THE BUCK WAS PASSED TO
YOU, UM, ABOUT THE CLOSING OF
FACILITIES IN THEIR USE. HOW TO
THE BEST OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE. DOES
THAT WORK? UM SO WHEN WE CLOSE
THE FACILITY, WE GENERALLY KEEP
STAFF ON BOARD TO DO WARM
SHUTDOWN ACTIVITIES TO KEEP THE
UTILITIES AND SYSTEMS IN THE
INSTITUTION RUNNING. AND WHILE
THERE'S NO, THERE'S NO
INCARCERATED PEOPLE OUT THOSE
LOCATIONS UM AND THAT CAN BE A
VERY CHALLENGING JOB BECAUSE
IT'S ONLY AS SMALL SKELETON
STUFF THAT DO IT. UM IT'S ALSO
CHALLENGING FROM THE FACT THAT A
LOT OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
DETERIORATED OVER THE YEARS AND
SO MAINTAINING THAT WITH ONLY
THAT SMALL SKILLS, 10 STAFF CAN
BE VERY DIFFICULT. WE HAVE TO
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT OUR ABILITY
TO MAINTAIN THOSE FACILITIES,
THOUGH IN THE LONG TERM, THE
IDEA HAS BEEN IF THERE WAS A
POPULATION SPIKE THAT WE COULD
REACTIVATE, BUT THE REALITY IS
ESPECIALLY WITH SOME OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS YOU
MENTIONED SAN LUIS OBISPO. THOSE
THAT FACILITY THAT WAS CLOSED IS
19 FORTIES WORLD WAR. TWO ARMY,
UM, WOOD FRAME CONSTRUCTION. THE
IDEA THAT WE COULD EVER
REACTIVATE OR REALLY, REALLY
LIKE WE UTILIZE THAT FACILITY IS
PROBABLY NOT REAL ON OUR PART.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT LONG TERM
OPTIONS FOR THAT PROPERTY. ALSO
UNDERSTANDING, THOUGH, THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS TIED TO THE
MAIN FACILITY AND THAT ACTUALLY
IN SIMILAR OBISBO, WE ARE IN
EFFECT UTILITY PROVIDER AS WE
ALSO PROVIDE WATER AND
WASTEWATER SERVICES. TO QUESTION
COLLEGE AND THE NATIONAL GUARD
CAMP THAT IS ALSO LOCATED THERE.
UM AND SO ANY FUTURE USE WILL
HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
FACT THAT WE STILL PROVIDE THAT
THOSE SERVICES TO THAT AND SO
THAT THAT PART OF THE
INSTITUTION AND HOW DO WE CREATE
ABUSE, AND THAT MAKES SENSE.
THAT'S ALSO ON THAT PROPERTY,
THOUGH IT IS ABOUT A MILE AWAY
FROM THE MAIN PART OF THE
INSTITUTION. WE ALSO STILL
HOUSING INCARCERATED PEOPLE AT
IN THAT AREA BECAUSE THE FIRE
CAMPUS TO LOCATED THERE AND THE
MINIMUM SUPPORT FACILITIES, SO
THE LOW LEVEL WORKER IN
INCARCERATED POPULATION IS STILL
LOCATED THERE SO THAT WOULD HAVE
TO ALSO BE DEALT WITH IN THAT
PERIOD, AND THEN MAYBE IT'S LIKE
SO ONE FOLLOW UP RELATED
QUESTION, AND YOU RAISED IT AND
IT'S VERY VERY INTERESTING. AND
THAT IS THAT IT WAS EDUCATIONAL
TO ME TO KNOW THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DO THINGS JOINTLY.
AND SO, FOR EXAMPLE, IN SALINAS
VALLEY PRISON I THINK IT'S THE
CITY OF SOLEDAD HAS HALF THE
WATER SYSTEM AND THE PRISON HAS
HALF THE WATER SYSTEM, AND THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN THE CITY CAME UP
WITH ITS HALF AND THE PRISON
WASN'T COMING UP WITH. I MEAN,
THIS WAS WHEN I WAS A BUDGET
CHAIR BACK WHEN WE HAD REALLY NO
MONEY, ALTHOUGH WE SEEM TO HAVE
RETURNED TO THAT, AND THE SAME
THING IS I MET WITH CAL POLY THE
CITY OF SAN LUIS OBISPO. IN
THEIR WATER PASSES RIGHT BY
THERE, AND THEY'RE SALIVATING AT
THE FACT THAT THERE MIGHT BE A
SAVINGS FROM THE PRISON THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A
LITTLE MORE. HOW DO YOU
NEGOTIATE OR MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
YOU'RE WORKING WITH ADJACENT
COMMUNITIES YOU'RE HELPING THEM
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE QUESTIONS
THAT THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY AND
DISPOSITION OF PROPERTY. I
SHOULD BE CLEAR IS A FUNCTION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AND NOT CDCR. AND SO
FUTURE USE OR DISPOSITION AND
PROPERTY HAS TO BE COORDINATED
WITH MDGS AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE
ADDRESSING THOSE INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES THAT EXIST WOULD NEED TO
BE DEALT WITH. BUT YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE ALSO HAVE JOINT YOU KNOW
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH OTHER
LOCALITIES. UM, AND IT'S
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE THAT CAN BE
WORKED THROUGH IN PARTICULAR,
THOUGH, WITH THE WATER SITUATION
AT IN ST LOUIS OBISPO. WE ALSO
FACED SOME CHALLENGES WITH OUR
WATER RIGHTS. THEY'RE RELATED TO
CONTAMINANTS IN THE WATER,
SPECIFICALLY ARSENIC. AND THAT
WILL HAVE TO BE DEALT WITH
BEFORE YOU COULD REALLY DEAL
WITH THE WATER RIGHTS AS THEY
EXIST, BECAUSE DESPITE THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE WATER RIGHTS
GENERALLY WE DRAW OFF OF THE
STATE WATER INSTEAD BECAUSE OF
THE PARTICULAR ISSUES WITH
ARSENIC REMOVAL IN THAT WATER
SYSTEM AND THE ONE CLOSING
COMMENT IS THAT YES, THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY, BUT
THEY'RE NOT TRIGGERED UNTIL
UNTIL WE ASK YOUR GOING TO WALK
AWAY FROM A UNIT IN TERMS OF
CLOSING IT OR THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE EXPANDING IN A PLACE AND
YES, YOU NEED THE ADDITIONAL
WATER AND SO IT'S JUST IMPORTANT
THAT THAT COORDINATION HAPPENED.
SO APPRECIATE IT. THANKS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. MEN AND VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU. MADAM PRO. TIM
I JUST HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
ON THAT. UM, I KNOW DGS IS THE
ONE WHO FACILITATES ALL THAT IN
THE TRANSITION OR DISPOSITION OF
PROPERTIES. YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THESE PROPERTIES WHERE WE
HAVE PRISON CLOSURES,
ENCLOSURES, AND THERE'S MINIMAL
TO NO STAFF. DO YOU IN YOUR OWN
OPINION, FORESEE OTHER
BENEFICIAL USES SELL THE
PROPERTY DEMOLITION OF THE
PROPERTY? NEW HOUSING NEW. I
MEAN, IS THERE? IS THERE A
BENEFICIAL USE FOR THESE
PROPERTIES? ARE THEY UH, LIKE
OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE, DO
THEY, YOU KNOW IS THERE IS THERE
A BENEFICIAL USE THAT YOU WOULD
SEE THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX FOR
THESE PROPERTIES, EITHER FOR
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH JUST LOST THAT PRISON
WHICH LOST THOSE JOBS, OR I
DON'T KNOW. I DON'T WANT TO SEE
AN AMAZON FACILITY. BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN. IS THERE ANOTHER
BENEFICIAL USE? I MEAN, I THINK
THAT'S A DIFFICULT QUESTION TO
ADDRESS JUST FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF A LOT OF OUR FACILITIES ARE
IN FAIRLY REMOTE LOCATIONS ARE A
CLOSURE FACILITY IN SUSANVILLE.
IT'S A FAIR DISTANCE ABOUT FIVE
OR SIX MILES OUTSIDE OF
SUSANVILLE ITSELF. THERE'S
PLENTY OF AVAILABLE PROPERTY.
THAT SOMEONE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE EXISTING BUILDINGS
AND DEMOLITION OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, AND DEAL WITH THE SHARED
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE EXISTING
INSTITUTION AS WELL THAT MAKE
THOSE MAYBE A LITTLE MORE
DIFFICULT THAN SOME SITUATIONS.
THE FUTURE CLOSURE OF CHUCK
WALLA IN BLACK LIFE IS SIMILAR
IN THAT IT'S ACTUALLY EVEN
FURTHER OUTSIDE OF TOWN. IT'S
ABOUT 25 MILES FROM LIFE. AND SO
IT MAKES IT A LITTLE DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT'S SO REMOTE, AND
THERE'S SO MUCH ACCESSIBLE LAND
BETWEEN THOSE TWO LOCATIONS AND
THAT, YOU KNOW, BENEFICIAL USE
IN THOSE MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DIFFICULT, BUT WE ALSO HAVE
CLOSING D. J J FACILITIES ARE
CLOSED DJ FACILITIES DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE THAT IN A
LITTLE BIT MORE URBAN LOCATIONS.
SO SINCE I'VE TAKEN THIS JOB WE
HAVE DECLARED THE STARK
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY AND
SURPLUS. WE'VE SENT THAT LETTER
TO DGS SO THAT COULD BE SOLD
POTENTIALLY. THE DGS JUST
FINISHED TRYING TO SELL PRESTON
AND I OWN DIDN'T HAVE MANY
INTERESTED PARTIES. EVEN THOUGH
THE PRICE WAS FAIRLY GOOD
BECAUSE OF THE NEED TO DO TO
DEAL WITH EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHICH DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF ALTERNATIVE USES.
UNFORTUNATELY YOU KNOW, IT'S
HARD TO FIND ALTERNATIVE USES
FOR A CELLED HOUSING OR THAT
KIND OF THING. I MEAN, THAT'S
JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT LENDS
ITSELF SO AND LARGE LAND USE
IDEA OF LIKE AN AMAZON, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT'S DIFFICULT TO DO
BECAUSE OF THE NEED TO CLEAR THE
LAND. AND WHEN THERE'S
PLENTIFUL, AVAILABLE LAND IN
THAT AREA THAT I THINK THEY
WOULD TEND TO AVOID SOME OF
OURS. BUT WE HAVE DEALT WITH IN
SOME PLACES AT THE COVER ANY
INSTITUTION FOR MEN, FOR EXAMPLE
, WE HAVE A LARGE PROPERTY THERE
WHEN? IN CHINO AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, MORE LAND ISN'T
READILY AVAILABLE, AND WE HAVE
DONE YOU KNOW, GROUND LEASES
WITH WALMART AND OTHER AREAS SO
THAT THEY COULD BUILD ON THAT
PROPERTY WHERE IT'S APPROPRIATE.
AND SO IN SOME OF THOSE
LOCATIONS, I THINK THERE'S MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BENEFICIAL USE,
AND BUT ON THE OTHER HAND IT
IT'S NOT AS IMPACTFUL TO THE
COMMUNITY AS IT WOULD BE, AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN SOMEWHERE LIKE
BLITHE OR SUSAN VILLE, WHICH IS
MUCH MORE DEVASTATED BY A
CLOSURE THAN SOME OF THESE URBAN
LOCATIONS, OKAY, THANK YOU. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID THEIR
LAND USE LEASES. SO THE STATE IS
RECEIVING REVENUE ON THOSE
LEASES, WHICH HELPS OFFSET SOME
OF THE EXPENSES THAT WE HAVE AS
A STATE, AND I THINK THAT'S OUT
OF THE BOX THINKING INSTEAD OF
JUST LETTING THE PROPERTY SIT
IDLE, BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMMENTS. THANK YOU, MADAM.
VICE CHAIR, SENATOR ROBACH.
MADRID QUESTIONS WERE ADDRESSED
THAT I WAS GOING TO, UM, WE
DISCUSSED ACTUALLY IN OUR
MEETING, BUT I DID HAVE TO JUST
A QUICK QUESTION HERE WITH
REGARDS TO FREEDOM, YOUNG
UNIVERSITY PRO VERT OR IDAHO?
YEAH. YOUR SCHOOLING. I WENT TO
BRIGHAM YOUNG UNIVERSITY IN UTAH
. I ALSO MY WIFE, MY PARENTS AND
THREE OF MY FOUR CHILDREN HAVE
GONE TO BYU. MY YOUNGEST IS A
SENIOR THIS YEAR, SO I'LL
FINALLY BE DONE PAYING FOR
COLLEGE AFTER THE PAST 13 YEARS
OF PAYING FOR EDUCATION FOR MY
CHILDREN. AND SO, YES, UM AND
ALSO BY THE WAY MY GREAT
GRANDPARENTS AND WENT TO BYU
WHEN IT WAS BRIGHAM YOUNG
ACADEMY, ACTUALLY. SO MY FATHER
IN LAW AND MY DAUGHTER ACTUALLY
JUST FINISHED AT BYU IN PROVO.
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO ASK HIM
DECEMBER SO AH! AND I HAVE A
SECOND ONE THERE AND HOPEFULLY A
THIRD ONE COMING UP NEXT YEAR.
KEEPING MY FINGERS CROSSED,
RIGHT? I JUST I JUST NOTICED
THAT I CAN'T BELIEVE I MISSED
THAT. ENTERING OUR INTERVIEW. UM
BUT I THINK WE ARE. I THINK
THEY'VE ADDRESSED THE QUESTIONS
THAT I HAD WITH REGARDS TO THE
FACILITIES AND HOW THEY COULD BE
REUSED. THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS THAT WE HAD. AND
I JUST LEARNED TODAY THAT WE
PERHAPS CAN'T USE THEM FOR, UM
WE DON'T KNOW YET. WE'RE GONNA
LOOK INTO THAT. BUT FOR WORK
OPPORTUNITY SITES, SO, BUT
THAT'S THAT'S ALL I HAVE. TODAY.
THIS IS THE TIME CELL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. I THINK SENATOR LAIRD
WAS CORRECT WHEN HE MADE HIS
OPENING COMMENTS, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THANK YOU, AND
I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF, I GUESS
GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA PLAN AND
ALL OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WERE HAD RIGHT BEFORE. YOU'RE
HEARING IN TERMS OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES OF FACILITIES AND
HOW IMPORTANT A ROLE THAT WILL
PLAY IN TERMS OF EXPANDING
REHABILITATION SERVICES. WHAT IS
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACE NOW, TOO? CREATING MORE
EDUCATIONAL FACILITY SO WE CAN
TAKE THE 10. THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS WHO ARE ON WAITING
LISTS WHO ARE DESPERATELY
WANTING TO ACCESS THESE SKILLS
AND PROGRAM. YEAH. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOME OUTSIDE THE BOX THINKING IN
THIS REGARD OF NOT VIEWING
PROGRAMS AS EXCLUSIVELY NEEDING
CLASSROOMS AND ALSO BEING MUCH
MORE FLAX, FLEXIBLE IN OUR USE
OF CLASSROOMS ARE YOU KNOW
MASSIVE PROJECT? WE'RE WORKING
ON IT. SAINT QUENTIN, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND ONE OF THE MAIN
IDEAS THAT WE'RE APPROACHING,
THERE IS FLEXIBLE USE OF
CLASSROOMS TO THE CLASSROOMS ARE
USED ALL THE TIME, NOT JUST
DURING THE CORE PROGRAMMING
PERIOD. I THINK UNDERSECRETARY
FOSS ADDRESSED THE FACT THAT WE
USE PRETTY MUCH ALL AVAILABLE
SPACES TO TRY AND PROVIDE
PROGRAM VISITING THE GYMS AND
OTHER SPACES CHAPELS TO TRY AND
LEVERAGE SPACE TO CREATE
PROGRAMS. IT'S JUST OUR
INSTITUTIONS WERE NOT BUILT WITH
THAT IN MIND, AND THEY WERE
BUILT VERY MUCH IN A PERIOD WHEN
PUNISHMENT WAS SEEN AS THE
PRIMARY DRIVER OF CORRECTIONAL
NEED AND THE FACILITIES TO SOME
DEGREE REPRESENT THAT, UM AND SO
, BUT WE CAN DO SOME OUTSIDE THE
BOX THINKING YOU MENTIONED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. FOR
EXAMPLE, UNDER MY UNDER MFP CM.
WE HAVE, UM. MB AWARD LABOR
PROGRAM. I MEAN, WE ARE STARTING
TO IMPLEMENT A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THAT IN OUR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS INTERNALLY IN THE
DEPARTMENT, SO THAT HOPEFULLY
WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED, THEY'VE
FULFILLED ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM AND CAN MOVE INTO FULL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WITH THE
VARIOUS UNIONS. WE HOPE TO START
THAT AT CMF WITHIN THE NET FOR
NEXT SHORT, LITTLE WHILE WE'VE
ALREADY FOUND IT INSTRUCTOR TO
BEGIN THAT PROCESS. MEN AND I
HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH OTHER
LABOR UNIONS THAT ARE ALSO
INTERESTED IN THOSE KINDS OF
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL. SO WE CAN
BEGIN TO ROLL THOSE OUT. I THINK
IT'S PRETTY KEY TO CONTINUING
ROBUST PROGRAM IN THAT REGARD
THAT IT'S NOT SEEN AS JUST A
CHEAP LABOR PROGRAM THAT IT'S
SEEN AS A FULL REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAM. AND CREATING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES WILL GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY WHERE IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE A LARGE AMOUNT OF
CLASSROOM SPACE, AND THE
CLASSROOM AND ACTIVITIES ARE A
SMALL PART OF THE PROGRAM AND
GIVE PEOPLE PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE
AT THE SAME TIME, AND I KNOW
PELICAN BAY. EVERYONE TALKS
ABOUT ALL OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE HAPPENING THERE IS HOW DO
YOU LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
FACILITIES? AND IS THERE SORT OF
. A GRADING PROCESS BY WHICH YOU
KNOW YOU LOOK AT FACILITIES AND
THINK, OKAY, THIS IS WHERE WE
CAN EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
EDUCATIONAL OFFERINGS BASED ON
THE FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE. UM
I KNOW THE WOMEN'S PRISON LIFTED
UP HAVING VERY FEW, UH
OPPORTUNITIES, PARTICULARLY
AROUND CONSTRUCTION TRADES. I
THINK WOODWORKING IS THE ONE
SORT OF TRADE THAT EXISTS THERE,
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS IS THERE HOW
DO YOU DETERMINE WHERE WILL ALL
THINK THAT MADAM PRESIDENT SAID
THIS EARLIER ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT ALL FACILITIES HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE PROGRAMS. HOW DO YOU
GRADE THAT IS THERE? WHAT IS THE
PLAN FOR THAT? AND WHEN DO YOU
SEE THAT PLAN BEING SHARED WITH
US TO KIND OF BE ABLE TO TRACK
HOW THESE PROGRAMS ARE ROLLING
OUT AND WHERE THEY'LL ROLL OUT.
UM I MEAN, I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY LARGELY SOMETHING
THAT'S BEST ADDRESSED BY THE
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS, YOU KNOW, WERE SYSTEM
WHEREVER WE CAN AND HELPING THEM
FIND SPACE. I KNOW THIS, FOR
EXAMPLE, THIS WEEK OR THEY WERE
PLANNING ON BEING AT SAN QUENTIN
. AND EVEN THOUGH WE'RE BUILDING
A LARGE BUILDING THERE WHERE
THERE IS STILL NEED TO EXPAND
OTHER PROGRAMS, ESPECIALLY
AROUND TECHNICAL EDUCATION THAT
WON'T BE INCLUDED IN THE NEW
SPACE THAT WE'RE BUILDING, SO IN
ORDER TO DO THAT WE HAVE TO
IDENTIFY SPACE WHERE WE CAN LOOK
AT SOMETHING THAT MAYBE WE HAD A
PREVIOUS USE. UM, AND DO THAT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, YOU
KNOW, ANY PROJECT THAT WOULD
REQUIRE FUNDING WOULD REQUIRE,
YOU KNOW AS TO COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ASK FOR THAT
MONEY. AND THERE'S PROBABLY A
LARGE NEED FOR THAT. AND AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE AND AS A
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE TO SIT DOWN
AND REALLY GO THROUGH A THOROUGH
PLANNING PROCESS OF DETERMINING
AND THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS HAS BEEN
VERY EFFECTIVE. YOU KNOW, I WAS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FISCAL
SERVICES FOR CDCR BACK WHEN WE
WENT THROUGH THE RECESSION, AND
WE ESSENTIALLY GUTTED ALL OF OUR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AT THAT
POINT, JUST FROM A FUNDING
FUNDING. STANDPOINT. BUT IT WAS
A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY COMING OUT
OF THAT TO IDENTIFY PROGRAMS
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE AND EVIDENCE
BASED AS OPPOSED TO, THEY JUST
EXISTED BECAUSE THEY HAD EXISTED
FOR MANY YEARS. YOU KNOW, FOR
EXAMPLE, PREVIOUSLY, ALMOST
EVERY PRISON HAD A DRY CLEANING
PROGRAM. THERE'S VERY FEW JOBS
AVAILABLE FOR DRY CLEANING, AND
THAT WAS MORE OF A STAFF SERVICE
THAN ANYTHING. SO WHY ARE WE
PAYING TO HAVE A DRY CLEANING
PROGRAM WHEN THAT IS NOT GOING
TO RESULT IN JOBS, WHEREAS I
THINK NOW THEY HAVE A VERY
RIGOROUS PROCESS TO DETERMINE
WHERE PROGRAM ACTUALLY PROVIDES
SOME OPPORTUNITY FOR EMPLOYMENT
ON THE OUTSIDE, AND WE JUST NEED
TO CONTINUE TO LEVERAGE THAT
PROCESS AND WHEREVER WE FIND
OPPORTUNITIES, AND FIND WAYS TO
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM AND IF SPACE
BECOMES A BARRIER AND FIND THE
EASIEST AND SIMPLEST WAY TO
ADDRESS THAT, AND THAT CAN BE
DONE THROUGH SCHEDULING, FOR
EXAMPLE, IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
ALWAYS BE NEW SPACE. SOMETIMES
IT'S SCHEDULING EFFECTIVELY SO
THAT YOU CONTINUOUSLY USE THAT
SPACE, SO IT'S NOT ONLY USED FOR
THREE OR FOUR HOURS A DAY WHEN
THE PROGRAM THAT WAS IN THERE IS
IN THERE YOU WE HAVE PLENTY OF
EVENING PROGRAMS, A LOT OF
COLLEGE PROGRAMS. AND PROVIDING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION THAT MAY
HAVE A JOB DURING THE DAY BUT
STILL WANTS TO TAKE PARTICIPATE
IN PROGRAMS. IT SHOULDN'T BE
EITHER OR OPPORTUNITY. WE SHOULD
HAVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
WHEN THEY ARE AVAILABLE. SO
YOU'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AND
SORT OF IDENTIFYING THOSE UP
FACILITY OPPORTUNITIES AND
PROGRAM OPPORTUNITIES TOGETHER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU DO
I KNOW THAT WE GET INTO THE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND THE
YOU KNOW FACILITIES ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. ONE OF THE
FIRST MEETINGS I HAD WITH SOME
FOLKS FROM CDCR WAS ABOUT THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND THE
CRITICAL NOUS OF YOU KNOW, YOU
CAN HAVE A LOT OF PROGRAMS AND
WE NEED THEM AND THEY'RE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL. BUT
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE DECENT SPACES
FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE. THEY'VE GOT
TO, YOU KNOW, THE RAIN DRIPPING
IN AND ALL OF THAT STUFF. I
MEAN, I HEARD THE HORROR STORIES
AND I'M SURE YOU ARE STILL
DEALING WITH TRYING TO CATCH UP
ON ALL OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. WE NEVER GET ENOUGH
MONEY PUT TOWARDS REALLY FIXING
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. HOW YOU'VE
BEEN IN THIS A YEAR. I THINK YOU
WERE APPOINTED ALMOST A YEAR IN
FEBRUARY. HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE MOST PRESSING
NEEDS ARE MET? I'M SURE IT IS
SORT OF CHASING YOUR YOUR TAIL
TO USE A PHRASE, UM, MUCH AND
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING READY TO DO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MODEL AND THE
CREATING THE SPACES. IT'S SAN
QUENTIN. YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND OF
TWO DIFFERENT WORLDS TO LIVE IN.
HOW DO YOU BALANCE THOSE
PRIORITIES? AND THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND ONE THAT'S BEEN MY
LIFE FOR THE LAST YEAR, UM IT'S
DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU KNOW, THE
DEPARTMENT HAS A HUGE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEED, AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE HAD TWO
MAJOR POWER OUTAGES IN THE LAST
FOUR MONTHS WHERE IT'S
ESSENTIALLY SHUT DOWN POWER TO
THE ENTIRE INSTITUTION ONE AT
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY IN CHOWCHILLA AND ONE
OF THE RICHARD J. DONOVAN
FACILITY IN SAN DIEGO, AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAPPENS. IS
IF YOU LEAVE ALL MAINTENANCE
DECISIONS TO THE LOCALS, LOCAL
INSTITUTION THEY'RE GOING TO BE
VERY FOCUSED ON WHAT'S DIRECTLY
IN FRONT OF THEM TODAY, AND
MAYBE NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO KIND OF THE
POTENTIAL CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT COULD FAIL
POWER, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU KNOW,
GOING OUT IN BOTH THOSE CASES.
WHAT WELL IN THE CASE OF R. J.
DONOVAN UM, UNFORTUNATELY IN
LOOKING INTO THE ISSUE IN THE
PAST, THEY HAD A REPORT THAT
INDICATED THAT WHAT FAILED WAS A
PROBLEM ABOUT TWO YEARS PRIOR TO
WHEN IT HAPPENED, AND IT WAS AN
ADDRESS BECAUSE THE INSTITUTION
IT COULD HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED FOR
$50,000. INSTEAD WE'RE GONNA END
UP SPENDING $2 MILLION
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM. SO I
THINK TAKING SOME OF THOSE MORE
STRATEGIC LOOKS, YOU KNOW AN
INSTITUTION WHEN THEY LOOK OUT
DOING AN ELECTRICAL SURVEY, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND THEY LOOK AT
SPENDING $70,000 ON THAT THEY
CAN SPEND $70,000 ON THAT, OR
$70,000 ON A PROBLEM THAT THEY
KNOW THEY HAVE TODAY. THEY'RE
GOING TO SPEND IT ON THE PROBLEM
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TODAY. AND
THAT'S THE RIGHT DECISION FOR
THEM, BUT MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR THE DEPARTMENT. AND
SO WE'RE TAKING SOME OF THOSE
LIKE REALLY CRITICAL AND WE'RE
GOING TO START DIRECTING THAT AS
AN ACTIVITY AT OUR LEVEL INSTEAD
, INSTEAD OF LEAVING IT TO THE
PERSON WHO THEY'VE GOT TO MAKE
DAILY DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY
FIX AND DON'T FIX IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN PRETTY POOR
CONDITION. AND START TO REALLY
PLAN FOR THAT AS AS A MORE
STRATEGIC RESOURCE SO THAT WE
DON'T LOSE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE COULD HAVE IDENTIFIED AND
FIXED PRIOR TO HAVING A LARGE
AND IT CAN STILL TURN OUT TO PAY
OFF IN THE END BECAUSE WE WON'T
HAVE THOSE THOSE CRITICAL
FAILURES AND THAT ENDED UP
COSTING A LOT OF MONEY FOR
GENERATOR RENTAL. AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES. SO REALLY TAKING A
HARD LOOK AT THAT AND
IDENTIFYING AND PRIORITIZING
FROM OVERALL AND WHAT HAS THE
BIGGEST RISK FOR THE DEPARTMENT,
AS OPPOSED TO WHAT IS THE MOST
READY TO GO FORWARD? I THINK
PREVIOUSLY WE WERE BECAUSE WE
GOT A SOMEWHAT OF AN INFLUX OF
MONEY. WE WERE MORE FOCUSED ON
AGAIN SIMILAR TO THE
INSTITUTIONS. WHAT'S RIGHT IN
FRONT OF US WHAT'S READY TO GO
WHEN, INSTEAD IT SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT FROM A VERY MUCH
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
STANDPOINT, BUT THE MONEY IS
LIMITED. AND SO YOU KNOW, AT
SOME LEVEL YOU YOU'RE ALWAYS
KIND OF LOOKING AT PUTTING BAND
AIDS ON A PROBLEM, BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T PROVIDE
BETTER DIRECTION ON WHERE THOSE
BAND AIDS GET APPLIED. WOW.
THANK YOU. THAT WAS A REALLY I
APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE BECAUSE
I THINK YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
TO BALANCE IT. AND I'M REALLY
HAPPY TO HEAR YOU'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT THAT FROM A HIGHER LEVEL
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO DO WHAT
THEY'VE GOT TO DO IN THE MOMENT
AND SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. GIVEN THE LACK OF
RESOURCES, AND YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR A WHILE. YOU'VE DONE
BUDGET WORK. YOU'VE BEEN IN THE
SENATE YOU YOU'VE GOT
EXPERIENCE. KIND OF AND YOU
NEVER CAN YOU NEVER GET TO TALK
ABOUT THIS ONE WITH FRUSTRATING
THINGS. WHEN I GOT HERE, YOU
NEVER GET TO TALK ABOUT THE
MONEY YOU WOULD SAVE IF YOU DID
THIS NOW, SO I THINK THE R J.
DONOVAN EXAMPLE IS A REALLY GOOD
ONE BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING WITH
THAT ON OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS, NOT EVEN RELATED TO
CDCR. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
APPROACH. AND I WISH YOU THE
BEST. BECAUSE YOU REALLY ARE
GONNA BE TRYING TO GET RESOURCES
TO FIX SO MANY PROBLEMS. I KNOW
UM WELL, THANK YOU. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO HAVE WAITED PATIENTLY
AND ARE STILL HERE AND WE
APPRECIATE IT. AND I'M SURE MR
LEWIS APPRECIATES IT. ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU COME FORWARD.
OKAY AND I WILL OFFER THAT SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND
SEEING NO ONE. I WILL SAY
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT AT THIS
HOUR OF THE DAY, AND I SEE MY
VICE CHAIR. EVEN NOW THAT MY
PERIPHERAL VISION HITTING HER
MIKE MADAM VICE CHAIR MOTION TO
MOVE THE COUNTRY FORWARD. THANK
YOU. MADAM SECRETARY, WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? LAIRD
PHOTOVOGUE TROUBLE GUYS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. I WOULD
QUIBBLE SIDE GROVE GROVE. I CAN
FIND DEFECTS. CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE, AND
WE WILL FORWARD THIS TO THE FULL
SENATE FOR CONFIRMATION AND
CONGRATULATIONS. WE WILL PREPARE
FOR EXECUTIVE SESSION AND, UM,
FULL DISCLOSURE OR POINT OF
ORDER, I GUESS POINT OF PERFECT
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE, MAN AND VICE
CHAIR. YES, THANK YOU. WE SIT
DOWN THROUGH THE MICROPHONE. I
GUESS THIS IS SENATE-ROOM TEAMS
INTEREST. I DID NOT WANT TO DO
THIS. AND THIS IS A SENATE PRO
TIM'S LAST RULES HEARING AS OUR
CHAIR. AND UM, I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. WE BOTH CAME IN
TOGETHER IN 2010 AND THEN
SERVING IN THE SENATE. SHE GOT
HERE A COUPLE OF YEARS EARLIER
THAN I DID AND THEN SERVING IN
LEADERSHIP. UM MANY PEOPLE IN
THIS BUILDING AND AROUND THIS
STATE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
FRIENDSHIP THAT WE HAVE, THEY
HAVEN'T THEY LOOK AT BOTH OF US
AND SAY, HOW IS THAT EVEN
POSSIBLE? UM POLITICALLY. WE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT WITH LIFE
EXPERIENCES, BOTH GROWING UP
POOR BOTH KNOWING THAT OUR MAMAS
TAUGHT US THE GRIT AND HOW TO BE
DETERMINED WOMEN AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. UM I THINK THAT
SPEAKS VOLUMES. I ALSO KNOW THAT
SHE IS AN INCREDIBLE LEADER. WE
DON'T ALWAYS AGREE, BUT I KNOW
THAT SHE EMPOWERS HER PEOPLE
THAT WORK FOR HER. SHE'S DEEPLY
RESPECTED BY NOT ONLY HER STAFF,
BUT EVERY MEMBER OF THIS BODY.
AND, UM SHE HAS INTEGRITY. SHE'S
TRUSTWORTHY. SHE'S TRUTHFUL, AND
I HAVE THE DEEPEST RESPECT FOR
MY FRIEND. AND I WANT THIS WILL
SOUND STRANGE. I HOPE PEOPLE GET
IT. TONI ATKINS IS A INDIVIDUAL
WHO RULES. WITH A SERVANT'S
HEART AND LEADS LIKE A KING. AND
WE JUST HAVE THESE FLOWERS FOR
YOU. AND I WANT TO GIVE YOU THIS
ON BEHALF OF EVERYTHING
BEAUTIFUL. EVERYBODY HERE. YEAH.
WOW. THESE ARE GORGEOUS. BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT BALANCED. OKAY. SORRY,
PHOTOGRAPHER MOMENT. MORE
SECONDS.
OLD JOB FOR US, AND I APPRECIATE
YOU EACH AND EVERY COMMITTEE
MEETING AND SESSION. THANK YOU.
OKAY? YOU WILL TELL ME WHEN WE
ARE. THANK YOU.